[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
pops
foreign
[Music]
four players have to show their best
chest in the elimination bracket two
will be knocked out it is high stakes
matches at the decibel Masters today and
the action Starts Now
[Music]
how on Earth have you save this position
well Magnus just widening his eyes
they're shocked by this last decision he
is showing no fear whatsoever
a winner
[Music]
this is Magnus carlsen's last tournament
as world champion and he is in the
elimination bracket it will be a
dramatic day of Chess and we'll make
sure you don't miss any of the action
we'll be calling it all out from our
studio Grand Master David Howell
that's a James Conti we here
Grandmaster Robin Hess
David what a roller coaster they want
that was was that the most intense day
one of the tour ever it might be the
most dramatic day of Chess I've ever
seen and uh yeah it had everything
really it had big upsets Magnus Carlson
falling to defeat it had time scrambles
Armageddon and yeah I'm just hoping for
more of the same today Tanya
we had three armor Gardens that very
well could have been for what a day of
Chess James what was the big highlight
for you well of course Magnus losing
he's in the losers bracket Magnuson
loser is not in the same sentence you
know what I mean right so that was a
huge upset there but also artemia is
playing out of his mind right now
probably play good too as well and of
course we got a lot of other checks
coming up today so day two is gonna be
crazy yeah yeah can't wait we got a
taste of what a monstrous lineup it is
at the chessable Masters Robert you call
it artfest that we will not be seeing a
Magnus Hikaru Final in this one are you
sticking to that prediction I absolutely
am Magnus lost Hikaru was fortunate not
to lose so I feel like what we've seen
from day one is in this 2750 average
field not a single player is scared of
the magnuses or their cars and they may
be taken down
mama so much
Axel getting over it here's what
happened
he's just taking too much time Vlad
still in a big Think Tank whoa what is
that oh he about to take on uh he's
gonna take that yeah he's training
is nice it's time to go he walked into a
pin and I told you float like a
butterfly State and that one stings
because Magnus he moves again and had
the white pieces the booth that hurts
Magnus Carlton resigns could be
dangerous like H5 H4 check and oh my God
oh my goodness what happened H2 he's
coming he's just the bishop he goes back
push
response oh
just last
is he getting checkmated look at that
white king my goodness it's fighting
against a black Rook a black knight a
black king and if it's not Checkmate hey
karu's gonna win so the evaluation Bar
says yes but where is The Knockout blue
he's winning again unbelievable this is
an unbelievable streak I've never seen
anything like this from any player on
the planet to be able to beat Hikaru in
all of these games look at him he's he's
frustrated he's angry everything under
control easy win now for FedEx but we've
got to commend him it looked so messy he
kept a calm head and uh Hikaru is just
not at his best today storm is away I
won't be surprised if that kind of
meeting that occurs here it's that
straightforward White's piece is not in
position to stop that Checkmate and a
car has played perfect chess you call
that it's tutu we're heading to
Armageddon
he needs to win a nine seconds oh he's
not going to he's not got any any time
just oh now there's gonna be checkmates
did he find it
[Music]
[Applause]
will not die he takes down the world
champion wow that was sick
so many twists sentence ended in a
Checkmate in the Armageddon for the
world champion and after a difficult day
Magnus graciously agreed to give us an
interview this is how he summed it up
it was a pretty
pretty uh bad
um
uh he generally you know uh played me in
the the third game
um first was yeah just
barrage of blender's ready but I mean
the last game was was terrible this was
a really really awful day of uh chess
um like I did everything to lose and
then some uh obviously you know it takes
a strong opponent to to exploit that but
that was really pretty poor so we'll see
I'll um
um do my best tomorrow but this yeah
this is unacceptable
wow a tough day there for Magnus Carlsen
he is in the elimination bracket on day
one it just looked like artemia was the
better player this is a bracket going
into day two of the adjustable Masters
David the Shocker has to be to see
Magnus Carlsen in the losers bracket
what is his mindset coming in today well
Magnus has to do something different he
also needs to start faster yesterday he
started with a loss with the white
pieces and his day just didn't get
better from there uh Magnus whether it's
a change of openings whether it's a
change of strategy he needs that far
start today yeah he sounded really angry
with himself in that interview very
upset with the way he played and to
cheer himself up one would expect he'd
be studying openings looking at some
more chess but that wasn't the case
instead Magnus is out skiing hope this
prep works better today Robert I'm gonna
call this the Avalanche opening a
trademark it right now I don't know if
that's a thing that's the Avalanche I
think he's gonna come and swing because
he's upset after yesterday's debacle
yeah I love it next course on chessable
by Robert Hess the Avalanche opening
James was day one a big wake-up call for
the big names yeah definitely a big
wake-up call of course that Nakamura
almost went down so this is like hey
wake up if you want to win you need to
win and you need to win cleanly of
course don't let this happen again
Magnus of course being a loser's bracket
he needs to of course clear his head
like he did when he was at the you know
playing the Avalanche opening out there
right so he's uh clearing his head and
coming back hopefully stronger today to
beat Liam yeah he needs all the fresh
air two come fresh for this big game
against Liam today is a lot at stake two
players it will be the end of the road
for two players they will be knocked out
it is a brutal format the players are
fighting to win The chessable Masters
they're fighting for tour points and of
course the big ticket in to the CCD
final so much on the line This is the
biggest ever season of the Champions
Chester
the 2023 Champions chess tour is the
biggest tour yet with a thrilling brand
new format and two million dollars in
prizes it's the richest online
tournament of all time
the tour begins with six elite events
taking place between February and
September
each event features an open
qualification system with qualifiers and
plans locking in 56 players to the main
events
there players are grouped into three
divisions and compete for 235 thousand
dollars in prizes each time
victory in division one in any of the
six events secures a spot directly to
the eight player Champions chess tour
playoffs in December
players will also accumulate toward
leaderboard points across the six events
competing for another one hundred
thousand dollars in prize money and the
unsecured playoff spots will go directly
to the top leaderboard finishers at the
end of the year we have two weeks of
incredible chess beginning with the
playoffs from which just four players
will advance to the Champions chess tour
finals to a single elimination bracket
which will ultimately determine our
champion
together the playoffs and finals feature
a whopping 500 thousand dollars in
prizes
there could only be one
in December of 2023 an Undisputed tour
Champion will be crowned
let the games begin
five hundred thousand dollars
things are critical yeah it's not all
about the money they say It's All About
the Benjamins but here the tour points
mean a lot because six players may make
their way through based on winning
division one that leaves at minimum two
spots up to Four Points yeah
it's not just door points on stake in
division one but in the other divisions
well the players are fighting for a
qualification spot into the next
Champions chess store as well as those
critical top points there we see Robert
not about Abdul satrov and Vladimir
kramnik had big wins on day one and
we've got some spicy matchups today
keeps up his winning ways the 14th World
Champion he's doing great he loves this
rapid time Patrol but the two people I'm
gonna single out are Dennis lazovic and
Maxime vascher lagrove then last as he's
known on chess.com he's a teenager from
Belarus Maxima Sheila grab the former
World Blitz Champion they won day one
Dennis lesbian taking out dubov they're
not stopping here in day two wow I'm
looking at this Vladimir kramnik the
14th World Champion Maxine Russell the
2021 blitzwolf Champion not the back of
the satro the youngest ever rapid world
champion was that really division two we
were looking at Robert how strong it is
it's no easy opponents no matter where
you look yeah I love it it's not just
division two check out the names in
division three and the action that
that today shock for your mama jorov he
is a super Grandmaster amongst the
world's Elite for nearly two decades
he's on his back foot against the means
having to buy but there's also the FFL
the famous fun Legend got akovsky he's
having a lot of fun in division three
here at the chessel Masters he's taking
on super Grandmaster way Yi so it's
tough sledding out there for the
American GM but he's hanging right in
the thick of things
famous fun Legend I love how you
know Robert of course we will be keeping
an eye out on division two and three but
it is a focus on division one the big
elimination bracket how important will
it be for Liam to get his kind of
openings Robert it's essential because
it gets Magnus Carlson you don't want to
be out playing you need to get an edge
out of the early stage of the game yeah
he needs to keep that clock on the check
and get the kinds of positions that he
likes to play that is going to be the
task for Liam and David gives us a
little sneak peek into Liam Lee's style
of play
Liam Lee is one of the classiest players
on the circuit the Vietnamese
Grandmaster is now resident in St Louis
where he works as a coach for the very
strong Webster University team some of
those players also help Infuse him with
new opening ideas Liam is a solid player
but he can be creative when given the
opportunity with white he often starts
with the Catalan opening maybe the
London system and he often gets very
decent advantages even against the best
players in the world with black very
solid with one E5 and the Queen's Gambit
declined the Staples of his repertoire
this is one example of his use of the
London system where he beat me a few
years ago this game took place in the
2017 World Blitz championship in this
position he shocked me with an extremely
strong move where I push the pawn to D5
cramping down on the black position and
this is a dream London system for white
White's Bishop's a fantastically placed
white has more space and black simply
has no plan he went on to smoothly
outplay me watch out for Liam in this
tournament he he might be one of The
Underdogs but he can beat anyone on his
day
[Music]
wow David that was a really fun great
video there yeah what can I say Liam is
a superstar in his own right and uh yeah
it was an honor to be able to to pay
that off wow well he does have big task
ahead of him as in our losers bracket he
will be facing Magnus Carlsen with the
other matchup Vladimir photos you have
taken on Labon aronian James both these
players could very well have been in the
Winner's bracket today absolutely of
course you have big fish which is fair
to say if he's doing big things and he
almost took down Nakamura which is
absolutely insane of course in that last
match I've owned in the last five or six
games in the title Tuesday was crazy
that you know a better state was able to
win he almost took down Nakamura again
and then we got LeBron aronia here who
just does his thing he's a veteran
creative very attacking player that's
going to be a heavyweight matchup for
sure
is the
news on his match against Wesley so
drawing first blood but eventually went
down to lose against Wesley Wesley
making it through to the winners bracket
there for the semi-finals will be facing
Hikaru Nakamura that's a matchup that
we've seen so many times in the
Champions Chester and we've got
vladislav our Tamia taking on Fabiano
caruana and I have to say Robert both
are tamiyav and Fabi they convincingly
won their matches yesterday even though
it was the Armageddon yeah it went down
to the wire but they did have the upper
hand it felt like and that's a lot
because artemio was playing Carlson but
Fabiano that's another tough opponent
for him it's toss-up
absolutely it wasn't just the scoreline
but also the style of play and the
dominating performance by these players
in the semi-finals bracket but we will
be starting the day with our losers
bracket the elimination bracket and the
big difference in this one is that there
are only two games there is no margin
forever error there's no time to come
back both players get only one white so
you've got to go all out you've got to
make the most of those whites they will
be playing with 15 minutes and a three
second increment in case there's a tie
we will once again head over to the
Armageddon wow it's going to be a fun
day David yeah it's going to be a fun
day and I can't wait to get started I
think those players in the elimination
bracket they're just getting ready
making those last minute preparations
and then we see empty Chair by Magnus
Carlson I saw something in the
background I think he's there at least
uh ready still he's not skiing right now
I hope he's back from
up in those mountains
wow we're waiting for Magnus Carlsen and
Liam Lee is ready to go what are the
openings that we're expecting here
Robert well I think David summarizes
quite well from when Liam lay especially
as the white side but from magnets you
never know what to expect I can't even
tell you his first move I have no clue
could be one of 20 Robert I'll tell you
that 20 possible first moves he's played
them all at some point in his career
Knight of three let's make a catalog
another three James I'll say D4 Robert I
have to go into E4 then I'm picking C4
okay
we've got it all covered what if he
plays one B3 oh wow
okay hey man what's the lottery ticket
you'll force my hand you know you took
all the other options so I just went
with the King's Pawn Best Buy test hey
okay and the King's Pawn is met by a
sicilian from Liam lay he does have more
solid yeah
let me get this grub real quick all
right it's my move oh my bad long day of
skiing he needs the energy he needs to
replenish his uh his reserves that hold
on I got you bro let's give you a time
spot
really that's how it is especially of
even Carlson being uh up minigame bro
he's smashing he is smashing his food
right now we don't care nothing about
this game he's like I got this in the
bag right of course the record actually
I mean he's up a lot of games against
Liam so I guess he's very comfortable
right now yeah I think they're head to
head in Rapid chest at least is 14 wins
for Magnus and three fullium so quite
one-sided but uh yeah Liam does have a
score to settle you just playing the
waiting game right now that must be good
what you eating
put it in the chat what do you think
Carlson is eating right now
I vote noodles so yeah we've seen him do
that before historically that tends to
be his favorite during chess matches
nice so where's the move Magnus we want
a Madness what are you doing D4 okay
there it is and uh it's an open Sicilian
Liam I've got to admire that just the
patience he didn't Flinch One slim he
was not disturbed by uh magnus's long
pause there and it's the four nights
variation of the Sicilian there we go
there we go that's what I'm talking
about right there that's exactly right
G4 foot of score baby yeah it's about to
get nasty wow
Brad oh this is uh impressive stuff
Magnus going straight on the attack
straight with the kill switching up his
strategy yesterday the slow approach
didn't work
oh one question for you Robert are you
I see Magnus
let's say G4 or
immediately played D5 yeah D5 seems
principled so I get why he would rush
that decision but now we see him deep in
thought because it's not easy there's
maximum pressure against that Knight
that is now pinned so them knows he
needs to deal with that he needs to
defend that night but how to do so it's
a not an easy question yeah and we're
about to also kick off are other game of
the loser's bracket as Vladimir fetusiv
gets ready to take on Lavon aronian with
the white pieces also starts with the
King spawn opening yeah better save he
started with this opening plenty of
times yesterday against Hikaru Nakamura
eventually going down to defeat here but
this time it is levonne aronian with
black playing E5 just very solid
approach so these two games will be
ongoing and we'll keep everyone up to
date
with any big
kind of developments but uh meanwhile it
is federative I'm just waiting for the
move here right it's bit it's a bit of a
strange one to think or move three for
white especially if your opponent's
playing uh his main opening he goes for
the Spanish and it's the Berlin the
dreaded Berlin one of my favorite
openings because I'm a boring old man
but uh yeah just solid start for level
it shows how much respect he has for
Vladimir felicev the silly stage yeah I
mean you can go to sleep right here chat
if you like you want to get a nap that's
going to be right now of course the
Berlin okay Knight C3 there we go there
we go now we're gonna have some action
oh Knight D4 yeah no this is this is a
good way for white to avoid some of
these main lines we saw Vladimir
krummick use it with great success the
Berlin defense against Gary Kasparov in
their world championship match when
chromic rested the title away from who
had been the greatest player of all time
now Magnus Carlson gives him a run for
his money in that category but here you
see white is a little bit ahead in
development Black's E5 Pawn the one in
front of the king is a bit vulnerable so
black has to deal with that well white
gets that first move Advantage yep so
this uh is called the four nights the
Spanish four nights and uh now this
actually this is a pawn sacrifice for
black white can get greedy if he wants
and capture this black e-pawn in the
center with his Knight but that does
lead to a variation that's actually
quite well known that has been studied
in depth and Whisper it quietly does
tend to lead to a force draw so Vladimir
fedes much more aggressive player keeps
the tension not getting greedy and
grabbing Pawns and now the game will
take a bit of a slower Pace very
symmetrical so far First Trade of
knights and uh this one the tension will
be pushed towards the middle game yeah
David you said it this is a slow paced
opening and will take its time to
develop into a rich middle game but I'm
just glad that we didn't see any of
those quick Berlin draws we still get
action on this one but the Sicilian in
the Magnus Liam game that is already
heating up so we're going to head
straight into that one what is this
position there have been trades in the
center White's King still on E1 take it
away David uh thank you Tony for very
good to me this one is just crazy at
this early stage
um I must admit I know zero opening
theory in this position that needs to be
a chessable course there must be a
chessable course on this one
the walking encyclopedia I already know
it's just definitely of course Seth
Dorman if you guys want to know that's
actually the most aggressive uh
aggressive Sicilian course is actually
bicep dormi as a part one and part two
this will be in part two in the Sicilian
variations right so he does go G4 and
mini lines in fact it had a game against
gamagami that I won GM uh us Masters
first round beat him with the G4 line it
was a seven engine but here you have G4
and H4 and you play G5 and you just
literally rip his head off that's all
you're trying to do in this in this
opening and Liam is going for what Liam
is in he's in for it right now I I can
pay attention to the chest but you're
like an encyclopedia over here hey you
know every single course out there
you're quoting specific authors and
games that's right who are you I mean I
am a Jedi I am a Jedi it's the way of
the Jedi impressive stuff and I think
Liam was actually terrified of his head
being ripped off as he said that James
uh so he's just trying to trade pieces
that tends to be a good strategy fight
in the center when your opponent's
attacking on the flank and here with
this last move Liam's captured in the
center with a knight he's saying
actually all of the nights can come off
the board I'm very happy with that and
then your G4 move with white does look a
bit odd it looks out of place uh White's
Pawn structure on the king side might
just be very weak later on in the game
so Magnus needs to justify his early
aggression right now and uh he needs to
figure out a way to do that again I'm
slightly surprised magnus's paused
because it was him who chose the opening
this must have been in his preparation
what do we think here what is this next
move going to be other than just trading
Knights and accepting a very balanced
position yeah usually what we want to do
is get the queen F3 but here he kind of
it's difficult because the Knight is
under attack here on D4 so if we can get
Queen F3 in and Castle Queen side well
then this is all Justified this is
usually what we do of course we're not
casting King side because we already
played G4 why would we do this so you
definitely want to Castle Queen side but
he's trying to figure out what to do
maybe I move the Knight to B3 but if I
trade on C6 I may open the B file and
give black in the tag especially if I'm
going to move the bishop and Castle
Queen side so it is problematic here
he's trying to figure out what to do you
may see something like Knight to B3 um
and then Queen F3 Bishop D2 and Castle
queen size yeah uh it is a very decent
plan I agree James but it does take a
bit of time so it feels like Liam uh
before the white king is able to jump
over to the queen side he will be able
to strike or at least cause some
problems and uh yeah Magnus dilemma he's
in the tank yeah not liking White's
position already with that pawn on G4
the king and the Santa James you
mentioned Queen side castling but that
doesn't feel very safe either with this
C Line open already it just looks like
Liam has developed all his pieces he's
the one who's ahead on the clock
has this opening completely backfired
for Magnus Robert oh for sure this is
one of those do as he says not as he
does moments where Magnus can get away
with it he's the strongest player in
history he's the world champion but he's
doing some dangerous pretty bad stuff so
do not try this at home for all those
you of you watching White's best move is
to take that G4 pawn and bring it back
bring it back to the second rank like
that would be okay for white even then I
don't think black would have problems
but right now oh white has huge problems
because your king will never find true
shelter yeah I mentioned that Magnus
needed to kind of switch things up
change his strategy change his routine
change something but I didn't think this
was the right uh right way to go okay
David this is messy okay messy let's go
here so I'm this Messiah so I need to
see it so nine to five whoa big time
maybe yeah of course I'm a Jedi and then
after Knight F5 Knight takes C3 of
course so engine doesn't like obviously
okay Knight G7 check this King f8 Bishop
H6 whoa Knight D1 96 98. check double
check all right 1988 now what's the
piece count here what's going on you
tell me James Black's a piece up
temporarily yeah right it's just I'm
just trying to figure out this was
something here Rook takes and then Rook
D1 I guess if we do a count black has
three miners white has two but uh at
least this one keeps the black king
trapped in a cage for now so some
competition uh some conversation but
maybe not enough but I think exactly
what James is doing is how we as players
think we're often trying to figure out
is that a viable variation and we just
went through the emotions there we're
often doing that in our heads and we saw
it doesn't actually quite pan out so
very instructive line in some variations
that may work out for white here it does
not so we expect Magnus I mean he did
just take uh the Knight on C6 instead of
playing funny business over there on the
king side and well he will temporarily
ruin Black's Pawn structure but white
king that's really what this position
boils down to is White's King will never
find true safety yeah and I like Liam's
decision not to actually trade off more
pieces but instead he takes back with
the pawn yes history structure is
shattered but he gains time he gains a
very important Tempo against this white
bishop and when the bishop Retreats I'm
not sure exactly where black will start
attacking soon maybe the queen will come
out at some point maybe The Rook just
slides across to the semi-open file now
and uh okay instead we've seen another
trade of knights but white is the one
with weaknesses look at these pawns
they're easy Targets later on for
Black's Bishop I still don't like
magnus's position but uh at least the
game continues now the middle game is
where this one will be decided I'm gonna
tell you right now this is not in the
chessable course not in the testable
course Magnus okay this is gross yeah
Castle King side yeah this is not in the
course but we're off the head now he's
just taking a decision to put his King
on the king side with that pawn on G4 do
not try this at home or maybe only try
this at home what is is going on here
this looks absolutely dreadful for white
and it is a best of two match this is
magnus's only white this is a nightmare
yeah but Magnus is going to do as Magnus
does and he look at the eval bar right
now it's only slightly better for black
so it's not like he's crying he's not
too worried but it just looks odd I
think the Aesthetics of the position are
clearly in Black's favor white has these
doubled isolated pawns his pawns
sticking out in front of the king we
keep talking about it we would love to
bring that pawn backwards help our King
find some better shelter but that's not
going to happen but how does black
actually punish white that's the big
question I really don't have an answer
for I like the look of it but how to
punish Magnus is more difficult and
going forward long term that might be
the Dilemma he has too many tempting
moves Liam does he go for those White
Queen side pawns those doubled isolated
pawns does he go immediately for the
white king which pieces does he want to
exchange so many questions that Liam has
to answer so he's spending his time
wisely this is the beginning of the next
phase of the game the middle game has
begun and I do expect Liam to maybe
invest two three minutes and then come
with a sensible plan I think as soon as
the black queen comes out the Rooks
connects he will be for choice but he's
just weighing up his options yeah but
this is a dream outcome for Liam to
start the elimination match with the
black pieces and to get this position
look at that pawn structure that Magnus
has on the king's side a glaring
weakness on G4 on the queen side you've
got the double pawns Black's the one
who's making all these Pleasant choices
between where to place that Bishop when
to strike in the center perhaps Advance
the e-pawn uh further up the board on E5
to open up that Bishop on D7 start
targeting that G4 Pawn so some very
pleasant ideas here for Liam in a very
critical moment this is the elimination
match between the players and Liam
chooses another part he wants to try to
put the bishop on the long diagonal from
8 to H1 I like it David The Rook can
move to see it and already start
targeting the queen on F3 yeah let's
show that move Tanya right now this does
look uh very logical this Rook is doing
nothing in the corner why not slide it
across big threat potentially if the
bishop does Reach This diagonal it's
going to be game over you could imagine
the black queen the black Bishop lining
up on this line and uh that will end in
a Checkmate attack but maybe Magnus can
slow this down slow down this plan you
can for example blink bring his Rook
across he can put his Bishop on the long
diagonal first himself preempt Black's
uh attempt to put this bishop on C6 and
suddenly it's not so easy these pieces
are still a bit cramped Liam has wasted
a bit of time his Queen is not active
yet I don't really like what he's done I
think he should have gone straight just
a couple of moves ago straight for the
white king he should have for example
pushed this Pawn as you mentioned as
well Tanya or maybe even push this one
play it on the side you're stronger
black has a four versus three majority
on the king side white is the one with
weaknesses on this side of the board
he's playing on the opposite flank and
actually this has all happened on the
board and suddenly it's Magnus look at
this with threats against the black
queen big tactic Bishop takes H7 check
if White had a free turn would net a
pawn because you take the pawn over
there go Queen D3 check at the end rook
and queen line up against that Bishop on
D7 you have to block the check or move
your king and then white ends up a pawn
ahead so actually I feel like Magnus has
the upper hand suddenly and this is what
Magnus does it just doesn't make sense
right we all were talking about it it's
a terrible position you shouldn't try
this and then Magnus like who cares what
you say I'm Magnus Carlson right I'm the
only player above 2800 In classical
chess and I will get the upper hand if
it's a neutral territory yeah big threat
Robert how does he actually defend
against this if you suddenly move your
Pawn for example you could go the other
way with another threat this is a pin
after all on the D file and maybe you
win some material here so Liam with a
real dilemma a real question to answer
and it's kind of self-inflicted he
played a bit too slowly and suddenly
rook and queen facing off on the d-file
big problems ahead it turns around that
quickly when you're facing a magician
like Magnus Carlson that is crazy yeah
he actually what is the move here in
fact you have to figure it because you
are on Queen E8 but that means still
runs in the bishop H7 Queen E3 I guess
he's just saying hey you have double
pawns and you have some weaknesses but I
mean okay I have an extra Pawn is white
here Bishop H7 maybe he's there yeah
what a tricky move Robert
trapped if you grab that point on H7 wow
my goodness so you've got to show that
David what a trick set up that volume
yeah what a trick I saw Robert smiling
here I don't think Magnus is gonna fall
into it he hasn't in this position he
has brought his Bishop out we'll mention
this in a minute but if he had been
greedy here after Queen eight and
grabbed this Pawn this is a check yes
this is a double attack yes but when you
finally take this bishop you get
skewered the black Rook just slides
across hitting the queen hitting the
Rook behind it and after Queen takes
Queen what we call exvisions or an
Intermezzo an in-between move Rook takes
Rook is a nasty check and when the white
king moves only then you take the queen
back and you're a rook up so of course
Magnus wasn't going to fall into this
but uh kudos to Liam for setting that
trap it might have caught mere mortals
like me uh there but uh instead Magnus
Dodges that brings his Bishop out to a
nice diagonal and uh still control for
white very tricky stuff Valium that
loved that a trap that you just showed
and just how dangerous and alert the
players need to be and Magnus now ahead
on the clock continues to ask these
questions because Bishop 87 is now a
threat with the Rook on D1 defended he
is planning to go in for this trick of
capturing on 8-7 while Magnus is asking
questions to Liam chat you can send us
your questions on Twitter using the
hashtag chess Champs send us your
selfies send us your questions and we'll
feature them on our show
yep and I really like how Magnus has
plugged the holes on the king side with
his pieces I mentioned that Liam should
have gone straight to the kill straight
for the white king now Maxis is Queen
his Bishops they're all lined perfectly
it's really hard to imagine black
breaking through on that side and if you
can't break through against the white
king what is your plan Black's queen
super passive and the board is on open
files right now and the white Rook on D1
perfectly plays that Rook that's in the
corner it's gonna slide one square over
take over an open file because magnus's
dark Square Bishop covers the enemy
Square on the eighth rank so I really
like the way Magnus is playing this I'm
surprised I'm even saying this at this
point I was like oh man's position is
terrible he's playing just kind of this
far-fetched joke of an opening and I'm
sitting here like yeah wow this is
looking promising for white look how
active the Bishops are
I don't know if I would play G4 in the
opening and end up with this double Pawn
I would be lost in 20 more and here's
Magnus playing one of the best players
in the world and suddenly we're talking
about him being better already how does
he do this
I mean it's just magic it's the Magnus
touch uh it's hard for anyone to explain
that that's why he's so good but you're
gonna have to relax you don't have to
relax my guy what is this in between
what is that what a move what is going
on she's giving up a pawn
guys what is this speechless here in the
studio what is the idea here he just
gave a pawn and instead of capturing
back Liam has just said okay I'm gonna
play on as if nothing happened and uh
this is the current position let's do a
rewind a refresh Liam threw his Pawn
forward to F5 very logical move and here
I was expecting at least for the pawn to
be captured maybe the white Bishop would
have slid in with a check but this isn't
at the end of the world the black king
could hide in the corner the game goes
on instead Liam says okay have my Pawn I
don't care Bishop C6 wow he's just
removing a strong piece in the center of
the board and if the white actually
captures her on E6 does black have to
move Queen G6 or am I losing my head oh
Queen G6 Tanya with a check oh it
doesn't matter though maybe it doesn't
quite work because white has a nasty
check himself just to block to plug the
f file but uh I think you're right there
are tactics in this position to do with
the pin along this line maybe just G5
maybe just take a chill attack a bishop
why not white weakened his King earlier
so black is fine with weakening his King
too and due to this pen you do snatch a
bishop I don't think white can get away
with this instead we've seen a trait of
the light squared Bishops on C6 and same
tactic in the air white has to be
careful of moving his Pawn off the F
line what a tactic what a trick there
from them gotta say James I'm not gonna
lie hey look when you if you get hit
with a move like that you're like okay
look I'm hey man can we talk about this
like let's uh let's uh let's step back
and let's talk about this politely like
that was very strong Bishop C6 would
definitely frighten you a little bit and
let you know that hey he came to play
just like you did Magnus so that was a
very strong move the pin is still there
right there's problems now down the F
line and your king is super weak after
that g G4 and stuff like that of course
you can go Bishop G3 maybe you have to
do something they said Rook B1 wow Rook
B1 we Rook B8 is that what you're doing
right yeah I like the way both players
are kind of ignoring the tension there
right them struck with F5 it was
captured he didn't capture back and now
we're seeing both players say there's
going to be a staring on pawns can you
take me can I take you the answer is up
in the air but what we see Magnus doing
he's controlling the open files both of
his Rooks are supremely placed on
perfect lines and that could cause
problems for the black king so watch out
if your Magnus your king is open but
lands King it might not be the safest
either yeah what a nice move I'm I'm
carried away as well by looking at the
white Pawn structure there's two sets of
double pawns two isolated pawns on the
flank that's why Magnus has to play
dynamically that's why his last move
getting a rook into the game potentially
zooming all the way up to the eighth
Rank and uh yeah often when you're kind
of struggling strategically positionally
with ugly pawns with bad pieces you have
to justify it with uh tactics with
tricks and suddenly I'm looking into the
position there must be something here
for white black has kind of abandoned
the eighth rank but there are so many
pins in the position so many tricks we
have to show something here uh Tanya I
see you're peering ahead you're really
interested in some tactics here for
white the first thing that comes to mind
is what happens if white steps up with
The Rook to B8 but the good news for
black is that the bishop on F4 is spin
so you don't have to really care about
it you can go on to pick up that Rook on
be it so that's not a threat anymore but
you're absolutely right David that each
rank looks really extremely weak right
now Liam playing with fire but is there
an immediate blow here the evaluation
bar the computer thinks no I'm also
tempted to just bring it up to the
seventh rank they call this seventh
heaven when Rooks are on the seventh
they have all the targets they're just
going to grab all the material this
looks very tempting maybe setting up
some tricks uh along that rank what else
could white consider maybe just a
sensible move getting the queen out of
Dodge getting it out of the pin but uh
either way tactics are starting to make
the uh appearance in this position and
Magnus is the first to think what comes
to mind here James Robert definitely
definitely I love the rugby seven more
that's a 2700 move by David there Rook
B7 absolutely after Rook takes I mean
you're just certainly Rook E7 and you're
threatening to bring the other Rook down
there and then you know seventh heaven
they call the pigs on the seventh when
you have two Rooks down there so that's
gonna be pretty nasty I mean it's
definitely there and Rook takes E7 is
there too as well so I definitely like
that Rook B7 move it's like the best
defense is offense right so did you play
Queen four check now and uh guys I guess
we
Bishop G3 Bishop G3 played on the board
and uh James he said Rook B7 was a 2700
move unfortunately Magnus is 28 2900 so
uh he played a better one yeah yeah
you're right you're right
what's wrong Liam what's wrong with him
today he plays some very good chess this
might be the game with like the worst
Pawn structure we'll see right
everyone's pawns are terrible nobody
wants to have a clean uncompromised Pawn
structure so if we see a queen trade
then black will have double isolated
Pawn so every single Pawn on the board
is about to be isolated yeah and I think
we will see Queen takes Queen what else
could Magnus consider here the tension
there it's just too much to bear you
don't really want to have to step back
with your queen yes you can throw in a
check for example whites Rook can still
go up to B8 hitting that black king but
I think that can simply either be
blocked or maybe the black king can poke
his head out start marching forward so
the Queens are coming off the board
we're heading into the end game and who
spawns are weaker that's the big
question it's level material but uh I
would slightly choose black I think I
would choose uh Liam's side just because
I feel that his pawns look fine for now
but white pawns are easily targeted
especially I'm looking at the A3 on the
side there Black's Bishop already
hitting it Liam meanwhile he's paused
because he's thinking about trading off
one set of Rooks before he takes back
White's Queen
oh yeah that's correct correct takes if
he keeps uh yeah hg6 I do like white but
then Rook D1 which is definitely oh wow
yeah now I like I actually like white
here a little bit just because of that
exactly the initiative I'm doing it
first you had to capture back which is
why Rook D1 was probably a little bit
better because even A3 is hanging in
that line there yeah different I agree
and if black actually takes only three
white also has the option of planting
his own Bishop on E5 you could do it
after capturing on A7 or even before
hitting that pawn on G7
so Magnus has got his own trumps in this
position yeah I think that white is
gonna have the more active pieces even
though Black's Poncho looks better it's
more difficult for black to get to
White's pawns because those C pawns you
have to bring your Rook all the way
around into the position and I feel like
the king Side Pawn structure is a
long-term weakness for black to deal
with white will take A7 we will swing
that Rook over to D7 next and put
pressure in the D5 pawn and I just feel
like white would be better in this
variation which is why Liam he's been
playing great chess throughout this game
and look what he has done he says don't
want that pawn don't want that flank
Pawn let me go for a more Central Pawn
and I'm stopping White's active plan of
putting the bishop in the center this is
great decision making by the Vietnamese
Superstar yep always prioritize peace
activity in these end games even at the
cost of porn sometimes so now after Rook
takes A7 creating a passport for white
Leanne has grabbed this Pawn hoping to
much forward but Magnus is saying yes
I'm gonna run across and now be careful
if you push your opponent the white
Bishop will find its active post hitting
this point hitting this pawn and Magnus
will have the advantage so still up in
the air this one yet to be decided but
both players playing really really well
so far I've got to say both very
creative especially in that middle game
full of tactics and they found a way to
kind of neutralize each other's
activity and uh Liam I think making a
good choice defending the pawn with this
rook and he's again ready to swing that
Rook over to the a file to go after
White's isolated porn over there also a
sneaky idea of actually pushing D4 next
because that Rook from C5 it's not only
heading to attack that a pawn but
controls the E5 Square as well so a
Magnus there stopping the first threat
that you mentioned is it time for black
to push the Deep on or is Magnus being
very sneaky with threatening Bishop to
B6 as well yeah I think both sides are
trying to be sneaky here Tanya and Liam
has lots of options I wouldn't be
surprised if he just drops back the
black Bishop to a nice safe Square first
just anchor it uh safely on F6 keep
everything protected and then decide
what to do but like you say maybe you
push the pawn forward so many options
try and activate the black Rook it's one
of these positions though we've seen
Magnus win countless times because it's
equals an end game it should be a draw
that's what everyone says and then
you're like Magnus Carlson doesn't just
agree to draw us he plays it out until
there are no pieces remaining and if
black is not careful you could fall
victim to this a pawn running up the
board but black has threats of his own
he's trying to bring his Rook back he
can bring it forward but he also bring
it back pin the bishop on the seventh
rank so both sides are playing excellent
chess right now and I would say both
sides have chances it's not just a dead
draw and the pawns are not in the same
flanks it's not symmetrical anyway both
players will have their shot
yep both players will have their shot I
like this last move by Lim I've got to
say that black Rook looked like it was
doing a decent job but it could be
improved this is where you always have
to ask which piece uh is happiest which
pieces need to kind of be repositioned
and uh he's talking to his pieces he's
asking them and he still has three
minutes that should be enough to keep
the balance in this game time scramble
will happen but this isn't the most uh
kind of terminal type of position if you
are low on time so uh yeah keeping
things within manageable Realms here
indeed a very high level game starting
from the opening the way Liam handled G4
and a position that looked super
dangerous for Magnus suddenly felt like
he was getting into a good end game but
now looks very level with both sides
having their own Trump Rook B7 The
Bishop's been but the good news for
white is that you can step out of this
pin by giving a check it's still a hot
end game even though such few pieces
David should we get a quick peek onto
the federacy of 11 game and then jump
straight back to this one I think we do
need to take a peek over there there
have been some developments Queens are
off in that one too it is an end game in
this clash between fedisev and aronian
also a bit of a strange Pawn structure
you would think it looks symmetrical but
both sides have weaknesses both sides
have potential access to outposts and
feder save he is not one to sit back and
relax he never takes a chill he's going
straight forward and he's willing to
accept an isolated Pawn in order to get
his Knight active the White Knight is
getting active the white Rook on the
third rank watch out for it swinging
across later and we talked about seventh
heaven James that white Rook might be
the most important piece uh piece here
on D7 I mean absolutely I think uh I
think for the save actually has in the
last few weeks or even months here have
uh some very good Big Boost of
confidence and I'm saying that just
because of me his record with Hikaru
just speaks for herself right now in the
last five or six games where he was able
to take down Hikaru in title Tuesdays
one of the biggest events right where
the strongest players play he was able
to do to do that he even had a monster
performance in the Pro chess league and
in a protest League Arena Battle Royale
whatever it is so um he played very he's
playing very good chess now these days
so of course it's very aggressive and uh
aronia is going to have to find
something you know here but it is LeBron
neuroney and he'd been around a long
time he does this he's creative he's
tactical too but definitely I mean this
one's up in the air for anyone I like
white though because of the Rook on the
seventh rank we do take on that four
play Rook F3 and uh and then get our
pieces active tonight is pretty gross
though on E2 that is a disgusting Night
on YouTube right now for now yeah
exactly it's trying to become a good
night with White's last move but the
Knight would like to hop forward but I
think the nature of this position is one
where these high-level Grandmasters they
would take this position with the white
side even though the eval bar is not so
high over one where the evaluation bar
is through the roof but it's complicated
this is one-sided you're playing for two
results either if Lavon plays the best
possible chess and makes a draw you're
like credit to him he played a great
defensive effort but it's very likely
that white wins this game because black
is shuffling back and forth you cannot
kick that Rook out of the seventh rank
that Rook is patrolling of both
directions and that Brook on B3 it is
going to get active either to the D file
as well joining the party or to F3 as
David pointed out and going after the F7
phone I hate Black's position here yeah
and you can see in the body language
level is not comfortable at all it's not
his type of position just to show the
main line if you do take this Pawn for
example white will recapture James
called it a gross piece this Knight now
is uh maybe the MVP it's gonna just step
into the center to a beautiful square
and it's going to win the game for white
so Levon he's uh really caught between a
rock and a hard place here just what to
play I have no idea I would want to
maybe move this Rook into the game but
how and where and if you do Shuffle
across for example white will just move
across himself and uh whoops I think
it's going to be a Calamity on the F7
Square he brings his Knight into the
game and uh maybe hoping to jump in a
decent choice but what is the answer
after Pawn takes porn still huge threats
in the air going after F7 I don't like
it for Levon but the evaluation Bar says
he's doing okay maybe this was a good uh
resourceful move maybe he just needs to
trade off this beast on D7 for example
dropping his Rook back or bringing his
Rook across just get rid of this piece
and maybe you live to fight another day
I think it's a good choice and
oftentimes Grandmasters they will give
up material to make sure they get
activity for themselves and that's what
Lavon is doing a great illustration of
that giving up upon the center but white
extra pawn it won't be healthy it'll be
doubled and I said not able to be
protected by another Pawn great decision
by Lavon because he's giving up two
different pawns there's the pawn the
center and then there's a Pawn on A7 and
then white would get a pass Pawn of his
own so Levon I mean what a fighter he is
I agree with the featured chat there I
mean he is just playing some great
defense against a dedicated determined
Vladimir fellow save
yep dedicated and determined and he's
tanking here a bit he spent one minute
but he needs a breakthrough at some
point you just got to make a decision
just take one of the pawns and if Levon
proves that he finds a solution fine
it'll be a draw you move on to the next
game but uh okay I'm getting worried for
feder safe around two minutes now he
just needs to make that decision just
grab a pawn I don't know which one but
grab one all right let's grab one yeah
let's grab one yeah maybe take on I mean
you probably take the E Pawn that just
seems better it's a center Pawn you
still have A7 on tap and Rick F3 there
it is yeah Rook F3 is there Rook d8 okay
activity yeah why it's got to be a
little careful if you grab the A7 Pawn
black will actually enter with his own
Rook to the second rank with Rook D2 and
then there are so many tactics that can
happen uh David if we can just bring
that up and you know I want to get my
knight on D4 if you try to defend your
knight with the King I'm gonna give up
my Rook not even gonna blink twice Rick
takes Knight and nice Fork there Tanya
it's a double attack you win some
material as black so you really need to
avoid this type of trick for feather
save and wow I was gonna say it would be
more in his stuff to just drop the Rook
back and uh just leave it there forever
leave The Rook on this square if it's
ever captured even by a knight uh you
will establish a really strong Pawn
Center but okay he's doubled up his
Rooks we have seen a trade of Rooks in
the center you still have a strong piece
here sorry but uh live on a ronin okay
look at this he's repositioned his army
and he's going for this weak Pawn this
straggler in his Camp that's
indefensible and suddenly this Black
Knight is like a rock in the center on
E6 it's holding everything together I
think No One's Gonna Hold this one it's
one of these uh positions where the
evaluation bar does not tell the whole
story this is actually unbelievable
defense because I wasn't even looking at
this Rook A6 move defending and
attacking simultaneously and levana Roni
is one of the best Bug House players in
the world and the key to bug house also
known as doubles chess is that you need
to make moves the simultaneously attack
and defend and this is one of those
Lavon deserves a lot of credit the Eva
bar has stayed in the middle and now
it's like going down in his favor
because he is playing this so
excellently yeah and Magnus Carlsen and
Liam Leia also deserve a lot of credit
for their play in game one very high
class chess precise play there and the
game fairly ended in a draw in the end
game where we left it but this one is it
is all three results are possible G3
played Black does have the option to
just pick up the pawn David yeah you
could pick up a pawn uh there's actually
no rush you could potentially try and
stop white snipe from jumping forward
this last Pawn push for uh Vladimir
ferisev is designed to bring his Knight
to the F4 Square to try and trade those
two knights off if the knights disappear
White's chances May improve Black's
night I think is far superior right now
so we'll live on try and take a time out
to try and prevent that I'm not sure how
you do it without weakening squares
yourself but uh he does have two extra
minutes on the clock that could be vital
and as Robert pointed out momentum is
slightly on black side it looked like
black was really struggling suddenly
there's no problems at all and you could
start hoping for more yourself
um I think I would just take that pawn
and start calculating later but uh Levon
is more creative what do we think I do
like that G5 move because their Knight
is gross like that Knight on E2 has no
moves my guy like what are you doing
with your life right so this Knight is
so bad so when you go G5 he might even
be tempted to go G4 and try to get the
Knight to G3 and then F5 but in that
case I mean when you move the Knight to
G3 then mine goes to F4 right so it's
very I mean this Knight is so bad and
you're just trying to fight for your
life to get the Knight active right so I
mean G5 definitely seems like a move um
that I would play just to stop and stop
prevent the knight from jumping into F4
that's what he wants he played G3 to put
the Knight on F4 you play G5 to stop it
then we take the pawn we go Rook A2 and
what do you do right you might be in
some trouble especially after we after
we push the a pawn the B Pawn is
connected to his well and we can take
the the pawn on B2 it's problems I
definitely I definitely see uh ronian
turning this one out and the time look
at the time he's up time here well it's
getting closer now but definitely up a
little bit of time here too yeah I think
it's the Instinct right most players
they see G3 they want to play G5 but
that's how strong Levon is he doesn't
just play on impulse he has enough time
to calculate but James the clock is
getting even and that's a problem
because Federal save is a bullet Maestro
that's correct if you yeah if you
compare the skills here classical chess
maybe live on aronia and Rapid chess
it's unclear it's much closer but I've
had to save definitely has the edge if
it gets down to a race and James you
called it you predict the future all of
these uh things have come to pass and
suddenly a check the idea is to drive
whites King forward onto the second rank
so when you go after this white B Pawn
you take it with a check a nice Tempo
gaining maneuver there by 11 irony this
is what he was calculating he spent a
minute or two but then the next four or
five moves came very very quickly the
downside is this white on uh White
Knight NF Thrive it's a f drive it will
Thrive but it is a beast and uh some
meeting ideas against the black king
potentially and are we going to see a
repetition with 97 Knight F5 or do you
think white is going to go for the mid
wow I mean to get checkmate you need
your work on the last rank but it's very
difficult the Black Knight has been so
strong ani6 since it got there so I feel
like white might not have all the time
in the world the time you need to
deliver that Checkmate so if you see a
draw perhaps it's time to make the draw
oh 10 seconds as well he's gone for one
check go King A7 you ain't got no time
yeah no checks now and the Knight does
drop back felicev is hoping begging for
the draw but Levon Orion doesn't need to
acquiesce to that one yet he grabs a
point with a check now the big dilemma
for black do you allow white throat to
go and take that F7 Pawn if your king
moves back you will get checked is there
a way to play for a win Maybe not maybe
you just have to admit it's better to
say I've found a good defense
but Lavon with that King Retreat to
eight seven has made his intentions very
clear that he wants Battleship to work
hard for that draw yeah no I mean
Federal saves the one on defense both
sides are showing good defense when
they've been on the back foot they're
saying some people crumble especially in
time travel but right now I think levana
Ronin he's the black pieces he should
just make the draw why take risk his
position isn't anywhere close to being
clear so make the draw now get the white
pieces in game two that way you have the
better chances yeah he's around 20
seconds himself yeah practical decision
wise decision take the draw get out of
here move to the next game but is he
gonna take a risk it's in his character
in his style he gotta move yeah and
Derek when you say take a draw you mean
just come up with the King defend that
F7 pawn and allow the repetition with
the checks with the Knight yeah exactly
bring the black king back keep
everything defended but no he goes for
the win there we go dropping with check
though look at all the pawns that the
white Rook is gobbling up but black here
Levon Orion is banking everything on
that b point it's two squares away from
promotion
rate just push it push it it's winning
push him baby and then there's a check
on each one and you're Queen yeah but
shall we King D1 how do you stop oh here
comes yeah because the king can't get
the C2 where it needs to and if you
trade that Pawn's coming in oh my God
Robert yeah oh wow this is it he's got a
yeah he's got to take that Knight they
were checkmating ideas on the board
white spawns are running forward but
Black's pawns are going to be quicker
this Pawn is going to be dealt with by
the black king and I think black's
winning this race it's definitely a race
right now but black seems ahead Black's
gonna make a new Queen first it will
cost white his Rook levon's winning
that's amazing because white is actually
up a pawn suddenly waiters five black is
four but it's about the quality not the
quantity and I think Federal Sav he
might just tip his King over in a couple
moves
looks so natural what was the move five
seconds you have a check first but we'll
check that later right now he picks up
this ball but the B2 Pawn Falls oh man
oh my God suddenly everything's
disappearing this game will likely end
in a draw actually it's Levon who has to
defend this he's going down three for
two now shaking his head could things
turn could white win we will go back and
uh check out what should have happened
there Levon was winning but he went for
the most natural move and it backfired
oh yeah you're right Tanya's right let's
check first yeah check first king C2 D3
takes D2 yeah if King takes you Queen
Cheese that's it bro that's sick right
idea I think Levon but just the wrong
order and uh wow what a turnaround chess
is hard said James Kenny he's absolutely
right but I think for Lavon you know
he's able to stabilize here because he
is down one Pawn but thankfully for him
his King is nicely centralized the white
pawns are a bit Loose as well so he
should be able to hold you should and uh
just while this game is going to take a
slower Pace I don't think Levon of ronin
ran out of time the clocks were slightly
wrong there for a second he's very
active with his King now he'll give a
check he'll win perform back and this
one will be a draw but I think we have
to show that critical moment uh okay we
might not it looks like we might get a
draw any second now it's a Perpetual
check and uh there's no way for White's
King to hide no shelter and finally
after all those twists and turns after
that roller coaster it is a draw
wow what a game and love on our onion
really did create his chances gambling
in very little time but just saying I
want to fight for a win and David the
critical moment was really that pawn
push where he missed we saw the eval bar
say and it was a decision a toss-up
between giving a check or pushing the D3
Pawn there yeah and he just chose wrong
that coin toss and he flipped wrong it
was in this position he pushed his Pawn
but as we saw White's Pawn was able to
step ahead and white was able to catch
up in the race instead a check would
have won the game for level neroni and
forcing the white king forward to
prevent this Pawn from promoting but now
another check deflecting the white king
no matter which Pawn you take the other
one will run through and black would
have won this game wow that is the
difference between a win and a draw and
David just to point out a very I want to
point out one more crucial line David if
we can just bring up because it was so
important that moment that instead after
what was played the key point was if we
can just back up to this uh to this
moment after D3 white can go C6 here
because you give a check oh sorry you
give a check the King goes up you Queen
and you don't have a way to fight
against C7 you pick up the Rook but then
this would end in a draw with checks or
White's the one that might win and with
that what a big Miss but this is what
Blitz this is what fast play is about
with this we end our round one off the
elimination bracket and this is our
score line Magnus Carlson Liam Lee had a
peaceful drop with chances to both sides
coming out in the opening in the middle
game fantasy of aronian what a game
Levon really creating his chances could
have wanted a slip in the move order and
this ended in a tie as well well we've
got game two action coming up but before
that for our non-subscribers you've got
a twitch break and for those of you who
have subscribed there's a very special
segment on a special player
foreign
what would you say was the biggest
adjustment that you had to make from
going full professional to combining
your academics as well as your
professional chess career of course it's
very hard to combine chess and and
academics but during the years that I
was here managed to do my best at school
and also got a chance to work with many
great players so that's helped me to
improve my chest as well I think it
always comes down to your time
management and your dedication to chess
and academics if you really want to do
well with both you can do it how do you
combine such a hectic life yeah you have
the coaching job but you also are very
much a trust professional I was offered
a job to take over and I couldn't say no
because
first of all I'm an alumni of the
program and I know the program really
well I feel like it's my responsibility
to keep the program I'm going and also I
wanted to to work with the students here
they are very talented and I believe
that I can help them get to the next
level last year we actually started the
chest in the chess in education minor
degree and that's the first time I
believe a university in America had a
chest degree for students that's a
perfect fit for what's the University
because we are Global University and
chess has been a big part of Webster
it's not only about chest but also about
the team culture about the team spirit
The Chemistry Between the players and so
on the friendships also a lot of things
that we have to consider but when you
look at the big bigger picture I think
as a coach you understand that more than
as a player and I think it's very
important to grow as a coach to
understand this sometimes almost like a
broader pattern too right you have to
guide them to help them do well in
school and academic in life in general
so they could feel better they would be
ready for purchase so I see myself as
mainly a coach nowadays I still play
chess professionally sometimes but not
as much as I used to whenever I apply I
try to prepare the best I can and also
because I work with my students on a
regular basis I also have some new ideas
that I can use in my own games I think
it's not too difficult to combine
between being a Jessica in a chess
player if you get the if you get two
students and you are motivated and you
keep working on it my favorite part of
the tour is that it's growing so much
and now it's more open to everyone I
don't really set a goal like
finishing 10 Place overall our top three
or something because I think it's
impossible to do that in Alessia but
there's like Canada but for other
players like myself I just enjoy every
tournaments that I apply and hopefully
I'll do well
this is it the moment has come for the
players to give it at all only one more
game remains in the elimination bracket
we saw both matches end in draw but big
fights in both these games with just two
games it is the best of two match if
tight we will have an Armageddon Magnus
Carlsen Liam both players played
fantastic chess Robert in game one and
it is Liam who starts with the white
pieces now yeah I expect a more solid
opening from Liam he's not going to be
pushing his G pawn two squares not in
the opening stage at least and I feel
like for Magnus he should be happy that
he wasn't any trouble in game one
because that could have gone a different
way absolutely with that pawn on G4 but
now we're not gonna have any of that
Robert you called out a solid opening
David we've got a Queen spawn yeah and
the Catalan opening one of magnus's
favorites and now Liam is using it
against him Liam has had a lot of
success with this opening uh in the
play-ins for this tournament he actually
did phenomenally well because he scored
some great upsets some great wins uh in
the Catalan and Magnus of course we'll
have studied this for World Championship
matches in his training camps there and
he's happy to transpose into the tarash
and uh he will most likely accept an
isolated porn Here Magnus uh clearly
maybe learning from some of his seconds
like Nils Cornelius I think he's done a
chessboard course on this one and uh
yeah solid start as you said Robert much
more solid than the last game at least
James chest of course news grindelius
yeah he also has one actually there's
just a Catalan course that just dropped
there's many courses that actually cover
what to do against the Catalan actually
but this one actually is a rare one that
he's playing and there's not many
Terrace courses on adjustable there's
only one it's called the dubar taras but
they don't really cover this part
he's keeping those Secrets because dubov
was a second from Magnus Carlson he'll
show you you know help Magnus get it
done but not how to stop Magnus yeah how
to stop Magnus that should be a course
in itself and uh meanwhile Magnus has
taken the opportunity after white just
pushed his Pawn to B3 better late than
never to plant that black knight in the
center and now there's a bit of tension
there is a pin on that white Central
Pawn uh that black dark Bishop I like
where it's placed uh a lot of tension
here Liam I'm not sure whether he's
planned this position whether he's
prepared this but he's slowed down at
least slightly
and uh yeah solid start it's hard to
imagine too much going wrong for either
side right right now right well
my garden in Magnus versus Liam David
oh so you think it's going to be a draw
what about you James nope
no Magnus does too as well oh are you
hinting at who you think it might be
what about you yeah I think we're
getting armed again limbs too solid he's
not going to do anything risky and
beating Liam with the black Pieces good
luck to you yeah
I love an Armageddon so I'm hoping for
one for sure tell us what do you think
how that one's going to go meanwhile
action is also on and our second matchup
Levon aronians so close to taking that
first game now has to do it all over
again but he does have the white pieces
Queens have been traded David yeah early
days it's the character let's go to
we on break let's go to break that's
crazy man this is the weird Carroll Khan
you actually can't play for winning
chances of with this this is actually
more of like a reverse philodorant away
especially when you put the pawn on C3
you go King C2 you play F3 this is
boring what is this Robert why are we
playing this man David I do love my
endgame grind so I'm gonna say it's all
about the intricacies it's all about the
nuances I love the uh sophistication
behind both sides play but yeah maybe
for the fans Not So Exciting uh this one
will get a bit uh spicier I'm hoping
later on so uh maybe we'll focus on the
Magnus game first of all but yeah this
one's an end game in Levon it's not
maybe his style to go into something
like this normally we see a more Dynamic
approach especially with the white
pieces but maybe he's playing the
opponent here it's not fair to save
style either I was going to say that
this is more Lavon style than it is
ferrose it's not really either of theirs
but it's less so Federal saves he loves
attacking chess he always has
interesting battles uh but here we see
the position without Queens on the board
no easy targets but white does have a
little bit better control one some odd
piece placement that moved Knight D7 you
expected the night that was undeveloped
to go forward but said it goes back but
when he wants to is clear the long
diagonal he sees that white wants to
feed and Kettle that Bishop he says well
you're not going to pin me you're not
going to attack my knight over there so
I don't know how to judge this position
balance sounds like a cop-out I think
both sides will have their chances
because they're playing for different
things yeah and that we see Levon aronis
chessable Court uh course mentioned on
the beauty of Chess I'm not sure he
would have featured this position in the
beat of Chess course not in there but
either way he will be trying to create
something a bit later on I think I would
choose white just because if you look in
the center White's Pawn formation there
is really really nice black yet to
really stake his claim for those Central
squares so uh yeah right now it feels
like fair to save maybe an open opening
preparation he's still got almost 15
minutes left but not too exciting what
do we think should we stick with this
one we'll move back to Magnus against uh
uh I guess Liam let's have another vote
yeah we definitely can go back to the
Magnus game yeah that's not even a
question
let's do it this one will take a while
to heat up we will keep our eyes out on
this Magnus versus Liam a Queen spawn
opening by Liam and wow at least the
Queens are on so James you can breathe
here and I see quite a lot of questions
for that D4 pawns to be answered here
Robert yeah and I'm also Lam has spent
quite a lot of time so in the first game
Magnus was doing The Lunchbox variation
where he was just eating his food
spending a minute here or there now it
seems like Lem just is a bit
uncomfortable because there is a ton of
pressure at White's Center D4 was
White's first move now that pawn is
threatened by three different black
pieces and you can't even take the pawn
on C5 that's attacking you because
there's a pin behind it the dark Square
Bishop for black is in a perfect
situation it is hitting the Knight on C3
what
just showing what would happen if white
blunders and takes this Pawn there is a
pin on the long diagonal so uh Liam
needs to do something about it and whoa
he's taken the knights off the board
this surprised me I thought he needed to
just defend his Central Pawn but he
drops back now and this is fine yes
you'll lose your Central Pawn on D4 but
you now gain Black's Pawn on the E4
Square I'm not sure if there any tricks
any tactics here uh for example if black
does take in the center then things will
just get hoovered off the board and this
position looks pretty balanced actually
I would maybe choose white unless
there's something immediate here for
black just because of the Catalan Bishop
the bishop so strong on this long
diagonal but of course Magnus Super
Active and he will work things out it
would also be a Magnuson style I should
mention to take this Pawn just to
imbalance things uh yes it gives you an
isolated Pawn in the center of the board
but black will have more space Magnus
loves his space and for example A
variation like this one moving the black
Bishop I'm not sure where which
direction but uh for example here Magnus
having worked with players like dubov
love this type of Pawn structure loves
the space involved and it does give
winning chances for both sides but uh he
will if he wants to win this game he
will go for this option so looking
balanced so far but uh yeah James at
least the Queens are on this one you
know we can breathe guys we can you know
chat out there at home you're not going
to sleep on this one okay this is gonna
be some action steel right of course we
do have I was even thinking of e32 as
well but there may be some problems
there around the long diagonal really
the problem in the Catalan is that
Catalan Bishop if it gets aggressive and
it's just it's open then of course you
have problems around uh on the long
diagonal you have to play stuff like
work to B8 and like how do you even
develop that side of the board and a lot
of times if that cat on the bishop gets
loose it's going to be a problem for
black on that side with board especially
even with Rook to C1 and Etc so I mean
Magnus is taking a thing here as he
should right to figure out how he should
deal with this maybe not even take it
too I mean the bishop on B2 is paying
maybe we have an in-between move but
yeah it's not something to think about
such a classic slight nag with that
Bishop on G2 for Liam the Catalan Bishop
it's a good thing that Magnus went up to
the mountains uh David to get some fresh
air because I also see that he's got
good air quality where he's playing from
a big shout out to our partners asking
for providing us that because at least
we know that Magnus is playing in Fresh
Air with good air we saw his game in we
saw his game one some good moves there
so definitely a good environment yeah
feel good play good that tends to be the
motto and if your air quality is good
that's just a bone we do see as well
what the air is like over there in St
Louis in the US uh for Liam and the
temperature may be a bit warmer uh
hopefully it won't affect his uh
cognitive abilities too much but in
general good air quality as well there
too I know Liam is a perfectionist both
on the chessboard and off anything he
can do to be fully prepared he'll uh
take those steps take those measures and
actually what we predicted on the board
rather than capture that Central Pawn
first though uh Liam is kicking back the
Black Knight I like this one maybe there
were some tricks with the black light
Square Bishop coming out to attack uh if
white hadn't taken this first step this
precautionary measure and uh Magnus he
needs to retreat or does he he doesn't
he jumps in trading even more pieces off
yeah this is more of a it's just like
initiative right if you can if I can
make you do it and then I get an extra
move this is why native three was so
nice if I go 96 then that gives you a
chance to do something if I go nice C6
Knight anything you get an extra move
but Knight F3 you're forced to take it
back then you're going to take the pawn
and then I get an extra move right which
is pretty nice so I do like this
decision for Magnus here but again I
mean it's the Catalan bishop and that is
so annoying in the Catalan is the bishop
I mean it's just so and it actually have
it on the board here and Rook to B8
after it and I mean I like white in
these positions because it's the bishop
maybe he goes B6 now so it's just kind
of I guess we will get a draw here I
guess we have a draw here yeah you're a
very solid play and that's the nature of
uh Liam Lake he does not want to take
undue risk he's not going to play like
Magnus did in game one and for Magnus he
found a way out this bishop on F3 now is
your fin Kettle Bishop the Catalan
Bishop it can be really frustrating for
black to deal with and I'm not actually
calling this game a draw just yet it's
not a symmetrical Pawn structure black
actually has an extra Pawn if you look
towards the queen side the left hand
side of the board white has that extra
Pawn the center so you're playing for
different ideas in end games past pawns
start to appear you get a little bit
scared but it is balance so we want to
be clear about that but I just think
that if this game goes on Magnus
sometimes he makes miracles happen here
but Liam really I mean he's not going to
go down I do think we're gonna see
Armageddon yeah actually she's not gonna
be my next question Robert you know you
mentioned this bishop on the Diagon
Al Pawn structure if it is Liam really
going to try to push this one or will he
be happy to take it to the Armageddon
where it's really just anyone's game
yeah there's nothing to push
just being honest I don't think there's
anything that white is going to be
pushing I think that this one is very
very balanced I think we'll see some
trades the light Square Bishops will
come off and then the players are like
okay we're in an even end game yeah we'd
love to see it come down to the
Armageddon well while this one goes
ahead let's take a look on the other
matchup because that is heating up with
Levon aronia and taking on set a sieve
and wow you the Queens have been traded
off but this looks like a queenless
middle game all minor pieces on the
board just one set of Pawns off and look
at that King on E2 it feels like a
Fisher random position right now yeah
you're right Tanya it looks as if the
pieces have just been randomly thrown
onto the board and uh black has spent so
much time look at that Black Knight on
G4 intruding in the white camp but it's
gonna get kicked back it's already moved
three or four times in the game Black's
dark Squad Bishop has moved a couple of
times but what has black been doing he's
wasted so much time he hasn't staked a
claim with his Pawns in the center and
here Levon once he starts the kickback
once he starts pushing Black's pieces
back even further I think he's gonna
have a great position I think he might
even have a nice Advantage just because
white has all the space in the center
and blacks pieces will lack squares like
outposts and uh yeah it does feel like
this is not the type of position that
suits feather save style he wants more
activity he wants threats on the board
he wants tricks but without Queens it's
not easy to achieve that and look at our
players on the camera
foreigns on the head and this is such a
classic chest pose David which one is
yours uh it was more levons a moment ago
before the head scratched it was more
like heading hands just hiding from the
world hating my position hating my life
yeah we see players I'll often adopt
this pose when they're calculating when
they're trying to work out difficult
questions and uh meanwhile if I had to
say I've maybe slightly more chilled out
of the two that's a good move that's
actually a very annoying move where is
he he's going Knight F2 or Knight E3
jumping in night after 9
H1 doesn't have so many squares is that
something that white has to worry about
right now yeah yeah quite possibly for
example if you do nothing what would be
a nothing move here let's move my Bishop
back to a rubbish Square the Knight
would jump in now hitting the rook and
as Tanya mentions if you move your Rook
out the way Knight takes pawn and it's a
discovered attack hitting this Rook so
you will win material no matter what so
that is the threat I'm thinking that one
of the white Knights has to jump forward
to this Square I'm not sure which one uh
to hit this bishop to try and gain some
time uh against this piece but no Levon
solves it more creatively he brings his
Bishop to the side of the board this is
asking for the Knight to jump in but now
after Bishop takes Bishop there's no
time to take this Rook well at least I
don't think so because now after you
take this Knight with check the Knight
jumps forward and this piece is trapped
in the corner white will end up with two
pieces for a rook and material advantage
if this happens so uh holding things
together with tricks level Iranian
although the problem with putting your
Bishop out on H3 is that your Pawn
really wanted to be there because the
Knight on G4 is defended by black Bishop
on E6 so you're actually not creating a
threat and black could also consider
putting the H Pawn forward protecting
the Knight and Main H4 next just trying
to Barrel through on that flank so I
feel like this is a kind of strange
decision from Lavon his pieces are not
harmonious neither are blacks but I
think I neither side really has a good
footing in this position you're kind of
just trying to figure out what to do
move my move yeah it feels superficial
for both sides you're right it feels as
if all the pieces are just floating in
the air this bishop unprotected
undefended it's going to be kicked back
anytime soon uh maybe white could kind
of prepare a pawn push later on this
bishop looks nice and pretty but it
could be a Target later on it's uh yeah
definitely all to play for in this
position I would choose white I've got
to say but I agree White's last move
maybe not the most consistent with his
previous play
and uh yeah for the save now in the tank
two minutes down trying to find a
solution for black yeah I feel like
wages has the the moves like Knight F3 I
mean you have F5 sometimes brick F1 like
Knight D3 just got there's tricks here I
mean you can't even move the king really
because Bishop E7 so I feel like he's
gonna have to spend a lot of time here
really trying to figure out this
position which is going to be Advantage
for aronian there uh having you know a
little bit extra time having some
creativity he's creative himself and
having piece play and activity and and
tricks I mean I feel like white
definitely is for Choice yeah and one
thing I will say I've played feather
save a few times quite a few times
actually over the board and my strategy
has always been to make it as boring as
possible and uh it's tended to work
quite well uh once the Queens come off
yeah you breed the sigh of relief
because uh he's so good in these Dynamic
positions where there's just chaos going
on and he sees things so fast that's why
he's so good at Blitz at bullet but uh
here without the Queens it feels like
he's playing for those tricks he's
trying to kind of make magic happen out
of nothing and if white is careful it
feels like he shouldn't have too much to
worry about meanwhile all of the black
pieces are gravitating towards the
center uh they're all I don't see any
threats right now but they're all kind
of holding each other together attacking
those white pawns White's King is it
sweating here uh is it really a Target
love on Iranian I'm expecting him to get
his Knights into the game now especially
that White Knight on E1 nights in the
real Madame at the best of times but
that night on the bottom of the bud
needs to join the action join The Fray
yeah this position does not look that
easy to play for either side and I'm
just not liking the look of some of the
pieces right the bishop on D4 is a bit
loose so white will be able to kick it
with the tempo uh the bishop on H3 for
white a little bit awkward especially
with the stare down of the bishop so you
have to be very very careful when pieces
are in the same diagonal or on the same
file you have to watch out when the
piece in between them hops out of the
way here there's nothing for black but
there could be a moment where that
Knight jumps away and that Bishop on H3
is loose so I think Knight D3 sensible
move by Levon aronian he is just
coordinating his pieces playing in the
center and both sides have their chances
here and it's a very messy position and
James you made a really good point about
how because the east seven Pawn is weak
for black it's hard for black to connect
the Rooks the way white the way Lavon
just did by moving the Knight out of the
way and that's going to be a bit of a
trouble for feather save just getting
Harmony for those Rooks where are they
playing are you going to go shark Castle
are you going to go long Castle or maybe
the king just steps up is that something
James that black can think about move up
with the King to D7 and then start
getting your getting the Rooks in the
game I think after King D7 I hit him
with Knight F31 Tempo and then go with
the and then bring one of the Rooks to
D1 and then we have some nasty tricks
they're nice C5 and we live Knight E5
Knight everything five and you're in
some trouble here I mean it looks pretty
pretty nice they even have maybe an F5
Knight F4 take on E6 Knight G5 oh my
goodness right just so many moves that
you can play here there's so much
activity for White and the thing about
LeBron aronia here is that when you see
him sometimes like when he does this you
know he stretches and he do that like
that that's body language that lets you
know you might be in a little bit of
trouble every time he does that he's
feeling look at him yeah he's doing a
little head thing and like he stretches
he's come comfortable he usually always
does that when he's comfortable I've
noticed so he's comfortable he feels
good about the position yeah some body
language reading that by James well we
will come back to this but let's head
over to Liam versus Magnus because this
looks like it is about to end soon which
means we will have an Armageddon yeah
and Magnus smiling laughing to himself a
moment ago
I was pretty happy with this play maybe
he's happy about the Armageddon that's
imminent at this point are the good air
quality he's got going or the food he
just ate whatever he's just happy we
like good to see a happy magnet yeah
that is true and he should be happy
about this game because with the black
pieces it may have looked iffy for a
couple moves but he was able to
neutralize whatever Advantage Lim hoped
to get and we see it's an even end game
it's rook and three pawns against rook
in three pawns both sides have a pass
Pawn uh the white king can't venture
over to get the pawn it's needed where
it is protecting this Pawn on G3 the
black king will have to stop this past
Pawn but neither side will be able to
make progress this is a pretty
Elementary draw for these players yeah
and just good strategy with the Rooks
Rooks belong behind past pawns whites
Rook is perfectly placed uh what
blackstroke is if anything is the more
passive of the two and there we go black
now with this last move he's tied down
his own Rook the black Rook can't move
without giving away his Pawn but he's
also set to wait if your king ever pokes
its head out kind of steps to the side
the Black Rock will move move with the
check and black will make a new Queen
with his Pawn so this one is very much
just maintaining the status quo neither
side can make progress I'm expecting a
draw offer or a draw agreement anytime
now the last game ended pretty much King
versus King maybe this will end in the
same way just uh two great players
canceling each other out in the early
game straight to Armageddon both of them
lost in our beginning yesterday who do
we think is the favorite
this one I'm definitely going with
magnets in the Armageddon gotta go with
Magnus they are me fresh off I think
it's just more Magnus because of uh
their score and their record already now
that doesn't mean that anything happens
in Armageddon but just from being who he
is and also what the score is right now
he usually has this number I mean faster
time controls too as well I'm definitely
gonna take Magnus what about you rubber
I'm more curious about how low he'll go
because he went to seven minutes and 58
seconds yesterday if I'm remembering
correctly so will he go less than that I
don't think he needs to because Liam
can't get himself in that time Trail we
are about to see all the pieces come off
the board but I think that if you're
Magnus you just want the black pieces
and for limb you need enough time
find out we have it nothing left on the
board but we've got
a Armageddon it is time for the inner
game for the Mind Games to come forward
with the bid for the Armageddon we will
keep you updated once we hear it from
our players that is exciting do you
think they're gonna really want the
black pieces this time Robert yeah but I
think Magnus for sure is going to get
the black pieces because he can bid less
time he's the faster player between the
two we saw what happened to Liam
yesterday he had the black piece against
five minute car one he did not have
enough time and karwan was able to Blitz
him down and Checkmate the king so I
think that match will be interesting to
see the bidding but this match might not
even gets arm again yeah actually both
Armageddon is four Liam and for Magnus
were absolutely disastrous yesterday on
day one so this is going to be an
exciting one but action is still on here
and wow what is happening Rook to C2
played the bishop is attacked it doesn't
have too many squares it's got to fall
back to the center David yep and there
we go the bishop now centralized but
White's Knights do have a lot of
Mobility the position isn't fully open
Black's Bishop kind of hits thin air
they did find a really weird it kind of
convoluted way to trade pawns earlier we
saw lots of tension lots of pieces white
seaporton disappeared but Black's F Pawn
disappeared and if we look at the
structure white has two porn Islands the
king side although the pawns connected
the queen side those two pawns connected
black has three porn islands and that's
because the E7 Pawn next to the black
king is isolated long term that could be
a Target that could be a weakness but uh
yeah I would choose the white uh side
here the white Knights just because they
look like they can leap forward to some
great squares that being said I do
usually prefer Bishops so I'm kind of
going against my instinct here but I
just do believe in white structure I
think that's a small thing but it could
be a key thing later on and Levon he's
not one to sit there and slowly maneuver
that would have been my uh first call
instead he's going straight for the kill
pushing his Pawn forward that white Rook
on B1 may be opening up some clear
Targets on the queen side uh what do we
think here who would you pick and why
let me see that time seven of five
yeah I do like white because I'm I feel
like I have initiative here I feel like
I have some better squares I have a
nicer Center than you do I have uh the
knights are tricky so if I get a knight
to G5 I can go into E6 and maybe do some
things I don't want to really push my
e-pawn just yet because you allows
Knight D5 so I do like white but it's
just hard to maneuver in pieces right
now we have to figure out what we want
before I definitely like if Pawn takes
work before obviously we're hitting B7
and we can maybe go work to C4 and try
to you know attack the bishop if the
bishop moves then maybe we could move
the Knight on D2 because right now we
can't obviously because of Honor E4
hangs so it's it's kind of cramped it
feels a little a little bit but I
actually feel like White's just a tad
bit better a little bit a little bit
more active yeah Robert do you see any
way for black to actually keep things
together now I'm struggling to see a way
to uh kind of stay active as black but
uh keep defending it looks like a big
threat simply Pawn takes Pawn opening up
this Rook all the active moves I see are
bad like I'm looking at ideas like can I
for black B5 and if you take my Pawn on
B5 I play A4 and I want to go get a new
Queen but I understand that I'm giving
White Pass pawns but this is the type of
thought that Federal save is having he
knows if he sits passively that Levon
aronia might just grind him down in this
position it's not fun to play from the
black side so I'm getting a little bit
desperate Federal save should not his
position isn't that bad we see the
evaluation bar for the side of the
screen so if I'm Federal save I know I
want to lash out but maybe calm is
better here you're gonna have to pass
through defend it's not going to be fun
but maybe federal staff can get the job
done yeah for example if he takes this
Pawn off yes you allow the white Rook
forward but maybe you can just hold
things together here I'm hesitant to
suggest it but just move your Rook the
evaluation was heading up in White's
favor this is uh scary stuff I'm not
sure exactly why maybe it says James
mentioned suddenly this bishop is a bit
loose wow is this bishop trapped maybe
the other one oh the nice wood that's a
big boy move wow you got to play C5
suddenly black has to give things up
push this Pawn maybe give up this Pawn
just to keep the bishop alive so
actually there are hidden threats all
over the board not just is the white
Rook getting active on this Square uh on
the B7 square but this black Bishop
talking an Escape Route so nice move
there from level neuronian and
definitely on the board and on the clock
you know I've commentated enough better
same game
he wants a last word and it actually
might not be a terrible move because he
will not push his a pawn if the pawn
takes he'll probably just take back but
he's figuring let me trade more of the
pawns because if I'm down only one Pawn
a few pawns remain maybe that optimize
his drawing chairs you see the eval bar
after levon's move a very natural one
it's actually saying that black is right
back in this yeah I'm really surprised
Levon his last move requires a lot of
calculation yes he's threatening to
maybe jump in with some night checks but
he all of that tension on the queen side
look at those four pawns staring off
against each other the white BNA pawns
the black BNA pawns there was so much to
work out he could have taken either one
of them maybe the pros and cons for both
but he rushed his decision and when you
make Rush decisions in such critical
positions
to backfire calculation over everything
like James says and there was so much to
calculate but you didn't that's right
yeah calculation over Everything Chad
okay you heard it from David first right
he said it not me okay right calculation
so you got to calculate here but it is
and he has a time to do it too as well I
mean I'm up three minutes here um LeBron
so I'm feeling good about the position
but man there's some definitely some
crazy stuff like you very rarely do you
have four pawns like this right in this
little you know Pond box right where you
have to actually figure out do I take
this weight and you take that way but if
I take that way he takes this way if you
take this way we take every weight right
so it's lots of captures and he takes on
B4 and the engine going crazy whoa is
that a blunder the White Knight can jump
in now with the check I'm not sure which
Knight but Knight to E5 and suddenly
there are all sorts of threats in the
air
white can simply take one of the two
pawns as you mentioned there or that
little box that cluster of Pawns but
there must be a knockout blower if the
engine's reacted maybe we can see the uh
stockfish suggestions here which is the
computer thing is there just one move to
win here for Levon or is there uh are
there more options simply and wow the
best move by far wow according to the
computer is to just take this Pawn back
calmly with the Knight this is not easy
because there are so many tempting other
options but uh maybe we can show this
after Pawn takes Pawn in the current
position uh Knight takes Pawn is by far
the best move really really calm maybe
five though yeah C5 and I guess the
White Knight jumps in uh with a nasty
double attack on the next move
Pawn drops well wow really calm yeah not
obvious James right yeah wow not
obviously tall and feather say of a Kate
Levon didn't find that he took this Pawn
instead the wrong Pawn there and feather
save now has had a chance to jump in
with his Knight there's a nasty nasty
threat on the board with a night check
hitting the king hitting the Rook but
Levon first has a move to get out of
this fork and I'm expecting him to drop
one of the two white Knights into this
Square I'm not sure which one but uh he
can jump in with either of these two
knights that's a check it's a race it's
messy but uh it feels like it's slightly
in White's favor you give the first
check and again I called it wrong we're
getting all of the moves wrong here
because it is so messy it is so
complicated but same idea love on
aronian next move will jump in with his
Knight to the square with a check wow we
see the eval bar saying that Lavon is
doing well but we remember what happened
in game one completely winning position
for love and you can't call it till it
is done there are still threats for
black black is also threatening a fork
on C3 currently but ferocyv his biggest
problem in this position James is the
clock he's down by more than three
minutes how critical is that going to be
100 critical but of course a fair to
save is actually very very strong big
fish on chess.com he's a really big fish
especially with that big rating he has
in Blitz and bullet so of course uh
Lebron aronia doesn't play that much
bullet as much but he is very strong and
he's up time right now he doesn't have
to play bullet chess he has an extra
four minutes right now coming up on four
minutes so he can use this time as he
did in the last game too as well and try
to convert this uh this slight Advantage
he has right now
yeah and uh I'm really worried about the
clock time feather save if he doesn't
calculate correctly right now as well
it'll be an immediate knockout uh so one
minute is bad but uh he's investing it
because he needs to find something
magical he's not even going for the
obvious move most would just take that
Knight back with the black rook and then
think later but what else could he be
considering I think the problem is he
thinks Rook takes Knight which is the
obvious recaption he's finally played he
thinks he's losing because the white
king up he played it before I could say
it slides up the board hitting two
pieces at the same time The Rook is
under attack and that Rook is needed
there to protect the Knight so Federal
said recognize his position as falling
apart and there's nothing he can do to
hold it he usually it's like to stare
with each other right there's the
stretch and it's not a stretch to say
the levada is winning this game because
if the Rook protects the other Rook the
Knight Will hop in with check at long
last and this is big problem for federal
sale yeah huge problem maybe we can show
this uh Robert because that is the key
variation it's a double attack hitting
the Rook hitting the Knight you can't
hold both together but if you defend
your fellow Rook then this Knight check
finally does arrive and at the end it is
a fork you hit both Rooks and if the
Black Brook moves with a check you can
step safely forward to take this Black
Knight something's dropping and uh it
looks like with the loss of material
will be the loss of the game for feather
save well the clock is dropping right
now he needs to make a move he's down to
30 seconds 35 seconds on the clock big
questions to be answered this could be
game over this very second he takes a
very drastic decision he sacrifices
material gives up an exchange
pure desperation he had to do something
and it was better to lose the exchange a
rook for night rather than lose a whole
piece wow so yeah I don't see anything
in the game David
um
I actually like it because what he's
doing is he's trying to treat everything
on the queen side and he said you may
have a rook I'll have a knight but if we
have two Rooks and three pawns against
Rook Knight and three pawns that does
give legitimate chance of knights they
are better pieces when pawns are only on
one flank and that would be the case
here so Lavon is thinking do I just take
this Pawn with my Rook or maybe I can
actually sacrifice my extra Rook for
that night and then go forward with a
pass pawn and win the ensuing rook and
pawn and game it's a big moment for
Levon thankfully for him he has time to
calculate it yeah that's what the top
players do they save their time for
later when the calculation is really
essential and okay he goes for the kind
of Safety First simple approach he's
still a rook for night up but as Robert
says the game will take a slower turn as
uh for the safe here tries to set up a
fortress he needs to eliminate that
remaining white Pawn there we go and now
he's going to bring his Knight back
towards the king side towards the pawns
he's going to try and find a safe Square
to Anchor it on and uh it's not easy for
Levon Iranian to win this one a nasty
check first of all the white King has to
be careful where it steps there might be
some nasty night Forks but yeah it's
this one will be very difficult to
defend for Felicia it feels like it
should be winning for white but not easy
uh to convert yeah this is actually I
mean honestly especially if the time is
low but he has four minutes so he
shouldn't walk into a fort we say
shouldn't you never know sometimes
especially when time gets lower but yeah
the Rooks I mean you obviously want to
favor the side with the extra material
we have two Rooks versus the three Rook
Knight versus the three of course the
rook and Knight can definitely hold in
many positions especially if we get to
Knight to F5 like we saw with the
Fortress that Fabi and Liam lay had so
you know in that game you could set up
some things here it is going to be a
play but he's going to play that clock
look at that clockwise you see he's out
of time yeah one of the issues I I would
say from looking at this from White's
perspectives I don't see an obvious win
like what's the winning plan not just
what's the next move but how do I win
this game and I think that if black can
get that Knight stabilized somewhere and
it likely will hop backwards and towards
the king side I actually don't clearly
see how white makes progress as the
Knight is doing a great job defending
the loose Pawn
fully agreed one wow there's someone a
little helper there at the back for
Levon uh being disturbed will this
distract him from his game but uh if
white could swap off one set of Rooks
it's an easy win Rook versus knight
you'll win that one you'll convert it at
the right moment you'll sacrifice and
witness and pawns but uh while one set
of Rooks remain on the board uh for
black there is always going to be some
hope yeah whatever happened that Lavon
wasn't too happy about that little
disturbance because this is such a
critical moment he wins this and he goes
back up to the Winner's bracket should
white keep that one extra pair of Rooks
on the board or should he try and trade
that off David uh White would love to
trade off Tanya as I mentioned if the
Rooks come off if one set of Rooks come
off easy win but uh feather save will be
the one dodging that avoiding that here
I'm expecting Levon to drop his Rook
back to block this check to offer that
trade but uh he could well March forward
with his King instead what is he
deciding the answer to your question
Tanya I think we'll come now will white
accept the trade or at least ask for the
trade or will he Dodge it and remember
the truth three minutes though against
12 seconds it's hard to believe likes to
the defend with no time on his clock
but I feel like we've seen this before
right we expect somebody's just going to
lose because they have no time and then
they play Perfect chess our time you
have yesterday in that scramble against
Magnus Carlson he didn't have much time
but he was able to withstand the
pressure and this Knight it can go
forward and hop backwards to a square
like F5 James you were calling out
that's how Liam held against carwana he
had an outpost for his Knight and said
it's going to stay there you can't kick
me from there yeah what's what's King
going I don't understand what levon's
done with this King he could easily have
marched his King over towards his pawns
a bit earlier on suddenly the white king
is stuck on the back rank cut off okay
he breaks that uh breaks that tension
now offering The Rook trade notice how
FedEx immediately said no no trade for
you because uh he believes that having
one active Rook is uh the best chance to
save this game but look at the e-ball
bar going crazy
now you can swap off the Rooks you can
Retreat your Rook from the center all
the way down and he's trapped his own
Rook feder save he has to agree to a
rook exchange and as we mentioned Rook
Exchange
is disaster time for black uh now all
level needs to do is to move his King
away defend his Rook on B2 and the Rooks
are coming off
new phase of the game begins and you can
see Federal save he just reacted he is
not happy those Rooks traded because
with Rooks on the board he can pester
those pawns without Rooks that Knight is
just a lone wolf and that Knight might
get trapped in a couple moves does not
have many squares to hop to yeah I think
you're right uh Robert it's about to get
trapped all white needs to do step
forward there we go defend your pawns
and the white king is coming he's just
gonna Shuffle across and uh the Black
Knight might have to find itself on even
weirder uh even uglier squares there we
go we get to the board just to survive
that's a funny move that's where my
night goes bro like hey hold on my night
goes there bro that's where the white
knight starts again right yeah uh
instead of still on the edge of the
board but the white king is coming just
Shuffle it across push it across towards
the Black Knight the best black can do
is push his Jeep on forward to try and
trade off next move but I don't think
that's going to save you that doesn't
improve the black chances no it doesn't
at all and actually the reason why is
because the night will still be stuck
there and white would then be playing up
a rook essentially and the rookers are
attacking black spawn so this is what
Lavon is doing he's saying your knight
is offside it's not getting back in the
game and now the Rook is free to start
challenging black but Federal Sav he's
doing this the best he possibly can he's
trying to challenge this Pawn if he can
trade more pawns right Rook versus
knight if there are no Pawns of the
world that would be a draw so if fedo
gets lucky and he can trade these last
two pawns he will have a shot but look
at Levon he's a man on a mission he is
not going to blow this one yeah he
shouldn't blow this one he's got enough
time he needs to just kind of sit on his
hands and just wait and there we go look
at his last move just waiting passing
the move to black black has to worsen
the position of his King unfortunately
with the Knight you can never pass you
can never just pass the move back to
your opponent Rooks can always wait and
now Levon can he find a winning plan he
would love to move the king towards the
Knight but still not easy to trap it not
easy to attack it because White's pawns
are slightly weak still some work to be
done can we find a winning plan here
that's the big question crazy yeah chess
is hard like we're not gonna figure out
that what's the winning plan here right
I was even looking like Rook B8 maybe I
mean setting up traps obviously if
Knight takes work f8
um but then I wanted to go Rook B6
because if I go Rook B8 he might go back
to G4 there so uh Rook B6 but then if G5
I could check and in King G4 maybe I go
F5 there though let's just show some of
these ideas that you're looking at maybe
B8 setting up this trap as you mentioned
a nice little skewer there uh but if the
king moves forward then you want to
attack this Pawn it's on the board okay
wow it's on the board he's actually gone
the other way here uh he's defended his
Pawn now and this looks very very strong
for levonne Iranian this Knight still
simply trapped actually you don't really
want to move the king either because
suddenly you might get trapped on the
edge of the board you might get
checkmated uh with the king so you're
kind of running out of moves if you push
this Pawn forward he has just done this
now white can make a past Pawn of his
own run through to Glory
it's very critical for him to not trade
these pawns as you said more pawns on
the board more chances for white to win
but why is left having a think right now
you've got to push the F Pawn Yeah play
does become very forced after that very
forcing black knight comes in now white
dominates that black knight the white
king nicely nice opposition yeah he was
just calculating this I think he's
worked out that his Pawn is going to run
through and it will cost black his night
I don't think you should push the pawn
now or at least if you do you need to
calculate for a very very carefully
because black snipe wants to sacrifice
itself for the white porn and the black
pawns are going to start running uh if
you can win that Black Knight without
giving up your white Pawn that would be
the smoothest uh simplest technique nice
move on that's beautiful that's it game
over if you start pushing the Jeep on
you can also hit the Knight on H5 by
sliding The Rook up G4 on the board he
does it and the F Pawn will March down
the board yeah great play by Lavon there
because if he slipped it could have
still been a draw but he gives Federal
save no chance here comes his F Pawn
it's gonna become a queen and there's
resignation Levon aronian he moves on
LeBron
LeBron Levon does it with a win and the
best stuff too it is Levon who will be
going back to the Winner's bracket it is
the end of the road for federal safe
could have been a very different night
every fantasy have had his moments in
the chessable Masters day one he almost
knocked out Hikaru Nakamura but today
Levon was the better player Robert yeah
Levon had the upper hand in both games
it was clear that he was playing great
chess and Lavon yesterday he won his
first game against Wesley so he stumbled
after that but he is a great player
Federal save he missed his chances
yesterday he didn't really have any
chances yeah and that was because of the
Fantastic play by Lavon let's Deep dive
into the action with our Lee soweta
learning points
oh
today's learning point is about knowing
your opponents if you know their
strengths their weaknesses you can form
a matched strategy that might give you
better chances to win the game here
leonoronian is in the end game but he
actually traded off the Queens very
early in this game he traded them off on
move Four Queens came off and fellas are
very attacking very Dynamic player was
unable to get his type of position was
unable to get any activity in the game
Levon later went on to win The Exchange
and I just want to show an action replay
of how he finished it off really tense
position here it looks like the Black
Knight the black king are holding off
the white Army the white Rook is
temporarily passive holding this Pawn
but he found the right moment Levon to
go active with this Rook bringing it to
B8 to the top of the board now relying
on this trick that Knight takes porn
does walk into a nasty check picking up
the Knight when the king moved he just
simply brought his Rook across and black
is in zuk Swang there's nothing black
can do without worsening his position he
was forced to push his Pawn forward and
live on Levon correctly realized he
could make a passport I just want to
show one final move to uh wrap this one
up a really nice idea here not getting
Hasty not getting carried away with
pushing the pawn because the Black
Knight can sacrifice itself but
domination that is the key to Black
Knight is on a bad Square anyway so
shuffling The Rook across and going for
this Knight clinched the game the Knight
is trapped and after a couple more moves
the white porn was free to run forward
and make a new Queen nice technique from
level neronian
and with that 11 advances to the winner
bracket create technique that these are
our results of the loser's bracket it's
not over yet as we've got Armageddon
action coming up with Magnus Carlsen
taking on Liam the bids will be will be
with us shortly with joining us
right now is the winner of the match
Levon or onion Levon congratulations
thank you very much Levon not just the
result not just the score line but you
have reasons to be very pleased with the
quality of your play today
from our place than yesterday for sure
what do you think what is it that worked
for you in today's match against fedexev
at some point I told myself that I have
to play faster and because I've been
playing too slowly yesterday but also I
think today uh in the first game I I
also managed to spoil it
although it looked very promising I was
done on time I didn't see a simple
tactic but generally I think the
positions that I've got today I mean
especially in the second game it was
such an easy position for me to play
that uh
once I got this Knights I I felt that
I'm going to win
yeah Lavon congratulations I mean that
was a great match Victory and we have to
ask there's somebody who walked behind
you so where are you playing from and
who was that
so I'm in a hotel in Egypt
and some uh well I I asked the general
manager of the hotel if he could provide
me some space to play my matches and he
kindly provided his uh
room you know the
his office
and there there was a some guy who was
responsible for for watering the plants
and I was trying I was trying
to manager forgot to notify that nobody
should enter here
great job of on you won today I always
like to call you LeBron aronian uh sir
so Lavon um you you know I've noticed
that you know you stretch when you when
you're like comfortable or when you're
winning just like I've noticed this from
games when you're winning so is this
something that you actually know or is
this something that you do when you're
when you're winning you just like
stretch and you do the head not like
this so I wanted to know is that
something you actually know that you're
doing
it's a never stick man isn't
here something it's sort of a stretching
or some sort of psychological thing I I
can't really control it it's some sort
of a tick that I have and as you
probably know most of the grand Masters
are
pretty screwed up people so it's one of
the
ways you know I I relax I guess I don't
know it's
unvoluntarily so I have to really
stretch my back sometimes
love it fantastic play today uh 11 and
you will be back in the winners bracket
tomorrow how are you feeling about this
double elimination bracket do you enjoy
this format
folks it's so confusing I have no idea
who
all I know that the time that I'm
playing it
so it's the same time so
I think uh it would be best if in order
to confuse us even more we had to start
at different times and then play a
different game you know or the bishop
moves as a rook or something like that
I love thank you so much we do have
action coming I love this
well we're really excited to see you
back tomorrow in the winners bracket
thank you so much Lavon for joining us
and good luck for tomorrow
wow we will be having the winners
bracket later on but before that we're
gonna go into a short twitch break
[Music]
he is the chess streamer of the Year
Levy Rosman has arrived on chessable you
want to know how to counter the Sicilian
the French the Carol then Levy shows us
the way with one info he brings
masterful technique to bring in those
wins with white head over to
Chesterville and start up in your game
today use the command to Master One E4
and if you want to play some chess in
the Bahamas so get ready to play in the
international Juan Chess Championship
there is a lot of action coming up and
earlier on our very own David Howell
visited the Norwegian business school
this is what happened
introducing World quad the partner of
the Champions chess tour and chess.com
[Music]
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
[Music]
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists that sounds very exciting
you put your skills in practice in a
case competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up
worldquant is seeking new talent and new
energy and it's looking at the world of
Chess to help because nobody knows how
to analyze a position better than a
chess player right no Quan experience no
problem so do you think you have what it
takes to compete in the international
Quant championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
[Music]
wow definitely get ready for the
international Quan Championship but
right now it is time to get ready for
the Armageddon this is going to be a lot
of fun because take a look at the format
these are the regulations we've got a
bidding Armageddon and we know what that
means a lot of excitement the player who
bids the lower time wins the Armageddon
gets to decide the color the player who
picks the black pieces and it's usually
the winner of the bed who wins who takes
the black pieces gets the time that they
bid for base time is 15 minutes so white
would start with a 15 minute but black
has got result odds which means that
white has to win on demand a draw means
that black wins the match Magnus Carlsen
what is he going to bid Robert I don't
know what the number is but he's gonna
bid lower than the M late that I can
assure you he's so good David with these
Mind Games we remember in the Athens
Masters how he outfit Hikaru are you
expecting him to
it did back far yesterday we should
mention against our team I think you've
been a bit too low Magnus Carson under
eight minutes and in the end the time
really counted he blundered his Queen
and ended up getting checkmated so he'll
go low but how low will he go that's the
big question and Liam I think we'll be
happy with the white pieces he'll be
happy in that masculine situation you
want to know how low he'll go well we've
got the bids let's reveal the players
bids for our Armageddon and wow James
how close was this Magnus Carlsen
bidding 10 minutes 29 seconds takes the
bit James how does he do this I don't
know how he does this I mean it's just
literally a mind it's the Magnus effect
he just knows what you're thinking at
all times especially in this building
with the armor getting here he's going
to take the black pieces against that
hey if I draw I win if I win I win and
Liam is going to be under some pressure
yeah and Robin I have to say Magnus wins
this bit by almost just 30 seconds just
about 30 29 seconds to be exact right
and that is just insane which means he
gets to pick the colors but not that big
a Time Advantage for Liam then yeah
Magnus can thank Fabiano because they
play this Armageddon match yesterday
Liam spin way too low for his own good
and five gonna punish him so after
seeing that Max like he's not gonna do
that again I can actually start with
more time than I have in other matches
still get the black pieces still get
drawds still have good chances yeah
he's won the bid he's taking black
taking black 100 100 yeah we've seen
Magnus he knows that if he doesn't need
to lose he can shut up shop and he's
very good at being solid when he wants
to be so he'll take black he'll take 10
and a half minutes and he'll be happy
surely but Leanne really hasn't given
him too many chances in the rapid
whether it was white or black both games
just amazing play by Liam yeah but Liam
needs amazing play plus more in order to
beat Magnus in this next game if Magnus
chooses black so it's not going to be
easy for him James draw will just not
cut it out and that is what Magnus needs
games were drawn two games were drawn so
Liam gonna have to take some risk here
he's like oh go ahead take as many risk
as you want you'll lose or we can play
something quiet and go to a draw guess
who wins there I do right you get
eliminated so this is elimination on the
break of elimination really especially
when you have those two chances to
either win or Draw the game and get
black with black ladies and gentlemen
fasten your seat by the time we're
getting is about to start Liam we'll
start with the white pieces 15 minutes
on the clock Magnus will have 10 minutes
and 29 seconds as he outbid Liam Magnus
plays with the black pieces he needs
just a draw to win the match Liam will
be knocked out in that case Liam has to
win on demand he has to win on The Mod
and he might have to pick a new opening
last time he chose the Catalan but
Magnus equalized effortlessly very
easily Magna showed his preparation and
unless Liam's been studying in that last
break then uh yeah he needs some
something new need something completely
different to catch Magnus off guard not
going to be easy and Liam's also a very
kind person he's a lot of respect for
every opponent not just Magnus you have
to lose all respect in Armageddon you
need to flag your opponent you need to
use the clock as a weapon and right now
you know Magnus he's had been shielded
with increment doesn't have that anymore
so Liam has to play quickly play sharply
and just say to Magnus you know what I
may be a solid player but here I have to
go all in yeah Shameless flagging is
recommended in the Armageddon are you at
all expecting a king's Indian today uh
James you're not a king's Indian today
unfortunately but of course Kings
Indians can you can go quietly in King's
Innings you can play them to a draw or
win actually with King's Indian but I
think he's just going to go with
something solid maybe a nimso Indian or
even a ragozan or even Queen's camber
decline something that he's used to play
yeah E6 right some something cool here
okay maybe yeah and queen's game of
decline Here We Go Again wow what is
this station
another Catalan and Magnus is the one
thinking early dose it's a bit
surprising his last black game he
equalized very very easily and I would
say if you if it's not broken why fix it
and uh okay why is he thinking it is a
race against the clock I think it's a
bit psychological because Magnus is not
one of the players who likes to repeat
the same opening over and over again so
even though he had success with it just
a moment ago he says I'm not going to
play the same line and this is actually
what both players want Magnus well
prepared but for lamb it's not just a
simple straightforward symmetrical
structure in fact white has the bishop
pair now but White's Pawn structure is a
bit compromised yeah I don't like this
Choice by Liam Magnus has used this
exact line himself multiple times he won
a really nice game against Anish giri a
few years ago as white in this exact
variation with those double day pawns uh
so if Magnus isn't kind of played it as
white he knows what's going on he'll
know the antidote he'll know how to play
it as black I think Liam should have
picked a different line different
opening 100 I mean I think already a
feels like he's already equalized when
it comes to the Catalan and what's the
best piece is that bishop and when you
get Bishop D7 Bishop C6 in I find that
this is a very cool way to actually kind
of almost neutralize the cattle in here
but at least we get to get rid of that
ridiculously strong Bishop on G2 if you
ever move the Knight you don't have a
knight C3 coming I mean Black's just
first choice I mean all all the way here
now I do like white has the bishop pair
you can try to make some some problems
obviously try to get E4 in that's what
you want in Catalan anyway maybe play
Bishop to B2 Rook B1 but black actually
is just totally fine in this position
like why we're totally fine but Liam's
strategy is clear keep all pieces as
many pieces as you can on the board and
try and run Magnus low on the clock any
trades favor Magnus and Robert is that
the reason why he's gone for a central
break with C5 yeah he wants to trade he
wants to make the position easier to
play and for Liam he's a former World
Blitz Champion the problem is he's
playing somebody who's the reigning
world Blitz champion in a multiple time
world Blitz Champion did we mention that
mag is a world champion in all formats
yeah he's that and the issue for Liam
he's not much as I've seen on chess.com
not much of a bullet player Magnus he's
been playing more and more streaming
these quick time patrols the speed Chess
Championship you name it he's there and
unfortunately for Liam I don't see his
opening going very well I actually like
black Swiss Even If This Were a
classical game yeah and James alluded to
that white Catalan Bishop sitting on G2
in front of the white king normally the
best piece in this opening but Black's
light Square Bishop in the center
completely neutralizes it uh if the
white knight ever moves we'll see a
Trader Bishops black will be very happy
to trade off that Bishop pair that white
has and the better structure long term
look at those white acorns black has all
the chances with sounding very biased
here in the studio but I think that does
reflect just White's opening not being a
success so far if you could keep pieces
on the board great there'll be tension
you can flag your opponent later but
pieces will come off Magnus is so good
to turning things his way and okay A bit
of a mysterious Pawn push there Magnus
now I'm pretty sure we'll just move his
Queen out connect the black Rooks bring
them to the center nothing to worry
about here just rock solid and all you
need is a draw how to fix an aria for
black
now connected I mean I'm finishing my
development I'm feeling good the OC file
is going to open you got weak pawns here
neutralize the Catalan Bishop this feels
like a disaster I'm not even gonna lie
for as a Catalan player here on takes
takes I mean what is this I'm supposed
to play for a win here guys my Queen's
off the board how do I you know this is
this is over yeah at least he's improve
this pull structure small gains here but
yeah off to this porn capture if the
white knight goes and takes this Pawn
back actually you end up losing material
you have to be really careful how uh you
recapture this Pawn okay he brings this
route to the center let's just show that
on the board if you were Hasty here if
you were greedy and took this Pawn back
after a trade of Bishops whoops this is
a double attack a fork and lose a piece
lose the Armageddon immediately so the
white Rook has slid across but now
Magnus is simply going to occupy the
open file I'm not sure which Rook you
use but he's going to bring his rook in
and black is fine I like totally fine
black squirrel for choice because you
can bring the Rook to C8 like David A6
let's open up the file for the rook and
its place and if you take on A6 The Rook
captures back A2 is loose there's just
nothing to Target in Black's version
white is the one who's down upon
temporarily and has to protect other
pawns this has not gone Lamb's way and I
don't think this is biased I think it's
just objective evaluation the position
Liam himself will be the first to admit
that this has not gone the way he wanted
and for Magnus his moves are quite
straightforward which means he's not
even get into severe time trouble
unfortunately for Liam he's playing
somebody who does not lose very often
and to win on demand is difficult
against anyone but Magnus Carlson
sometimes impossible yeah it looks
impossible it looks like white is trying
to play for equality if anything this is
the type of Chess that I play when I'm
trying to draw against those top players
in the world but uh he needs to win
remember Liam and uh looking difficult
right now I mean he must win a situation
you have to
opening choice is very important too as
well I mean Catalan is the small
Advantage squeeze opening right and
you're trying to squeeze the squeezer
right it just doesn't work that way you
know it's very difficult especially in a
must-win situation if this was okay if
you're okay with the draw that's cool
but not in this situation I think uh
this opening Choice definitely is not
going to be uh he's going to be kicking
himself for this one yeah it comes back
to those Mind Games Tanya you use that
phrase Mind Games he guessed on the
clock he got got the black pieces and I
think actually that was the Turning
Point uh he knew that actually opening
wise he would never really be in trouble
against Liam's repertoire he's clearly
done his homework against the Catalan
Magnus and uh Liam meanwhile because he
was maybe affected by those Mind Games
chose wrong in the opening he chose an
opening that Magnus knows everything
about you need to catch him off guard
you need to provoke him uh if you want
to take him down but as Robert says
those pawns have disappeared from the
board the whole Queen side is going to
be liquidated you can imagine the black
people and despairing maybe the white
apron will disappear and if play
switches just to one side of the board
White's Bishop pair I say Advantage uh
won't amount to anything at all he does
have this unique ability to get into his
opponent's Minds where we see him outbid
in the Armageddon time and time again
what was most impressive was the margin
that he did it with we were talking
about how low will he go to just get the
black pieces and he barely just went
enough knowing somewhere annoying how
much he pretty much guessed what would
Williams be that's the that's the
feeling that we got with the bidding
that we saw in the Armageddon it's
because Magnus is not just a great
player he's a great student of the game
and he watches everything I mean he
devours chess material he watched
yesterday on replay I'm sure he saw what
happened between Liam and Fabiano he saw
the huge time disadvantage that Liam had
and stayed throughout the game so he
realized them can't bid that against
Fabiano if they repeated that he
wouldn't bid it against Magnus so he
learned from it and I just want to give
a quick shout out to Liam it sounds
harsh because he's unfortunately it
seems like going to be eliminated
against Magnus but he hasn't been worse
for a single move in these three games
and that is something that not many
people can say they have done so Liam he
just needed to play less solidly to try
to get something it's okay to lose an
arm again because it draws the same as
the loss when you have the white pieces
but I really want to shout out the
Vietnamese super Grand Master the coach
of Webster University because he's
played a stellar match he also Drew four
games yesterday before losing an
Armageddon so he's been right there he's
so close but unfortunately with the
white pieces you need to win when it
comes down to it he's not getting it
done in this game yeah but one also had
a feeling in his match against Fabiano
where he was really struggling playing
that active position he never got the
kind of positions that he would enjoy
playing and here we see the pieces all
being trade off more and more which
means it is Advantage Magnus because he
needs just to draw Robert is taking your
point following on that point that you
mentioned the biggest problem here is
that the draw just doesn't suffice Liam
hasn't lost or been worse throughout the
match but it's not good enough
yeah small margins at the top level
sometimes your victim of the format
sometimes you're a victim of your own
type of Chess your own style and here
it's just dead level it's going to be a
draw with best play but not enough and
uh yeah on Robert's Point as well that
Magnus devours the game people don't
give him credit for studying chess he
studies in a different way to others but
for sure every game yesterday both
division one division two even division
three he would have played through all
of those games he would have noticed the
clock usage he would have kind of
adapted his Armageddon strategy
according to the opponent and that's
what brought in Victory today or what is
likely most likely now to give him
Victory and we saw a small Shake of the
head from Liam he's normally stoic he
normally barely gives away any emotions
but he knows he's up against it and his
time in this tournament is almost done
yeah I think Liam should have played uh
the London system of course because he
does have a London courts he has one of
the best chance of London courses right
you have other ones too as well but his
is one of the best especially as a super
gm2 as well very great you know system I
think he probably should have went for
that just to maybe play something
different get some different positions
here because this I mean this was a
Magnus had no trouble at all Blitz the
moves out me Barely Used any time then
he started with 10 minutes right so he
barely used any time here and I mean you
know time is about to be even this is
going to be in a draw and it looks like
Liam is on the brink of elimination
James we know one other person who has a
course on the London London oh the jar
jar base London oh okay yeah the meanest
Joe Bava that is coming your way on
Chesterfield make sure you're looking
for that one well he should have chosen
something else because right out of the
opening Magnus managed to equalize and
we see a very symmetrical Pawn structure
this one it is hard to imagine white
creating anything and we see the clocks
are leveling out as well David is there
anything left in this position can white
create something with that lone Bishop
well that's going to be traded off as
well now yeah I think I think the
question is can black women can black
play for more look at those beautiful
black knights in the center of the board
look at that beautiful black Rook just
x-ray vision across the second rank
looks like it's holding together by a
thread fullium it should still be a draw
but it might be Magnus getting uh
enthusiastic getting excited here uh
James you mentioned he could have played
the London system for example the
problem is Magnus plays the London
system himself he probably knows how to
equalize against that opening it's so
hard to give advice at this top level
because if you catch Magnus on a good
day he's hard to beat and uh yeah Magnus
has done enough just about enough but
enough to progress but I like how you
framed it that I think Lem is a victim
of his own style within this format
because the players who take risk tend
to be the players who do better in
Armageddon because when they get the
white pieces they're willing to lose
some people even in a regular tournament
where you're going to play the same
number of games no matter your result
they don't want to lose they're almost
like afraid of losing it breaks their
Spirit it hurts them to the core whereas
other players like I'll win some I'll
lose some but that's okay and I think
the players who do take more risks the
nakamuras even the federal saves they
tend to thrive a little bit more because
we can't forget even though FedEx just
got eliminated he probably should have
taken down Hikaru Nakamura yesterday it
was just unfortunate for him Misfortune
in that end game that he couldn't break
through and made a slip there but I
think that players who are very solid we
often comment them for their Precision
they're really hard to take down but
when they need a win on demand they
often struggle to get it because they
don't go outside of their comfort zones
yeah and that's what sets Magnus Hikaru
apart they have different gears they can
shift to kind of hustle mode they can
shift to all-out winning mode and they
can try and trick bamboos or their
opponents and not everyone has that in
their locker
also they can play solid which helps in
situations like this as Magnus is
showing really cynical chess but it's
effective chess just trading off the
remaining imbalance now the night for
Bishop imbalance has disappeared
symmetrical Pawn structure will ensure a
draw here Magnus though setting up
tricks setting up potential traps maybe
the pawns will step forward kick away
the white king from the defense of his
Knight
uh Liam has to be careful to hold this
one wow David you're mentioning a
Potential Threat with that Bond moving
forward to F4 giving a check deflecting
the king at the right moment also watch
out four
a potential sacrifice on D2 with the
Rook there are threats and folks all
over the board and Liam is the one who
needs to be careful even though the most
likely result is a draw in this one but
that would mean that Magnus Carlsen wins
the match Magnus looks almost a little
bored right now James yeah actually in
fact uh it's funny the body language
you'll see that even a Hans used to do
that they just sit here like this and
like I'm like are you even feel it feels
disrespectful so you playing anything
like this
I'm looking around you and actually
earlier today it looked like Magnus was
just doing he's doing laundry he closed
the blinds behind him he was eating food
like this mattress was just like in fact
he felt like the confidence for Magnus
even knowing that he has a plus record
on Liam is just saying that I had this
in the back the whole time I think Liam
kinda knew that too in a way I mean he
is down you do you know your opponent
your record against opponents here but
he's going to fight and I mean he did
and it's just it's not looking good
though for them yeah no Magnus as well
he'll feel slightly guilty that he just
kind of hoovered off all the pieces and
just went for the draw he probably
wanted a fight he probably uh wanted
some more excitement today but he did
what he needed to do and he's actually
said another cunning trap in this
position if the white knight now moves
then he can force to draw immediately at
least by uh giving up his Rook the White
Knight is a bit stuck a bit pinned if it
had moved on this last go sorry uh then
nice Rook sacrifice Rook takes Pawn
check and a nasty Fork this is what
white has to watch out for uh next move
the Rook will disappear and black would
be with the advantage four versus three
meanwhile white moved his Rook but this
did allow Magnus now to throw in a check
and just to show what happens if the
pawn is captured uh it has been captured
the first point at least Rook takes
Knight Rook takes Knight Brook takes
Bourne everything off the board two
versus two draw immediately so uh Magnus
continuing in that same vein hover off
those pieces and draw is about to happen
I love the difference between American
English and British English you say we
say vacuum you know until
I appreciate it
it's so special tonight oh
okay okay
wow I think just to point it out a
little bit that there was a nasty little
trap there set up David yeah
yes night I think everyone got excited
for a second by Rook takes Knight it
looks like it wins because after King
takes there's a nasty night fork and
black picks up the white Rook but don't
don't forget about those checks watch
out because Sonny White flicks in a
check the king moose now after King
takes Rook the king and Knight King and
Rook sorry are sufficiently far apart
for uh them to avoid any Forks black
would have been on the blundered here
trickster gets tricked as they say
instead we go to this position limbs
kept the knights alive he kept the game
going the problem is he's still stuck
the black Rook along this rank look how
strong it is just keeping white
completely tied down Black's Knight
holds all the other pawns and no way to
make progress for white and that's not
his biggest problem he's actually behind
on the clock now
we're a little less than five minutes
and a position where it's hard to
imagine white making any progress while
he is going after the H Pawn but both
these pawns are going to be traded off
James absolutely I get one you get one
same same appreciate it right you know
thank you thank you buddy appreciate it
right take and that's really it we got
to move the night you have to take take
and maybe put the Knight on F5 very
strong post for it maybe go to E3 after
that there it is Knight of five plate
and I mean there's no way I'm losing
this game unless I mean even Knight G3
looks good too unless some type of mouse
slip right which we actually saw in
division what was this division two or
uh division three division three right
there was a mouse slip happen where uh
um Josh from Jose Martinez geez Jasmine
lost from a mouse that got eliminated
from a mouse slip that hurts so this
definitely got to make sure your click
game is correct here okay
yeah I feel so bad for Liam he's done
nothing wrong at all he's got this game
going credit to him there would have
been so many ways for Magnus to force
the draw against uh someone who is
slightly inaccurate he's kept the game
going but still making zero Headway and
we saw it for a moment on the camera
Liam kind of sagged slightly in his
chair
um less upright than he previously was
but uh yeah just looking for ways to
keep the game going that's all he can do
at this moment four minutes though
no increment not easy such a kind guy
though like I go Liam and I played in
the same youth tournaments growing up he
won the world youth under 14. and I drew
somebody who could have tied with him if
he had beaten me and his whole like the
whole Vietnamese Federation came and
like was thanking me I'm like I didn't
win the term why are you thinking me I'm
like oh it's because Liam won and I I
understood but you know since ever since
every time I've come across some super
friendly guy always wanting to talk
chess look at new uh possibilities and
he's the coach of Webster University and
for those who don't know Webster
University has the best chess team uh
they are stacked their chess team could
beat most countries Olympic teams and so
he's the coach he's working on chess all
the time he's a great leader and this
time it's not going his way in the
chessel Masters but I think we'll see
him again
and we've seen him have a great
performance in the past seasons of The
Champions Chester but it just feels like
Robert that in these formats being Mr
Nice Guy it doesn't help
you gotta be nasty gotta be nasty right
oh man yeah I mean as Robert pointed out
to me and Liam played gray chess here
this is a draw three draws I didn't lose
right I mean I didn't lose but I'm still
getting eliminated I'm not even lost in
any position in any game correct all
right rookie one played defended the
pawn black advances the King Liam is
going to play it down but we can't even
imagine a possible flagging scenario
here I can he'll get flagged he's the
one who's down a lot of time now but he
created to him he keeps trying to find
ways to keep the game going uh but
unfortunately against Magnus Magnus
hasn't given him an ounce of hope uh
White's pieces are tied down Black's
pieces are more active and they both
know what the result was likely going to
be from an early stage but for them he
kept going and finally there is that
exchange sacrifice liquidates everything
yeah a night Fork picks back the
material gets that white rook and we
will see I think for the third time out
of three games King versus King damn
that's how close it's been how hard they
fought and Magnus does progress he does
and it is the end of the road for Liam a
heartbreaking moment but Liam has so
much to take away so many good moments
from this one he was never was in his
match against Magnus Carlsen but that is
that is the brutality of this format
sometimes a draw is just not enough
which means it is the end of the road
for Liam while Magnus is the one who
advances big moments is the in this one
David what got your attention oh it's
hard to pick a key moment actually in
this game I'll just show an action
replay of the final few moves because uh
Liam tried but uh Magnus was so cynical
every moment he got he was alert to
those exchanges we saw it from the
beginning Queens came off Rooks came off
Bishops came off and here Magnus uh
after locking down the white position
tying down all of White's pieces found
the final tactic to draw this one after
the white Pawn stepped forward we saw a
trade and Rook takes Knight I wouldn't
even have been looking for tricks here
but Magnus is so alert Rook takes Knight
forcing the white king onto a bad square
into this uh fork and that was the end
of this match up simply all of the pawns
disappeared we saw King versus King in a
couple of moves time and the game was a
draw just cynical chest by Magnus but
effective chess yeah wrapping it up as
efficiently as possible with that
sacrifice at the end the and that means
these are the results of our losers
bracket Magnus Carlsen and Levon aronian
advance to the Winner's bracket Liam Lee
and Vladimir photos have been knocked
out of the trustable Masters James the
two favorites of the Elimination
Brackets go ahead absolutely of course
you have Magnus here it was just a
favorite in any time control of course
in any format he definitely Lost first
but this is double elimination now he's
back in there right so that's actually
really annoying for the winner in the
winners bracket he's like oh cool Magnus
is out but he's like oh he's back right
so now you got to fight Magnus now then
it's a LeBron aronian just doing what he
does very strong creative and if he gets
on the road it's a very it's a problem
for everyone
and we've got the winner joining us
Magnus Carlsen is with us Magnus
congratulations
thank you
Magnus you were quite disappointed with
your play yesterday are you happier with
the way chess with the way it went today
against Liam
special uh
well I mean apart from the first 10
moves or so in the first game uh I
played more or less okay uh
but I think uh his choice of opening in
the arm again was pretty unfortunate uh
the way it happened I just
got a very comfortable position where I
could just trade it every opportunity
and then it was really easy
yeah Magnus I'll have to ask you how
have you always managed to outbid your
opponents in the Armageddon
I mean yesterday my bed was pretty
pretty awful uh in the sense that it was
not close to his uh uh today
I was sort of fine with playing white I
thought let's try that as a challenge
and if your bids
you know a few bits higher than 10 and a
half minutes you know be my guests
that's fun
and uh Magnus you posted on Instagram
before today's match that you're out
skiing a different form of preparation
do you think that helped
um well I was skiing yesterday as well
but uh apparently it works better today
I'm not sure why I don't think my play
was particularly better but I enjoyed
air a lot that's fine
Magnus you were grubbing hard man when
you came in what were you eating
everybody in the chat wanted to know you
were eating and it looked like it was
great what were you eating
it's just a little snack
um some
uh bread with
[Music]
um
bread with some local cheese and uh
avocado as well as a few tomatoes on the
side it was really interesting do you
have any left because I'm getting hungry
just hearing about it
no
no actually we should wrap this up soon
because there is uh there is a risotto
waiting for me I managed to have like
two bites before I played the Armageddon
but now I'm really eager to to get back
to it all right Magnus we let you get to
the risotto congratulations and we look
forward to seeing you back in the
winners bracket tomorrow
isn't it the losers
you're always a winner to us Magnus
don't worry winning one match doesn't
make it uh uh but yeah I'm happy to
survive another day uh tomorrow's match
will be insane the tough
uh regardless of who my play
um but yeah
I'll uh we'll try
yeah all the best we look forward to
that thank you for joining us
thank you
Magnus Carlsen there after his
Armageddon win against Liam Lee and he
did make it look
quite easy in that one Liam never really
had his chances yeah maggots himself
said it was kind of unfortunate for Liam
he just didn't get anything whatsoever
in the opening not only did not get an
advantage he let everything to be traded
and it was easy for Magnus from there
well we've got a shot twitch break
coming up for our non-subscribers
[Music]
there's so much ass action going on all
over the world including a very famous a
very well-loved tournament the Reykjavik
open the chessable team caught up with
the players at the Reykjavik open take a
look my name is I am Bjorn tortenson
from Iceland I'm an international Master
forever striving to become GM basically
because my little brother made it as a
GM and I'm doing pretty well I I I'm I
have two and a half out of four I I beat
the players that I'm supposed to beat
but the super GMS are still uh yeah I
can't get past them at the at the moment
I was playing here in the Reykjavik open
yesterday against Grandmaster emra Khan
and there I hit my Achilles heel we
started the openings I only had limited
knowledge of the opening I played and
against the super Grand Masters it's uh
almost impossible you have to be very
accurate so yeah I I hit a wall against
that strong player
wow the action is also on in division
two we've got some results David coming
in yeah we do and uh there have been
some huge clashes as we mentioned
earlier in the day look at the winners
bracket nordebec Abdul sotorov continues
his hot form takes down Arjun eragisi in
form four games uh Dennis lazovic as
well taking down Vincent kymer a bit of
a surprise on paper but not to those
familiar with denlaz and Maxim
vashilograph winning his match actually
a blowout there against pregnant and a
bit of a surprise but Vladimir kramnik
14th World Champion continues the fairy
tale comeback he wins his match too and
uh some big games in the losers bracket
Anish uh Geary Daniel dubov Alex hydrov
and new yangi winning their matches yeah
I just love it I love to see it Vladimir
kramnik keeping up the Old Guard in this
very difficult format which gets younger
and younger and the hair is Vlad with
his 3-1 win impressive stuff he says
moral degradation he's back
hey maybe you didn't
you didn't lose his retirement greatly
exaggerated but Vladimir kremit playing
some great chess I was actually looking
at the games he is informed yeah there's
also some great chess going on in
division three let's bring up our a
bracket in that one and some shocking
big upsets there
yeah no there are some famous K's from
previous decades you had karpov kaspara
of krumnik but don't leave out komsky he
played a championship match against
Anatoly karpov he was one of the
prodigies of his generation he's still
around don't forget that name he moves
on and so it does Alexi serrana it looks
like taking down iterizaga in Armageddon
so Serana he was in division one in the
air things Masters he still afloat in
division three here in the chessel
Masters yeah
lost his match there five thousand
dollars and tour points at stake in
division three but it is back to
division one as we are about to lift off
the action in the Winner's bracket take
a look at what's on the menu it is
another big Vlog taking on a fabulous
Fabiano caruana
Fabi and we've got Hikaru versus a
Wesley all right guys are we going to
see any of those Berlin draws yes or no
David
if there's a Berlin drama fall asleep on
the spot okay
I'll be more optimistic artemiev and
carwana they will fight every single
game so I don't care what happens the
other match they make those draws so be
it carwan entertainment they're gonna
duke it out well I'd love that we need
to be compensated for any of those draws
if they do happen these are the
regulations in the Winner's bracket it
is going to be a best of four it will be
a mini match between the players a best
of all with 15 minutes and a three
second increment of course if the match
is tied we will have more armageddon's
I'm gonna call it out you heard it here
first Wesley Hikaru is going into an
Armageddon yes or no David yes James yes
oh my God Robert no no
all right well either ways we would love
to see an Armageddon the players are
getting ready let's take a look at their
head to head a big fight they've played
each other so many times 46 draws oh my
God
Nakamura leads when 10 wins Westy soul
to seven one thing's clear Wesley cannot
rely on an Armageddon David we've seen
that go against him that's right twice
in the air things Masters a couple of
months ago
Nakamura took down Wesley so in the
Armageddon and remember in the American
Cup they had that kind of marathon Clash
where Hikaru was Victorious as well so
Wesley he's going to be sick of the side
of Hikaru right now but he needs to go
in the attack he needs to take him down
in normal time before it gets to that
stage yeah
that is a big fight as well I think that
is going to be all-out fireworks in the
four rapid games I'm gonna expect the
unexpected in that one but we do have
liftoff it seems with Hikaru and Wesley
the Wesley he doesn't even know that the
game has started so here he comes he's
got some cats that are often hanging
around and he will probably play E5 and
oh no are we gonna see it oh my God it's
gonna it's happening early days
laughing yeah I need a pillow the car's
laughing oh my goodness don't do it
don't do it I'm about to go to sleep
okay the Italian game the scotch the
four nights anything just not the Berlin
draw and uh we've seen some Anarchy
villains between these two I'm hoping
for an anti-bull and push the Deep one
push the Deep ones
we can breathe and uh this is actually
something that occurred during the
American Cup Hikaru was playing D3 the
Black Knight would jump into the center
very quickly and uh the games were very
balanced I've got to say a few drawers
here and that but at least we see some
action a bit later on and this last
bishop move dropping back has surprised
Wesley it's not typical not normal it's
very reminiscent however of that game
earlier between fedasev and level
running you know time and time again we
saw that 14 move Berlin jaw with the
queen check and the Perpetual uh not the
Perpetual but the repetition being
played out and I really think that it is
the flag that the two players got for
repeating that draw James that has
discouraged them from doing that and
that's the reason we see an auntie
Berlin today absolutely of course I mean
hikara wants to fight you know he's uh
this is a big match of course and if I
can take it to you or maybe mix it up a
little bit maybe we've got 46 draws I'm
like I don't I'm tired of this like I'm
coming man bro how many draws does it
take right so we want to actually fight
this time and I like the choice for
mikaru Auntie Berlin yeah and that's the
beauty of a four-game match that is time
to take risks if it was just a two-game
match neither side really wants to push
forward and neither side wants to kind
of gamble but uh even if something goes
wrong for white hair for example Hikaru
will have three more games to strike
back I really like this format and okay
the game is alive there's only been a
trade of one set of nights so far the
other white knight is coming back to
replace uh it's departed counter its
departed fellow there on F3 and black
still needs to Castle Wesley so needs to
get his King to safety needs to get his
Bishop out of the center at some time uh
sometime soon before it gets trapped and
it's very balanced I've got to say I
like Black's position it's solid but
still plenty ahead plenty ahead and not
just on the Hikaru Wesley matchup we are
about to kick off vladislav our tummy
have starting with the white pieces
against Fabiano caruana I am not
expecting a Berlin in this one Robert
um or an auntie Berlin you know I wasn't
gonna expect it either because Artemis
doesn't play E4 so it'll be hard to get
to the Berlin understand what you're
saying the spirit of the question is
that these two will fight for artemiev I
think giving away the white pieces that
would not be very bright and for Fabiano
he loves the game of chess he always
plays I don't I can't think of a single
short draw he's made unless it's the end
of a term of the secures him first place
I can't think of casual short draws yeah
it's one of the most fighting players at
the top level there Fabi for sure uh he
likes I mean he loves chess in general
he just loves to play loves the heat of
the battle and he actually goes out of
his way to avoid those uh quick draws
more often than not I will mention last
time I played Artemis when I was black
he played white the Berlin against me
and uh it was a draw
occasionally he dabbles but uh not
regularly instead it's the symmetrical
English and it's the four nights
variation I'll tell me I'm opening
things up black will most likely push
his e-pawn there we go and very
theoretical stuff this was an old
favorite of Magnus back in the day a few
years back with the white pieces it
started uh with this Queen spawn
position starting with one Knight F3 but
it's kind of transposed into a sicilian
structure absolutely this looks just
like some type of Sicilian here I'm a
big fan of these type of positions from
the white side almost on the Roxy bind
type but the knight uh Bishop E3 could
maybe be hit with some Knight Q4
sometimes even though it's hanging there
you still can take on D4 right but if
this should be three there's also Knight
C6 threats there's all kinds of things
there so you can also try to go Knight
B3 and even go a weird G4 right Knight
B3 anytime you have these Sicilian type
positions with the Knight on F6 and you
have the clamp on D5 you are able to go
G4 and try to you know obviously hit the
hit the Knight there but you do also can
play in the moroxie buying fashion by
playing F3 Bishop B2 and getting a
bishop outside the pawn chain or Bishop
of G5 I mean and Bishop F4 and castling
uh king size sometimes weirdly enough
even queen size very aggressive but
actually you're you they would never get
D5 off if Black's able to get D5 off
then a lot of times white has actually
failed in these structures because you
have you bind it up with E4 and C4 and
they play D5 anyway that is a concession
or you actually are in trouble sometimes
if they're allowed to play D5 with black
yeah I think we will see the structure
you'll write James uh if I'm not
mistaken this is one of the most uh
principled moves I guess you could also
take on this square but that does
transpose into another variation where
white would be a Tempo down so a bit of
a rare one as far as I know from Fabiana
karawana bringing his Bishop to this
square or maybe not the most uh kind of
typical move at least and already that
has caused our time we have to think at
this early stage yeah and as someone
who's worked with Fabian in the past I
won't give away too many of his Secrets
but what he has publicly said in
broadcasting during the world
championship of 2021 he said that
sometimes he looks for what the computer
would say is the third best move because
then his opponents don't expect him so
he is caught our teammate by surprise I
like the opening choices combative and
Fabiano's reputation sees him people are
afraid of his preparation what he did to
Maxine vashir lagrav in the candidates
tournament when Maxine was in first
place at halftime they came back and
fabulous showed like 25 moves of
preparation and blew him off the board
frankly so I think that you know that is
scary for people and I'll tell me if he
said oh I just wanted to win a match he
beat Magnus he was Smiley but he is
taking this seriously and he is
seriously not you know going to be in
time trouble because he doesn't know
what to do right now and he had a lot of
problem with the clock in his match
against Magnus on day one he needs to
make sure that is not a repeat he's
already down by more than three minutes
on the clock really nice inside there
Robert what you said third best line of
the engine and not to go for what is
most topical because in these formats
David it's often about asking and posing
the most practical questions to your
opponent those slight Novelties that
forces them to think out of the opening
to burn their clock yeah time is money
and if you gain a few minutes on the
clock then uh who cares if you've played
the top move or the second choice move
uh often having a few minutes extra is
worth that small sacrifice and look at
this the White Knight drops back very
logical very normal move and Fabi
immediately with the big threats lining
up the black queen with its dark Square
Bishop hitting that white F2 Pawn
suddenly some big threats on the board
are temet of his heart rate is going to
be racing he's already facing some
massive threats as white and normally as
white you're happy to just kind of ease
your way into the game you normally get
a space Advantage push it to the middle
game here he's struggling to survive
already and four minutes down uh
interesting strategy by Fabi there will
be ways for white to defend I should
mention but it's not obvious you can't
rely on kind of automatic chess here you
can't rely on instincts it's pure
calculation and uh I'll tell me of
outside his comfort zone he does not
like direct play like this one early in
the game yeah it's a very annoying move
queen of B6 is direct it hits F2 and it
stops you from really moving the bishop
because Queen takes B2 Knight A4 you
can't actually play I mean you could try
it 94 but the problem is the Knight on
C2 blocks the square so after Bishop F2
and then King E2 I can play Queen A5 or
sorry yeah Queen A5 is not checked but
Queen A5 I take the Knight you take the
bishop right so you have to like play
something strange here for instance
actually on the light board Queen D2 was
played but that blocks the bishop in now
so now you have to go Bishop B2 castle
and you do have to take some time to
actually develop this dark Square Bishop
later by even moving the queen or
playing B3 and Bishop B2 so we kind of
in a way wasted a Tempo where we cannot
get this we have to make an extra
move to get the bishop out or uh on the
contrary if we would have played Knight
to B3 that would actually hit the bishop
with Tempo giving us uh more time time
being the tempo to be uh to be able to
do more things in our position and wow
and uh I was just going to ask James
last move what would have happened if
the Black Knight had jumped in to
continue pressuring the F2 Pawn Fabi
says no he just gets castled instead uh
not asking any more direct questions but
now this surprises me because I thought
it was possible to bring the white
knight to A4 with a double attack with a
fork and the computer hasn't a reacted
the evaluation bar hasn't moved so this
can't be a blunder by Fabby but what
must the idea be here 94 94 this gets
crazy is it Knight takes Pawn I don't
think this quite works because Knight
takes Queen Knight takes Queen it looks
level but the Rook is hanging in the
corner white does pick up this rook and
wins material it must be in this
position to move the bishop to B4 but oh
wow wow this is crazy stuff this must be
Fabiano's opening preparation I like
your reaction because it seems like
black just hands weight the pair of
Bishops but what black gets in return is
activity you'll notice the black kings
already canceled we just go through line
Knight takes B6 Bishop takes D2 is check
you can't take the rook in the corner
you have to deal with this bishop you
take it the black takes the Knight on B6
and now Black's Pawn structure double
isolated pawns however King safely
castled Pawn on e4 is threatened The
Rook on 8 with an open file and black
will strike with D5 next exploding the
center of the board while white King
still sits there that means that the
king could be in some danger just
because Queens are it does not mean your
king is going to be safe permanently and
I think that this is what fabi's relying
on wow this is so deep and I think
you're completely correct there Robert
this is what he has in mind uh Fabiano
but look at the clock time he's asking
this question to answer me if he's
saying yes you can go for this but you
know that I'm prepared you know that
I've studied this with a computer and
that is scary and uh personally I don't
see what else I'll tell me if can even
try to do maybe you can move his bishop
and try to get castled but go for the
bishop pair get the Queens off the board
it's the safest it's the most logical
it's the most principled and uh yeah the
game will go on but as Robert says black
very very active there
and yeah I worry for Artemis chances
I'll tell me against Magnus it's kind of
a perfect style as we saw yesterday
because his strengths match Magnus and
strengths those end games that kind of
strategy strategic play but automatic
against Fabi he lacks the openings there
to compete he lacks uh he lacks the
dynamism that Fabi has and the line we
mentioned on the board
wow counter-attacking chess already and
Fabi just kind of flexing there did you
see what he put on his shoulder as well
was it some kind of like blanket some
kind of uh a few moments ago he looked
very very cozy in that secret lab chair
but uh very comfortable too clock that
clock he's down to eight minutes Bobby
is Barely Used any time so far this is
going to really tell and our tummy have
hasn't yet finished his development is
white in trouble already in this one
feels like there should be a way to just
get those Queens off the end game that
Robert mentioned yes it looks a bit
scary but you should be able to hold
that one and we will find out I think
it's scary on the clock more than it is
on the board it definitely looks like an
Armageddon game where it's kind of uh
I'll tell you have his bid seven minutes
42 but yeah he started with 15 and he's
just burned all of it and uh what's he
thinking about here maybe King takes
Bishop get that King active in the end
game Queens are off the board what a
move that would be bro stop okay yeah
it's just one of those positions where
you trust fabula king take D2 is too
enterprising we appreciate it as fans of
chaz's commenters but against a strong
player like Fabiana car one like nah my
king should be in a more natural place
but we kind of expect this and artemia
burned a lot of clock to get here look
at it 500 was more than double the time
of his opponent and at this point I
guess I'm asking you guys all right do
you think the five to start thinking do
I not just equalize would play for more
I think he's gonna get excited the more
the clock ticks down for our Tammy F uh
Fabi he's Mr ambitious right Robert you
worked with him he wants to beat
everyone he wants to win every game like
you said he avoids the quick draws
because he's so confident and he loves
the fight oh and uh Chad is saying I'm
calling it now Vlad is going to bring a
big upset while he's already done it
once the biggest upset off the
tournament so far he did knock Magnus
into the losers bracket is he is he
going to pull off another big one
against Fabiano that is the big question
it looks like a pretty level start let's
head back to our Hikaru versus uh to our
Hikaru match up with Wesley and there we
have it wow it was an auntie Berlin but
if this was the position that we saw
David one wouldn't believe this started
as an auntie Berlin yeah it looks like a
reverse filador or some reverse Spanish
type of opening but uh yeah crazy this
Pawn structure I like White's kind of
queen side it looks like a little heart
or a little I don't know what that
structure is called on the queen side
but uh either way I can't uh I can't
criticize Wesley's position too much as
black he's got the center he's very
solid he's got all his pieces out where
do you see the heart and Black's
position in White's position I don't
know with the pawns but I'm just seeing
these pretty patterns and getting
carried away uh these players of course
calculating moves and roughly balance on
the clock compared to the other game
that's good science yeah the primary is
there's so many captures there's moves
you can make into ABCs you can do B5 you
can do cd5 you can do ed5 you can go F4
like there's lots of moves here you're
gonna go see like there's just too many
things here I think what James is saying
let me translate for a second is uh
takes takes takes yeah okay
and then we win a juicer in the end I
bet you didn't uh see this one coming
Knight C1 James that's not a capture
wow what is the ID oh Bishop A4 maybe
and the Knight swing around that is
Crafty he always finds some crafty moves
yeah sneaky guy Hikaru Nakamura uh
really creative will oh await uh the
reason for that mysterious Retreat
that's
routing your pieces bringing them to a
better square but Robert what is the
better Square for that night is it
heading to G3 or C3 yeah usually carbo
had good positions when he made this
kind of Maneuvers and I'm just being
honest I think black's position is much
better here I think Wesley has the
better position out of the opening look
his Rooks are connected his Queen is
more active his Dark Sword Bishop is
attacking a pawn that white star Square
Bishop is defending White's light Square
Bishop is stuck behind pawns it's kind
of like a big pause City back there so I
feel like Wesley's position is better
that said hitkara's position remains
solid the foundation of it is strong but
I feel like Wesley should be thrilled
about the opening and he's just about
even on the clock
yeah what would he call it rotating his
Knights uh he's rotating it around three
and uh maybe it has uh more life there
on a better circuit but yeah Wesley it
feels like the time to strike might be
in the next couple of moves uh just
before Hikaru is able to rotate his
pieces around and kind of uh consolidate
get a grip on the center for example or
maybe go for those exchanges that James
was mentioning but uh Wesley spent
around a minute and a half now I'm
expecting something big from him here
not sure exactly what it is I don't see
an immediate breakthrough but it feels
like now is the moment to kind of uh at
least ask questions of Hikaru normally
when you see your opponent Retreat you
go forward so I wouldn't be surprised if
Wesley so pushes forward in the center
now I actually completely understand uh
the nice C1 move now of course lots of
times here um uh the positional play
from Jacob Agar that is unchessable by
the way but you can also get the hard
copy Grandmaster preparation positional
players three questions to ask what's
the weakness in the position what's the
worst place piece and what's your
opponent's idea so of course having the
three questions there what's the worst
place piece if you go back fact the
night was disgusting oh my goodness you
don't have a square right so it makes
sense even if you take on B6 you still
have no squares if you take on D5 you
still have no Square so he says this
Knight is the worst place piece so he
moves it to C1 to reroute it and you can
do this type of maneuver due to the
nature of the pawn structure because
it's closed it's a closed position so
having close positions mean you can make
lots of Maneuvers like what he's trying
to do right now problem is I think after
92 you may actually have some problems
with the E4 Pawn so you have to do
something there first and then move the
Knight but Wesley has a very nice
position because all of his pieces are
developed he doesn't have any really
worse place pieces really right now so
he actually is doing a little bit better
even though the engine says actually
probably slightly better for black I
mean like point four three maybe and
maybe even zeros here right now but
black is a little bit for Choice here
but definitely understand the move from
Hikaru here but his pieces definitely
need to get you know active in the next
few moves here he needs to get active
and he starts by shifting his Queen up
one square just keeping all the pawns
nice and defended
um and it's really hard to find a
productive plan it's easy to see moves I
was going to say just uh one move
threats such as this one it's easy to
spot those one move threats but to find
a kind of uh comprehensive plan is more
of a challenge and wow Wesley attacked
the White Queen and Hikaru felt
compelled to block with the pawn Wesley
steps back so he's actually lost two
moves but he's created some weaknesses
in the white Camp look at the dark
squares around the white king now those
might be uh really vulnerable really
weak long term imagine a knight or
Bishop landing on those squares
especially the G3 square and uh yeah
interesting that Wesley's willing to
invest a couple of moves on that one I
like it right because the bishop was
taking away the nice jump now the H5
score is accessible for the Knight and
F6 and when the Knight jumps to the rim
it's heading right back in F4 and G3
these weak dark squares are explodable
for black to take advantage of so I
think that Wesley he just tried to
provoke a weakness that position is
closed so there's a couple Tempe there
it didn't make a big difference and for
akaru that night that went back to C1 it
can't move forward the queen is in its
Square the pawn still sits on D3 I like
the way that Wesley is managing his
clock and the position but at some point
soon a car is going to lash out and
Wesley needs to be looking out for that
yeah I agree with Robert I think the
last few moves by Wesley super
impressive just taking it slow provoking
some more weaknesses forcing Hikaru to
take a little bit more time on the clock
it's always harder in these formats to
be on the defense and find moves rather
than the one who's got a more pleasant
position and that is Wesley's strategy
here but coming to the point that where
is the big breakthrough David does
Wesley have more quiet moves just simply
improving the position he might have
more quiet moves available but I'm also
thinking about the player's Styles
Hikaru he's very resourceful he'll make
quick Snappy decisions Wesley he's
actually nearly two minutes behind on
the clock because he doesn't like these
slow maneuvering positions as much as
some at the top of World Chess Wesley
likes Clarity where it's a clear plan
maybe it's a very simple position where
he can uh kind of play with no risk he
can ask questions and if the opponents
answer them draw is fine but uh Wesley
here it's very very tense and his nerves
will they hold up we've seen uh hit he
um wisely play games with heart rate
monitors on and his heart rate gets very
high when the position is very tense and
look at what hikara is doing no Clarity
here just keeping the tension and lining
up his Bishop with the black queen oh
yeah some questions though can't really
push that pawn with that Queen and which
is why Wesley falls back with the queen
how critical James do you think the
clock situation will be in this round
one well it's definitely critical when
you're playing Hikaru Nakamura you are
either one of the fastest one of the
greatest on the planet when it comes to
speed chess when you get in time trouble
that's almost an ale just it's very it's
just you can count on him being very
good in all time formats and if you get
lower and lower and lower on time you're
gonna feel that I mean even Wesley
mentioned that yesterday he was like
yeah I was down a lot of time I see a
small head shake from Wesley they're not
even sure what that was about what he
was thinking about but he is getting
lower on time and that is going to
affect it and car was going to sense
that like I'm up time and you smell
blood in the water as a shark or a half
man half whatever he is you know what I
mean like he's gonna do his thing right
when you down time he's going to make
things happen yeah and that's kind of
forced Wesley's hand to take a decision
in the center Robert are you happy with
Wesley's decision of how to fix
structure I'm not unhappy but I think if
I'm a car I'm happy so not that a car is
better in this position but at least his
Knight can jump forward that pawn was in
its path uh White has more plans in this
position I actually think it's quite a
level game and Wesley decides to go back
instead of Ford he just wants to keep
his foundation solid I can't blame him
he's the black piece he's a draw is a
good result but Hikaru I mean he is
showing that he's willing to fight even
it gives him a shaky position and he
almost better than anyone on the planet
not named Magus Carlson is able to make
it look like oh what was the issue I'm
fine right now and if you're not careful
he might play for more especially given
his time Edge
yeah meanwhile both sides maneuvering I
really like what Wesley's done he's
going to bring his Knight into E6 and
maybe into the center uh I do however
feel that that two minute Advantage
gives Hikaru a small Edge uh long term
it looks like the other game is fizzling
out slightly we mentioned that Fabi came
armed with that great opening
preparation but artemia has found a way
to shut that game down good practical
play uh from him so we might have to
check in on that one before it finishes
let's do it now let's take a look on the
other game it looks like this one will
be finishing soon all the action is on
the Wesley Hikaru board but is this just
a draw or is there something to play for
while the pawns are getting traded yep
we're hoovering we're vacuuming those
pieces
the only question is Hoover vacuum you
beat me to it sorry Robert
yeah this is as drawish as you will get
wow that was an illegal movement
hey that's a glitch that's a glitch
a big move and gets up and leaves and
with that draw we are left with one game
in round one of our winners bracket and
things are really heating up on this one
Rooks have been doubled up on the a file
how big is that a threat for black
big threat white threatened simply to
capture on B6 opening the line for those
two white Rooks and at the moment black
can't deal with that tension you need to
commit maybe you need even need to run
away with that black rook in the corner
simply two are better than one and that
black Rook has to be the first one to
evacuate the a file now if we do see a
Trader pawns the white Rooks will have
access to some really nice squares
they'll have complete domination of an
open Line there we go and white trucks
look nice but if they do Advance now
they might get traded off so Hikaru just
needs to figure out whether there's
anything else productive to do right now
quite level I think you need to uh keep
improving your position like what pieces
are bad and we improve them but it's
kind of hard to like I mean the B4 Pawn
is hanging if you go Bishop E3 or move
the queen you're going to lose the B4
Pawn maybe just Rook A7 but then he's
happy to trade you know maybe with the
Rook B7 right immediately and the trade
but maybe then we could mile move the
bishop to E3 and try to go maybe Queen
B1 and A2 but then he goes Rook A8 so I
mean he's going to be he's comfortable I
think well Wesley's very comfortable
here now we both have terrible y-square
Bishops like the bishop on G6 like what
is that and the bishop on B3 is like
yeah I'm the same bro like look at us
like right terrible Bishops right so
it's quite level here I think and uh
Wesley's doing fine but if that clock
gets lower it then definitely that's
when Hikaru comes up with more tricks
and and I don't even have some problems
yeah uh no problems right now but
potentially later on as you mentioned
that James uh if I were Hikaru I just
want to keep the tension I'm not sure
how maybe to move the uh White dark
Square Bishop just Shuffle it to C3 I'm
not sure try and improve the light
squared Bishop again not sure how it's
not clear what the moves are it's not
clear what the plans are but if you can
keep your time Advantage then that will
count later this game will likely
explode at some point having a having an
extra minute might be decisive and if
the board opens up that's probably bad
news for white because white has some
holes on the king side those dark
squares in front of the white king are
blacks for the taking especially if you
could throw that pawn on E5 that King's
Point thrown off the board get out of
there the bishop on D6 will open up so
Knight D4 is a legitimate idea for black
sometimes even if it costs you a pawn
you make a move like that just to get
the E5 Pawn out of the way so I'm
actually looking at this position I
think that Wesley does have some chances
if a car does not start trading off
pieces so he played his Rook up to A7 I
like that choice for Macaro it's not
worth taking huge risks in game one
yep and uh okay he does vacuum off those
Rooks and he does get rid of those
pieces and uh okay what now he's freed
up his Bishop to move potentially but
still looking very very balanced the
more pieces that disappear the more
likely uh this game is going to be equal
but uh okay the clocks as well balancing
out this is good news for Wesley so yeah
the time advantages Hoover as well
I have a feeling that'll be a recurring
theme uh in this match specifically uh
lots of hoovering
and uh yeah looking very balanced I
think her courage is struggling for a
plan because there is none uh or at
least nothing that makes a great
impression and okay he lines up his
Bishops but that's purely defensive
guard uh guarding against Robert's idea
of jumping in with that black knight to
D4 he is I'm that E5 pawn and we've been
talking about a potential break in this
position for white or for black which
all the pawn breaks that are possible
and wow we've got one on the board on
cue but hey Karu says none of that
happening the position completely
blocked but this does give black the
access to jump on with the Knight to D4
how dangerous would that be rather it is
very natural look at Black's play
hopping a knight forward cementing the
control let's go with the pawns the
white Bishop went back to D1 it's just
being very defensive and passive and I
wouldn't be surprised if Wesley decides
to strike we talk about how he is so
solid
two squares he only went one square but
I this might be a good choice in the
long run the C4 Pawn is a bit of a
vulnerability and he's going to try to
retreat his Bishop back on the light
Square as an attacker it's happening
it's happening you call it the only way
to defend it with the Rook it advances
to the fourth fourth rank defends that
C4 Square James you mentioned it the
black Bishop the light squared Bishop is
dead but Wesley's Bishop is now quite a
powerful piece attacking the only
weakness in White's position absolutely
I mean a black right now is definitely
for choice I mean you don't want to take
this Knight on D4 I mean you're just
going to open up things you have lots of
dark Square weaknesses around the king
here the bishop on D1 I mean what is
that I mean if you take it off the board
it's the same position right so you know
it's a very bad Bishop especially with
his counterpart there and you know in
these type of positions Wesley is very
very good here I mean he's even beat the
Hikaru before in the CDC chess Global
Championship right so these positions I
mean are are difficult and the time is
getting a little bit closer here yes
Wesley's down on time but I mean pieces
are coming off and as Pieces come off
the board here and the hope maybe he's
able to hold this might be a draw
because might end up being a draw
shuffling here if you can't make
anything happen yeah but the last few
moves it just looks like a Carlo is gone
on a bit of a defense Robert yeah it
does seem that way I think that uh kind
of I'm still
contemplating that moment where Wesley
pushed his F Pawn one square instead of
two I think Hikaru surely would have
pushed it to open up the board and
Wesley he might be using the Mantra you
draw with black and try to win with
white that's what these top players do
and so I think Wesley he went into this
game Thinking let me try to draw he's
still in that mindset but he could have
taken uh some chances there and played
for more than just a draw yeah we've
seen it countless times in the past
against these top players if you don't
take your opportunities to attack you
might not get any opportunities in
future again and uh Wesley switching out
of that mindset has maybe been the one
thing that stopped him throughout his
career from really elevating up to uh
kind of take take out the likes of
Magnus Carlson on a consistent basis and
yeah just being happy to draw is great
but to win to progress to beat Nakamura
he needs more and I don't see him
switching out of this mentality now he's
just waiting look at his last moves
Wesley just shuffling his Bishop around
shuffling the other Bishop around
waiting waiting waiting if he doesn't go
for it sometime soon I think the rest of
the match he will be regressing that
opportunity and Hikaru I'm not saying
that his position is fine now I still
really prefer Black's position feels
like whiteness with that terrible Bishop
on D1 it's a bit stuck but the question
is can Wesley break through one minute
down on the clock he needs to get the
black queen active how is he going to do
that okay first more shuffling oh yeah
this is actually a great idea here I
might definitely understand he wants to
go Queen F7 at some point but Queen F7
was uh always hit with Knight B6 back
around the D5 so he wanted to put the
bishop on C7 which he did then he went
bishop d8 and he's going to play Queen
F7 but that's why uh with Bishop C3 so
you can put the Knight on B2 because the
bishop was on B2 at first I think it was
on B2 but um Knight B2 and he's just
gonna sit there and I think that's
probably going to be a repetition from
there or like a knight B2 and then just
Shuffle pieces because literally white
has nothing else to do and there's
nothing to attack I mean unless someone
to make some type of break like F5 or F4
that's the only thing that we have at
this point yeah for example just to show
your idea that James the queen will come
across hitting this Pawn the White
Knight will be forced back into
passivity to defend end it and the
question is can Wesley break out can he
open up some lines you need Pawn breaks
you need these levers to open lines for
your pieces I do like this idea for
black the bishop could somehow come out
now from this diagonal Robert
highlighted the G3 Square earlier on it
could sit on the Square trapping that
white king but uh of course every Pawn
break comes with risks and it depends on
whether Wesley so is willing to break
with this Pawn push in the near future
first however he's trying to get the
black queen to a more active post he
tries to bring it to the open file and
white plugs that with his Bishop first
he's pushing some pawns Harry the h-born
making an appearance Harry
my voice
I'm going to get you back for that
I was expecting that honestly I I
appreciate it but I think this H5 move
it's his idea to continue pushing the
pawn off the board that's a big question
and Hikaru says I don't want to fall
victim to an attack over there I'm gonna
move my king towards the center we might
see a petrogen King march where you
Castle them one side and run to the
other but speaking of running to the
other side Wesley brings his Queen over
and watch out that Queen may lead in the
way black can keep pushing pause the
kings of G5 and F5 and all your pawns
can go forward so maybe Wesley did the
right thing he shut everything down and
now he's the only one who could press
forward the side that controls the pawn
breaks is off the side with the
advantage here Wesley definitely has the
edge yeah but just don't repeat just
don't go back with the queen to A7
Wesley he can't push in this position
just a little more he pushed yeah he
pushed he literally pushed the pawn H4
on the board no repetition vesely so
making his intentions clear he wants to
play this out till the end it is about
getting that F5 break he's timing it to
a point where Hikaru has the least
amount of time on the clock to counter
it precisely and I think David it's
going to come down to that F5 when it's
played yep F5 and will white survive
that's the big question you can't play
it yet White's bishop and queen are
lined up on that diagonal but that pawn
break that we highlighted a few moments
ago black will eventually aim for it
first Wesley's gonna Shuffle around
tease his opponent and uh keep Hikaru
guessing when is it going to come when
is it going to come look at that white
Bishop it's so sad that piece that light
Square Bishop that's just stepped back
but it's purely defensive right now
lined up behind the queen just in case
the position opens but first Wesley
massaging this Advantage sneaking in
with the black queen potentially look at
it
wow big threats potentially of some
sacrifices
Queen F1
gotta just chill that's kind of annoying
there it is and then Bishop E1 is the
idea look at her car repairing into his
screen that he was like wait have I
blended no I'm fine not bad yeah no and
Bishop he won next for uh White bring
that dark Square Bishop back next to the
queen to kick the black queen out of
there so I feel like a car's doing
everything correct at the moment Wesley
did not strike with that five he may not
get a chance to and you have to watch
out because black has some weaknesses in
his position as well that pawn on B6 it
looks like it's nothing's attacking it
but later in the game that could be a
problem so Hikaru he's doing a good job
of playing defense let's point this out
right here look at the camera what does
that say back there on let's put the
back what did I say look at that yeah
see the hessible championship
I mean that's beautiful wow look at that
that's crazy I love how I call you out
for calculation not being over
everything but you support me this is a
good friendship I like how this works
possible Masters
wow that's beautiful yeah and uh okay
here Karu plugging those holes with his
Bishops uh I must say there's no one
better I think in chess history than
hikara when it comes to defending but
now Wesley is getting ready to strike
he's preparing that move you mentioned
dying it's gonna happen on the board any
moment Knight D1 has been played Wesley
preparing all his pieces for that F5
break does he do it now yes that one
ever yeah now exactly
on the clock you've got to do it play it
fast but he decides not
nothing decision yet
it's on the board and that means Wesley
is going for the win all out for the win
now and Hikaru backs to the wall
defensive chess I just praised his
defensive skills but he's gonna need
every ounce of them here look how he's
just rotated all his pieces to the
background he's just retreated
everything this is backs to the war
chest park the bus chest pocket in front
of your goal and hope your opponent
can't score past you but uh it needs to
be done and where's Wesley's
breakthrough yeah but Wesley could bring
his Queen to the the first rank as well
all the pieces on the first Rank and
there are a lot of pins here pieces are
hanging I'm not sure if the mouse say
anything we see the evaluation bar
suggesting that it can't be that much
better for black but look at him take
control of all the squares white has no
activity he does bring his Knight
forward but that B6 Pawn I mentioned
earlier watch out because that is the
one target that white can go after
um White Knight can also plant itself
maybe in the center of the board kind of
mirror the uh actions of the Black
Knight later on and while the Queen's
jumped in dived into White's camp and
what is the threat I didn't see it yet
but oh hey to trade Knights
well the nitrate benefit white is the
defensive task feels like this must be
good for black must be good for Wesley
so but 30 seconds on the clock Hikaru is
so resourceful such a tenacious Defender
and the Knights are off oh this is not
good this looks like the worst is all it
is over for Hikaru and we're just 30
seconds left this is going to be tough
but what amazing play by Wesley and he's
still pushing but if the Queens are
traded is that essentially a draw for it
should be yeah absolutely too blocked if
the Queen's come off he doesn't do it
yeah nice play by Wesley so I really
like what uh hikara has done just over
the last few moves he's covered
everything every week Square in his Camp
has been covered now he's simply going
to start attacking that black queen with
his dark Square Bishop kick her out or
maybe offer a queen trade you need to
get those Queens off at some point yeah
the big prompt for black there are no
more piece that can jump into the
position the Knight that was in D4 was
so strong now we're seeing a repetition
and that's a fair time to do so this
position is completely locked up any
decision to trade pawns for example E4
is probably a bad one for black there's
just nowhere to go so I think that this
draw is imminent and it was a
hard-fought game and I think everybody
everyone at home should be happy about
that they did not make their quick
Berlin draw they really fought and
Hikaru he was the one who needed to show
starting defense he did demonstrate just
that oh did he just refuse a repetition
17 seconds what's going on is he playing
on the clock wow is Hikari gonna switch
attack now and just try to flag and is
he going to try and trick Wesley it
feels like he should be the one playing
for the draw but suddenly getting
ambitious Hikaru Nakamura and uh he will
move his Bishop most likely the Queens
will come off but at least he's trying
at least he's putting that fear into
Wesley so he gives that headshake I
think he's just gonna come back with the
bishop yeah there's nothing I mean you
have no where do you try in this
position
[Laughter]
well now the Queens have to come off so
there they go and that means no progress
for either side yeah totally blocked
here uh White will just uh at some point
start centralizing his king that's the
worst piece for white and this one
should be a draw Wesley's still the only
one who can break he's the only one who
can try and play but it feels like
there's no way through and uh yeah white
pretty much has a fortress
draw incoming
that was shocking he just moved his King
away from the defense of the pawn for no
reason he's playing too quickly he's
fortunate the eval bar suggests it's
still even it's because he's more
activity but wow that could have been a
huge blunder look how focused Hikaru is
right now he realizes it's a golden
opportunity handed to him on a plate and
uh okay the black King's coming in
attacking some pawns but uh Hikaru can't
cover everything and yeah
but that's G5 luckily nearly Checkmate
living a Charmed lifestyle way too
active yeah you might have to just trade
I mean because if you have King G3 too I
mean like this is a bishop D4 check King
G3 I mean then like who's winning you
know be careful here so there's a
definitely uh he blundered that but I
mean that's crazy how active his King
ladies playing on Hikaru with under 10
seconds on the clock a moment ago he's
allowing the black thing in wow this is
playing for fire for both sides it's
real but Hikaru has taken risk his
Bishop is trapped that white dark Square
Bishop okay Wesley's repeating the
position yeah will we finally see that
draw I think Wesley's had enough
excitement Bishop F6 he refuses the
repetition what on Earth is going on wow
maybe he's just trying to zigzag and
give away that Tempo and then now we can
go kingji through if he wants I don't
think he's crashing through but maybe he
look at him he's trying to win this game
is there a place
that pawn shop was a blunder but now
suddenly Wesley has all the initiative
in a queenless position but this should
be the third time the position has
repeated Bishop D4 check is a drawn well
I can't believe it because this actually
feels like history repeating itself do
you remember in the air things Masters
they were playing and the car was like
because he realized he blundered in that
Queen and pawn end game and so gifting
your opponent still doesn't lose the
game apparently I don't know how these
super jams do it wow Wesley again
rejects the draw his opponent down
doesn't he can't he count it
the phone down but he's keeping the game
going he's hoping to trap that white dot
Square Bishop he's coming the whole way
round but this feels risky don't think
you should get too greedy if if you're
not careful the white Central Pool might
step forward and break your coordination
look at this the bishop always finding
squares that's a nasty check and uh
Wesley makes the win with only 10
seconds left against it right who is
this Wesley yeah but he has to watch out
because that's why both his kingdom this
Square white was trying to push that
extra Pawn forward to distract the dark
Square Bishop so King has to remain in
this kind of territory and Wesley he
doesn't have a problem yet but if he
keeps this game going too long and he's
the one in time travel that's when
mistakes occur yeah this is such a cat
and mouse game it's just hard to imagine
and hard to think who is
shuffling around with the bishop but
there's no progress to be made they're
just playing with each other's nerves
right now just uh teasing each other
testing each other and we will see a
repetition surely oh that black Bishop
coming back around attacking some pawns
this would be E2 yeah is that dark Squad
Bishop that white has manages to find a
way to attack the B6 spawn it's game
over so black has to make sure that the
bishop remains trapped on the king side
an offer of Trades by giving back the
pawn I think it's smart by Wesley it
might have still been a draw but he says
I know that I have a fortress so let me
just go back to that and they're just
look at this they're almost a move 100
in Wesley Hikaru language that's like 20
games
at least and uh still this position
hasn't changed too much in the that last
30 40 moves for both sides asking these
little questions asking setting traps
and neither side has fallen taken the
bait so far
surely we'll see that draw surely we'll
see that repetition but yeah packed full
of content this game that's for sure
that was just not dry how is this not a
draw by now grind it out growing like a
grand master Ryan right that's right
that's to get that course that's a
chessable course that is a testable
course with Magnus and David in fact I
didn't get it I went to sleep a little
bit because it is like it's like pin
game stuff but of course when you wake
up you know you are oh you're gonna
learn how to grind right yeah that's
what this is so that's everyone's taste
but that's how the top Grand Masters
squeeze out their results they're so
well balanced these two great warriors
and sometimes they just need to rely on
testing the opponent like this and
reacting the game is over it seems like
they've made either a 50 move rule or
they were I think they repeated the
position three times from all sorts of
directions but the game has finished it
is a draw it feels like a fair result a
fair result and what a fight that was so
much drama in that end game the two
really work in extremes either the 14
move Berlin draw or 100 move fight David
take it away yeah we saw that end game
that was so blocked even after a pawn
blunder Wesley so was able to hold the
draw but I want to rewind all the way
back to the middle game where Wesley if
he was feeling slightly more aggressive
could have struck and I think Hikaru
would have been struggling here he could
have been on the back foot and it was
this move he moved his Pawn but it was
only one square foot he pushed it
forward to F6 and the game entered a
maneuvering phase and Hikaru held his
own instead if Wesley had been uh
feeling brave attacking now with F5 I
think was extremely strong the problem
here for Hikaru is you can't really hold
your structure together if you capture
this Pawn The Black Queen jumps out into
the position there will be ideas of
throwing this Pawn forward next some
attacks against the white king
potentially and it's all about this
Black Knight the best piece in the game
giving black the advantage a missed
opportunity because Wesley wasn't brave
enough
I could even stop waving the end game he
kept dying but when the moment really
mattered and not getting that F5 move in
but what a fight and with that let's
take a look at our results of the
Winner's bracket just down one game wow
that game felt like we've played through
I don't know how many games it didn't
feel like a one game uh match there and
we've got a tie on both these matchups a
draw in the Fabi vladislav as well as
the Hikaru Wesley but such big fights
and with that right before we move into
our second game we will take a shot
twitch break
[Music]
foreign
internet
[Music]
thank you
what amazing action we've had and one of
the players who's been on fire in the
chessable Masters is Fabiano caruana
he's had such great performances the
last few months including the bronze
medal win at the world rapid
championship and of course winning
division two off the air things Masters
two punches to get into the chessable
Masters let's take a closer look at Fabi
speaking of that that deep after the
world championship match what happened
after that 2018 match well after the
match I felt very confident I had a
decent 2019 I think like I I tied her
first in the PD Grand Swiss with Wang
Hao and that was an event with with
Magnus and with Hikaru and with
basically all the best players in the
world level and so on and so 2019 I
wasn't unhappy uh 2020 started very very
well I won Vikings day with um plus
seven results and that was one of my
highest ratings that I achieved
2014 2018 and 2020 were the highest
ratings I achieved I was like 28 to 40
or so I forget exactly so so I was
definitely at like a very good level at
2020 but after uh things got kind of
shaken apart by covid my results did did
have a dip from from that point forward
UE improved quite a lot on your rapid
and Blitz chess for the past couple of
years what did you do differently to get
to that point there was a period when I
had some some better wrapping list
results I didn't like put much weight
into it I didn't care so much I'm not
that I didn't care like when I was
losing I was very upset somehow I didn't
take it seriously before the event and
didn't know exactly how to prepare
myself
so yeah now I take it more seriously but
it's already been many many years since
I've had like
I've had some some bad results I had a
match against Magnus where everything
went wrong and I got completely wiped
out obviously I have some bad results in
Rapid Blitz but for the most part I my
results are pretty much on par now my
blood training is so much higher than my
classical rating I don't it's like
almost 100 points higher
I've almost like now I want to get my
classical rating up more it matters much
more to me normal chest work will
hopefully get me back there I think
things are a bit more difficult now
because everyone got stronger that's my
feeling at least that a lot of people
especially young guys got very strong so
you don't you don't really have any
tournaments where you have some like
easier games you know I I'm playing like
17 year olds and they're not only are
they very strong and calculated well and
they're discipline but they also have
fully fledged opening repertoires and
they're
it's things have changed quite a bit
especially opening wise that people are
just like super well prepared and I very
often feel like I'm on the back foot
against these guys
chest wise still want to qualify for the
Kansas now qualify for the World
Championship
would be the ultimate goal and
you know last time was was a strange
cycle
obviously five years ago already it's
been since I I played the world
championship so the goal is to try to
get back there it's it's very difficult
it's always been difficult but it's I
think getting even more difficult
because now we have the you know
established guys who are very good and
the young guys were also very good so we
have even more competition
[Music]
in the world the 2018 World Championship
challenge look at that profile he is
defeated candidates winner of the 2018
and what's been amazing about sabi's
progress over the last few years Robert
just the work that he's put into faster
speed formats and that's what he
mentioned in the video that he's put in
some real work to improve his rapid and
Blitz he was perhaps the most criticized
player in the world when it came to
quicker time controls he lost the rapid
to Magnus Carlsen for the 2018 World
Championship title everyone said oh this
guy can't play faster chess what did he
do raise his feet a blitz rating over
2800 winning some important rapping and
Blitz events he's showing that he's up
there with the best of them I mean he's
working on his game but not only that of
course a mind and body I'm a big fan of
that and actually also uh the chess
players Army if you Google Fitness and
chess I recommend you do that at home
fitness and chess actually it's a huge
correlation right he's now working out
more I saw him with the grabbing a
little weight off the thing trying to
get his little squats on I'll help him
out with that of course get help your
squat form poppy but at the same time
right that man's working and you can see
it in his game yeah it's so impressive
just the level of professionalism that
he has in his early 20s he burst onto
the scene I remember in St Louis winning
seven out of seven in 2014 in the single
cup but he had that youthful energy now
he's a bit older as James says he's is
working in order to continue maintaining
that high level of form Fitness stamina
everything and uh yeah it's paying off
with his results here yeah
yeah he also had a smooth win a against
Liam it went into the Armageddon but
Fabby pretty much dominated on day one
in that match today is a very tough
battle as he does face our Tamia our
tamiyab is also on fire he's a man on a
mission in the chessable Masters yeah
our champion was fantastic people may
not be as familiar with him as there are
some of the other players but he beat
Magus Carlson in the world rapid
Championship he then beat him yesterday
here in the chesswell Masters and in
game one he didn't really get anything
as far been a stellar preparation from
carwana but for artemia he's happy to be
here and he's a threat to anybody
our teammate is extremely scary I mean
he took out Magnus right and he's also
very very strong his rap what is that
28-70 or something like that he was
basically close to Magnus by 30 points
or so right it's insane how strong our
Timmy have is but also Fabi with the
preparation and the calculation of
course calculation over everything is a
human calculator right in a way
fabiana's very good with that but he's
definitely up for a challenge with our
Timmy especially in this form he's in
right now yeah and that first game it
might have been a draw but this Clash of
styles guarantees action and I think
we're going to see it in this next game
we're going to see Fabi with the white
pieces if he can unleash prep like he
did in the last game watch out or tell
me if right watch out our time here but
our channel has been so impressive
especially the way he took down a Magnus
on a day one we will get to the action
in division one very soon but action is
on in division three wow Robert what
stands out to you here well I mean Tampa
to buy it vociro vokidov from Uzbekistan
the Olympia Champions these two are
super strong they may not have the name
recognition that some of the others do
but they make their way up to the
winners bracket finals and down the
losers bracket you've got Wei Yi Mama
jar bluebound and when these are
superstars in their own right and that's
the losers bracket of the third division
unbelievable what kind of strength is
this at the chessable Masters it feels
like an elite tournament just this
bracket yeah they don't need a workout
they're already super strong so James
you can help a lot of people out they
don't need it right now no unite they
don't need it right now of course they
are absolutely pushing out of their mind
right now great chest for them yeah the
clock is sticking
we will have left off
two off the Winner's bracket Fabiano
caruana takes on the white pieces
against vladislavartame Wesley so what's
this after that Marathon game one how
important will stamina be in this well
Fabiano's been working out we sell it on
video but he doesn't need the stamina
right now it's the others and I think
actually sometimes hard to wait before a
game so for Fabiano and artemia they
need to stay in game shape whereas for
Wesley in the car there was a lot of
jockeying back and forth but I think
they're ready for the next game so
Wesley and nicaro feeling the floor
there James absolutely well Wesley and
Carl I mean they 46 48 draws I mean 100
draws like that's what it feels like of
course so many games they already know
each other they're gonna have to bring
something different to make something
work here or something shake for
somebody to get some type of event this
year or less you know maybe they take
some draws go to Armageddon right and
then that's Hikaru favorite there so
maybe that could be match strategy as
well
we should be starting any moment and
David what is the opening that you're
expecting from Fabi oh from Fabi uh this
one I'm expecting the Berlin
well there's an obvious answer from Fabi
I'm expecting him to start with one E4
he can play Everything of course he's
well prepared Robert knows his
repertoire better than me probably but
uh I'm expecting him to be very direct
because artemiev does try and duck and
dive and Dodge and uh dip and all those
things but uh yeah he does tend to have
a bit of a soft Center if the opponents
go very direct against him that's why I
tell me every classical chess maybe
never ascended the heights but uh yeah
the first moves are about to start any
moment Robert I love the answer from
patches of howl hand over here so I'm
waiting for the first move it seems like
the clocks are going but the boys are
not yeah we'll uh we'll make sure we're
up to date on that but uh the players
are making moves we will get the board
updated but it's early stages with these
two they've played so many times before
and we're gonna get I'm sure a familiar
gameplay from these two Monsters of the
game they meet at the highest level
everywhere I have a theory it's been a
Berlin the clocks are on but the board
is so disgusted it doesn't even want to
show it and hecarly doesn't look too
amused either it looked like she was
making the pieces levitate his arms were
just kind of at his side and this is the
position we have so um yeah this is the
position right now and uh it came from
the Italian not the Berlin but very
similar uh type of position so we'll
watch it on this board for now and we'll
get things sorted soon but yeah looking
very balanced we've actually seen these
two face off in this exact line this
exact variation plenty of times before
including in the air things Masters a
couple ago where things were drawn the
games were drawn but uh very strategic
style of play I'm happy to see a
non-berlin position in Italian by Wesley
because it's clear that he knows he
needs to make the most of his white
pieces when he's playing a beast like
Hikaru you can't just rely on the
Armageddon you can't just go draw and
I'm gonna bet all my chances in that
Armageddon it hasn't worked out in the
past so Wesley there trying to maximize
with the white pieces but it's Hikaru
who strikes in the center how dangerous
is the D5 break Robert well D5 is
typical right we just saw Wesley try to
do something similar when he had the
black pieces and you just need space and
this move D5 it doesn't actually
threaten all that much White's pawns are
defended but it's kind of a tale of two
Bishops the dark Square Bishop for each
side and here we see fabula caruana and
vladis overtime E4 played by car one not
surprising he mostly plays E4 he does
dabble with other openings but actually
E5 from artemia that's a bit of a
surprise to me what did he usually play
he doesn't play Carol Khan you know he
plays a bit of everything but I didn't
think he would go so Mainline against
Favi wow in the Berlin will we see that
Berlin draw I think not we might see the
Berlin end game from Fabiano he has been
known to crack that one from time to
time uh what is he feeling like wow it's
a pawn sacrifice a very trendy topical
move maybe asking her tell me if whether
he studied his theory we were surprised
how tamif went for the Berlin he's not a
habitual Berlin player he normally goes
for something else so here he needs to
know his stuff I've faced this a few
times myself recently it's actually very
dangerous if black isn't familiar with
all the ins and outs all the details you
need to get that black into safety soon
is still stuck in the center and it's a
clear Target for white pieces so you're
reporting up as black but you need to be
fast often you need to give back the
pawn in order to complete development
well fabi's prep is out of this world
some of the greatest prep you ever seen
I made took a whole year and uh to you
know um with the with the candidates and
beat MBL and that night or finder was
crazy with the p Sac so here same thing
with our Timmy I mean he was mentioning
it's like oh he needs to know it he does
not know it he's just sitting here
thinking and trying to figure this out
and we already know our Timmy up does
has a little bit of a problem with the
time trouble he even mentioned that
himself in the interview yesterday so
this I mean I've never seen this Pawn
sacrifice either I'm not even gonna lie
here so what is actually black supposed
to do here yeah as far as I know black
should actually just bite the bullet and
take that white Pawn in the center but
he did not do it it doesn't go for it it
does look maybe a bit too brave to uh
actually open lines for that white Rook
but uh now this black pawn that has
advanced it's holding things together
it's blocking lines but it will fall at
some point and that's how we have I
think he just needs to rush get that
Bishop moving get that black into safety
you know who plays his line is none of
the Daniel neraditski Daniel loves this
type of position and it is a pawn
sacrifice but I think as we're
highlighting that black should probably
just say I don't need the extra material
I want my king to be saved there is a
castle King for white a rook staring
down the middle of the board and that
pawn is pinned for the time being it
likely will be won by white and then
maybe black says okay as long as my king
gets safe I will be equal in that
position so I think for artemiev he
doesn't mind spending time in the early
stage of the game he just does not want
a blunder yeah what's he even thinking
about here it looks almost automatic
just move your Bishop break the pin the
White Knight now is finally attacked and
uh when it moves for example jumps into
the center you are safe to Castle this
is maybe the most sensible way to play
is he really considering uh maybe
ponderboard okay it's on the board I was
gonna say is he gonna consider pushing
his Pawn forward and uh trying to cling
on for dear life to that one nope he
plays the most sensible approach of
course Very solid uh play and now whoops
not that one I'm expecting him to Castle
and the game will go on uh often white
will win this Pawn back white will bring
the Knight out this Pawn might fall but
that will just lead to a symmetrical
position
that this is what I'm expecting I'll
tell me if tanking though in the opening
I've seen so many neridity games in
Blitz in this exact variation and so for
Fabiano he's doing what we've said he is
playing an offbeat opening not the main
line maybe not in the second most common
line he's trying to get our team of on
his own he wants artemiev to be working
it out with his brain where Fabi can
still rely on some of his pregame
preparation it's working to Perfection
right now both games Fabiano has had a
size of a lead on the clock the first
game was for equality here he would like
to play for more West Daniel bring him
in bring him in covering division three
right now oh yeah he is yeah yeah
definitely check out the action in
division three Daniel narditski will be
covering that on his twitch Channel but
the action is also on in our other game
let's bring it up with Wesley Seoul
white pieces against Hikaru Nakamura
that D5 move Wesley's still having a
thing hasn't really decided what to do
in the center which pawns to trade this
is a critical moment for white yeah we
left this game four and a half minutes
ago and Wesley's been thinking for four
and a half minutes he hasn't moved he
hasn't reacted I think he just needs to
maintain the tension maintain the status
quo I was about to say move your queen
out the way avoid any potential coin
trades on the D file and uh here you're
throwing the move back to nakamuri or
throwing the question back to him how do
you improve your pieces the central
tension it's not clear how white was
going to clarify it so you asked black
the question you take but only on my
terms
Hikaru looking up now to the side that
normally means either he's trying to
recall what his opening notes say or
he's surprised by his opponents move and
he's thinking oh you can't get away with
that I'm going to punish you and um yeah
I'm not as good as Danny reading
hikaru's faces but uh he's surprised by
this last move from Wesley and there are
two main options right from hikara's
point of view he could lock the position
up in the center by pushing his d-pawn
forward or he can capture in one of
those pawns I'm not sure what he should
do but you know hikar he just leaned in
he's calculating and he's trying to
figure out not just this one term but
the direction of the game is closing the
center good for him because oftentimes
if someone's going to attack you you
want to strike in the center but what
attack is there going to be both Knights
you look at the Knights there are mirror
images of one another right but for
white and for black same situation White
Knight trying to go into F5 the Black
Knight might go into F4 but what's the
difference the F5 square is light the F4
square is dark white has a dark Square
Bishop that can kick a knight that jumps
into F4 so white has the ability to boot
that Knight out of there of course the
E5 Pawn would hang immediately in some
of these positions as well but just
knowing that for the long term yeah yeah
it's a big moment here as the players
decide what pawn structure is to take
often in chess we speak of critical
moments which is why Hikaru is taking
his time here critical moments are not
just about calculation and tactics but
also decisive moments that do Define the
nature of the middle game and Hikaru
takes a very committed decision he fixes
the pawn structure he moves that pawn
forward the bishop on A7 that kind of
kills his own Bishop David do you
approve uh in one word no Tanya I'm
gonna trust Hikaru he also understands
these positions much better than me but
it's not what I would have done uh I'll
just say that the black Bishop as you
mentioned very very unhappy by that
decision and also as Robert alluded to
the Black Knights if they ever jump into
the white half of the board will be
kicked away will be traded off by
White's Bishop whitesnites but the same
can't be said if White's Knight jumps
into F5 and I don't have five or five
that's the rhyme and I wouldn't be
surprised to see that one land at some
point soon still balanced I don't think
it changes the evaluation objectively
but in terms of the nature of the
position maybe Hikaru is playing against
Wesley because he noticed that Wesley
did spend a lot of time in the last game
because it was so blocked uh he's hoping
maybe the clock Factor might be an issue
later Wesley already down four minutes
and uh in these slow maneuvering phases
maybe he'll burn even more of that
remaining time
yet to be seen yeah definitely uh
because you have to figure out how
you're going to get the bishop active
where are you going to put you want to
ideally think about okay where are these
pieces going to go Bishop A3 I like I
was also a fan of Bishop C12 as well and
then Knight F5 and almost I mean just
setting up just hinting that I may sack
on H6 um but Bishop A3 is is totally
fine too as well but the bishop is uh
very bad on A7 he looks a little
surprised by that move over see taking
on C6 liquidating the queen side but
what's so surprising about that why does
he have that expression I think he just
didn't think it was coming but it makes
a lot of sense if black takes with the
Rook then that B7 Pawn becomes a Target
if black takes with a pawn well then the
B file is open so he decides to keep the
B file closed for the time being I like
the look of Rook to B1 I don't look at
this position and think that black has
any sort of Advantage but the engine
obviously stronger than I am saying
black is better yeah wow I'm surprised
too I'm gonna say Robert eight does look
uh familiar with this Pawn structure it
looks very similar to a benko Gambit
where uh White actually accepts the
Gambit and gives the pawn back and it
might be because in this position
Black's next move is going to be to try
and trade off these Bishops for example
if white takes a timeout maybe a silly
move actually I'll give white a useful
move just to hope for argument's sake
but the bishop is going to come to C5 if
we ever see a trade this Knight might be
the best piece on the board it is
attacking this backward Pawn it's
keeping white pieces on us tied down to
this a pawn as well watch out for this
Black Knight to re-maneuver itself as
well into a nice Outpost later so I
think he's playing by analogy Nakamura
this Pawn structure actually happens
with reverse colors in the benko and the
benoni and those types of openings and
he knows that if he gets a knight to
this beautiful C5 Square he will have
the advantage and actually this position
is on the board I don't know if Wesley
should actually trade off these pieces
maybe he needs to step back and keep
these pieces on the board just because a
Black Knight on the Square would be too
scary to deal with
and uh yeah it's very strategic here
these players they're both so good they
never go for each other I notice though
it's always kind of playing for playing
for inches here and there uh playing for
these tiny little incremental gains so
they do lead to these fascinating kind
of maneuvering battles yeah
yeah positional fights between Wesleyan
that's exactly what we saw in game one
also just a little bit
but he saw a hundred move Marathon but
they're definitely in the moo in the
mood for a big fight Bishop trades have
been offered that F5 Square for the
night still up for grabs what are we
expecting in this one the one thing
that person is to watch out for though
is that clock James seven and a half
minutes he's burning too much time it's
almost double the time I mean of course
we talked about this before and I was in
these fast time controls I mean he car
was always a favorite second to him
literally no one in fact I mean Magnus
can obviously keep up there you know and
even he beat him in the speed test
Championship right uh he covered it
right so it's very important to
understand when you get long time you
have to use your time or your clock as a
piece here and if you're not able to do
that or you mismanage it you're going to
get in time trouble and actually Hikaru
will just Blitz you you're going to make
a mistake for instance last game he
dropped a pawn got a long time it was
still good his King was active but he
did drop upon due to time trouble so he
needs to watch that time and manage the
time a little bit better and a headshake
from Wesley there what's that about
David yeah he's just not enjoying life
not enjoying his position enjoying life
it's hard when you're facing Hikaru
every time the Beast uh himself and look
at that white Rook that white Rook on B5
it looks like it's entrenched in the
black half on a nice Outpost but it's
stuck it's completely trapped and you
could imagine some fine day one of the
Black Knights coming around to attack
and when in that white Rook uh that
black knight I mentioned on C5 maybe the
most important piece as well and white
is just a bit stuck the best you can
note for is to trade off maybe black
start Square Bishop for your own Bishop
but as we mentioned earlier in that
earlier variation
actually suits Hikaru and I will as well
just record the American Cup where these
two faced off recently Hikaru took the
win because Wesley was the slower player
and he decided to lash out in the final
game of that one blundering his Queen in
one move just because he thought okay I
might as well go down fighting uh rather
than lose on time lose uh in Armageddon
and that was the decided it's small
margins but it feels like hikaru's
nerves are slightly stronger and he's
slightly quicker and I think once he has
to lash out here because his Rook is
trapped on B5 his Rook on B1 not really
doing anything I think he should start
pushing his pawns on the king side he
needs to break free from the position
because right now everything is locked
up I don't see a plan for him except for
pushing those pawns forward but we know
that if you push pause they don't move
backwards and you may uh regret it in
the future so I just don't love the look
of this for Wesley oliverson at first I
was surprised that the evil barge black
a nod but now I'm looking at the car
does have a slight Edge
the Knight on C5 is such a monstrous
piece just tying down White's Queen to
defend the D3 Pawn you're talking about
lashing out here but where is the big
break for Wesley how does he really
build the counter play on the king side
good question right yeah James Maybe
it's the idea to push this Pawn forward
move this Knight out the way for example
if the Black Knight moves uh actually
bad Square sorry let's move to this one
the White Knight could move out the way
and at some point later on you could
hope to push the spawn forward Again
Play played by analogy with the king's
Indian but it does feel very very loose
this white king will also uh have
something to say about that it will have
questions to answer in the future if you
do open it up so you go for the black
king but at the cost of weakening your
own King very difficult I've got to say
maybe you just kind of in the game
position start stepping forward with
this pawn put a clamp on and hope that
long term you might have some activity
over there just kind of consolidate your
night on this beautiful square but this
Knight alone won't do the work it won't
do enough and it's very difficult this
position very mysterious look at
Wesley's clock time as well oh man under
six minutes you're not looking good
there a clock time is serious here and I
mean I even like uh I mean Pro it's just
hard to find a plan for white here I
mean you want to play some maybe even
like if if the Rook wasn't on C6 you
have things like King H1 or even talking
going King F1 King E2 Rook G1 4g5 of
course this is a nice plan the reason
why we go to E2 is because it's actually
really safe here because the center is
really locked down you also you know the
queen isn't very you know you don't want
that defending the pawn on D3 for
forever you want to actually use the
queen and if you can but the queen is
just stuck here on C2 you have to defend
D3 so maybe moving the king over to E2
playing Rook G1 and G4 and going for
something but the Rook is doing a great
job on a six rank of any type of
sacrifices or allowing anything to
happen even if we get G5 in I could even
go Rook G6 myself and kind of just
neutralize your attack so it is quite
difficult to find anything for white
yeah
that you're saying and I'm
dead that is going to be trapped for a
long time and one can actually imagine
Wesley getting into big trouble just
losing that Rook David yeah
yeah Behind Enemy Lines and he's trying
to get it out now by trading off those
Bishops in Hikaru he's asking himself
look how interested he is in this one
moment he's asking himself can I leave
my Bishop on this Square can I leave
that white Rook trapped on B5 can the
Black Knight start coming in for example
at some point towards it but
okay what is he calculating that's his
calculation face James you're the
exponent calculation yeah you know
what's funny actually believe it or not
there's actually a study I've read this
you can read this actually looking away
actually improves you actually can
calculate a little bit better from doing
it so actually in tournaments I do this
I actually do this you might look at me
strange but at least I'm gonna beat you
on the board because I calculate it
right so of course it actually when he
does this you know I graduated from a
school of Hikaru I draw the arrows I
even look up when I'm eating food
calculator yep absolutely it works every
time works every time I do it when I
usually just blunder a piece where I'm
like oh God please save me right now it
doesn't work
okay at least the Bishops have been
traded off and another trade has been
offered The Rook is coming back yeah no
it looks like Wesley's trying to trade
everything off and this is good game
management he was worse if he didn't
start trading pieces now they're coming
off and frankaru a draw with the black
pieces that's a pretty decent result but
for Wesley given the position he was in
this is good decision making I think
that he understood how much risk there
was for him his position was that awful
so he's just saying give me some space
let's trade and now it should be a
neutral one trade everything off Robert
don't you mean Hoover everything off
yeah you're right it's I think it's just
simply a necessary decision here you
need to get at least one set of nights
off the board you're cramped if you look
at the central structure Black's
actually got the furthest Advanced Pawn
hence more space and uh when you're
struggling when you're cramped take
those pieces off the board Hoover them
off and uh
vacuum vacuum them off if you have to
and uh yeah this one should be safe
enough I still slightly prefer blacks
pieces uh Black's position I've got to
say but we're sleep doing what he needs
to do a small trick as well we should
mention in the current position uh
Nakamura here is calculating whether he
can take this Pawn okay he hasn't gone
for this but uh if he had captured this
Pawn the White Knight would have jumped
out the way capturing a pawn itself and
after it's taken this Knight would have
fallen and actually this changing
structure would have helped white so uh
Nakamura here instead just pushes his
Pawn the reason he did this was to push
this Pawn next Gary the G Pawn will
follow Harry and uh it will kick out
whoops sorry my arrows it will kick out
this knight from F5
so G6 coming next to evict the White
Knight
on the camera it just looks like it'll
be such a nightmare to play against him
OTB because he's so intimidating with
his expressions and body language you
just don't know what to expect from him
he's always such a tricky player on the
board off the board we see this move H5
just threatening building an attack on
the king side the G Pawn might March
forward the Knight will come to F4 we
will check in with this in just a short
bit but let's rush over to the other
game Fabiano caruana takes on a
vladislav or Tamia their first game has
ended in a draw an uneventful result but
it was quite a fight Fabi is up against
vladislav
and while we bring that up a decision
has been made by Wesley to retreat with
the Knight and Robert I see that
expression you are surprised
um the Eva went really far down there so
you know maybe the fact that we're still
in this game is a good thing because it
is sinking and I wonder why because I
look at this position Knight G3 are
attacking a pawn but can black suddenly
maybe take the a-pawn over there is that
the point you take one Rook Pawn I take
the other but that trait should help
black there is a past Pawn in the making
The Rook on A8 is behind that past Pawn
so the Knight jumps forward into C3
that's an issue and I see tactically why
this is a problem for white in the
previous position why I could play
Knight takes D4 this Knight Gets Out The
Way of the queen and then after uh the
Knight takes back on D4 you keep trading
everything and the queen finally takes
on A4 at long last but because white
retreated that knight from F5 it gives
black a tactical shot and now Hikaru can
take advantage wow is that just another
blunder in one by Wesley dropping upon
David yes simply he's forgotten that
Knight takes D4 is not available now
because after the night recaptures you
don't have your knight able to cover the
D4 Square as Robert mentions and yes you
can take this Knight but your Rook Falls
at the very end of this variation no
compensation here for white and game
over and Hikaru has definitely noticed
this look at his facial expressions over
the last couple of minutes he's
calculating this he's just thinking
Wesley you must have a trick up your
sleeve otherwise I'm just winning you
can't take this Pawn what is your idea
if you move your Rook across maybe this
is what Wesley's got up his sleeve
trying to attack the Knight attack the
pawn behind it but again the Black
Knight just jumps in and even if there's
a rook exchange yes you're happy to go
for this and after the move Rook A6 this
Rook is trapped you have to agree to
this exchange and Robert's Point again
comes into Focus this past Pawn is going
to win the game long term Knights are
super bad at stopping these Corner pawns
these Rooks pawns and this Pawn is going
to decide things so Hikaru by pure
calculation by Brute Force here can work
it out every move is forced and it is
winning for black you just ignore this
Pawn on the edge of the board ignore or
that threat just capture that's the more
important Point Hikaru should be winning
yeah no he's going to go for it he
doesn't miss these opportunities he has
the unique ability to just have such
precise calculation in a short amount of
time and not shy away from tactics
resourcefulness I'm expecting Knight A4
any moment and with Wesley down to four
minutes how difficult James will it be
for him to find counter play in that
this is why he blundered in the first
place is because of the time trouble
right as soon as that time gets low it's
just I mean anyone can be substituted to
this even it even happened to Magnus
when he lost and played that Rook B6 or
Timmy evmu game was over he was in time
trouble in fact I mean actually or to me
I have four seconds too but also he was
getting low times too so it's important
to understand when that time gets low
like he's just start moving fast I don't
want to get lower on time let me move
real quick Knight G3 oh blunder right
immediate move here and of course uh
Knight A4 is definitely on top here but
I wonder what else he's thinking about
here because he hasn't played it yet
yeah I think he's just trying to weigh
up that variation uh that we saw with
all of the Rooks coming off the board
and we should also mention at the bottom
of your screen you can see the computer
top suggestions everything else would
miss the opportunity lose the advantage
and it would go back to being a level
game so he needs to capitalize now this
is the moment of this game he needs to
take that point he does it it doesn't
miss this stuff 94 he's calculated it
all and we will be coming to the
variation that David showed us Wesley
immediately goes for the A5 point but
after all that Skirmish it looks like
Hikaru will be the one on top
she will be what could be more natural
just jump in with the Black Knight to a
beautiful outpost on the C3 Square the
line we showed and that should lead to
an advantage Hikaru meanwhile he's got
that Evil Genius look I'm just uh
wondering how should I uh play with my
food here how should I progress but uh
we see the Jedi here with James but I
actually you point out his look made me
think of something he could of course
jump in with that A4 Knight to C3 but he
might bring the other Knight to C5 to
defend his Knights that way he's
removing one of the attackers on his
past Pawn so I really thought that
Knight C3 that was a foregone conclusion
he would jump forward but he could bring
his other Knight into C5 defending one
night with the other and yeah the eval
Bar says Robert you're a fool but I
actually think once if you trade Knights
there then black does have this outside
pass Pawn so it's something that he has
to consider here white will take the H5
Pawn but that Rook Pawn is way less
important than the queen side one
yeah I agree from a human point of view
this still looks like a fantastic
Advantage
um yes you can take this Pawn but uh the
black Rook is always going to guard
across I don't think there'll ever be
threats against the black king and it
will all be about this passer so I
wouldn't be surprised if he goes for
this but nope he goes for the other one
instead just as strong uh Eve if not
more so and uh there we go all the Rooks
are coming off the board and this is the
key moment he needs to bring his Rook
across and he has done eliminate the
remaining Rooks trade on your terms and
at this point is surely going to decide
this game
yep Wesley maybe he missed the sting in
the tail this final move of the
variation he calculated all of this but
underestimated this Rook slide from
Hikaru and uh here we go temporarily a
H well I was going to say a pawn up is
it level material now uh but that black
apron so dangerous Wesley stepping back
to try and trade off Knights
do we agree take that night or do we
keep them on the board I mean I have to
move it somewhere strange which is like
I don't really want to go Knight A4 I
feel like I'm giving him something
specially maybe after Queen A2 like
Temple I'm a big fan of the temple I
worked with coaches before about that
was like I'm just I love the tempo and
I'm like oh cool I didn't I love it too
right so so I mean a strong player tell
you something you're gonna listen so all
right cool perfect you love the tempo
what I'ma love fall in love with it too
92 is Timbo so 92 is a movie 85 just
gave it back while Eva didn't like it
either I love it though he's lying it
yep he's going with Pawn quality is more
important than Pond quantity so he's
actually giving Wesley a pawn in an
unexpected Way Wesley could have taken
that Rook Pawn that clearly wasn't
valuable but this Pawn does feel a
little bit more important in the
position so if white takes on C3 black
has to take back the queen could step up
and capture the black a pawn goes up one
square hits the Knight and we are seeing
this variation but when the Knight moves
away black has carved at the D4 Square
for his own Knight that Apon is a force
but white has a pass Pawn of his own and
that's why you see the Evo react to
Knight D4 white can start pushing the
pawn distract Black's pieces and then
white is going to take that passer that
black has established that's a very
brave decision by Hikaru just sacrifice
upon went very well you could have kept
a material balance traded the knights
and then looked for a way to advance the
eight Pawn he's going for blood in this
one yeah he really is and this whole
variation has played out on the board if
the Queens come off white has an extra
Pawn but I have a feeling that black
porn will win the day that black apron
will tie down white tonight completely
and it should be decisive but uh
meanwhile Hikaru activates the black
queen he's actually giving up another
Pawn that other Blackboard in the center
he's not materialistic at all Hikaru
Nakamura he's saying
he's saying please go take my point if
the White Queen now gets greedy and
takes that black Central Pawn wow I
think we're gonna see a pin that black
queen is gonna jump down to the first
rank that white knight might be gone in
the near future he loves the initiative
he's happy to sacrifice that Bond it's
all about the a pawn three squares away
from queening combined with the queen on
B1 the Knight jumping to D4 that will be
a tough one to save and we see the eval
bar despite Wesley being up on material
it loves hikaru's position this is
dangerous
terms as well two minutes down on the
clock white is on the back foot yes you
report up but you're defending
I don't like Wesley's chances you can't
take that second Pawn either they're
taking the pawn E5 is losing I think by
force because Black's Pawn is way way
way too fast I keep saying it's about
the quality
but here even with A3 for black and the
point is if you try to bring your queen
back to C3 The Black Queen goes to B2
typically when you're down between you
don't trade but here trading wins for
black because you cannot stop the past
pawn and your Knight's under attack so
you kind of have to do something about
everything and I just don't think Wes
can get it done wow yeah it's just a new
Queen appearing on the board and uh
simply no way to stop it so Hikaru right
now maybe there are multiple strong
moves uh this is one of the most natural
maybe you can bring your queen down the
whole way I think this is uh just a
beautiful position for Hikaru he's
looking for other options clearly but as
Robert points out this is the most
natural Pusher pass Pawn follow the
rules and you're gonna make a new Queen
yeah I don't think Wesley's going to be
able to stop it Hikaru spending his
remaining time trying to figure out uh
the most accurate path to Victory now he
knows he's winning he must do ocean baby
position
and is this just completely busted he
goes Queen B5 so Wesley did think of how
to continue after A3 and Hikaru says I'm
not trading because he says wait what
kind of a move was that was that the
reaction that we just saw he said what
he's just like criticizing Wesley's play
he's doing analysis while he's playing
and he's doing it for the fans you know
how a card does he's the big chess
streamer but right now I mean is there a
way out for Wesley doesn't look like it
that pass Pawn is too dangerous the
Knight and C1 is a flimsy Defender here
so I do think that Wesley is going to go
down yeah well big moment here but we
will come back because our Tammy have is
playing on seconds can Fabiano caruana
win and take the lead in his game Let's
jump straight into Fabiano versus
vladislav or tamiyev huge time advantage
to Fabi here wow huge time Advantage
something we're used to saying at this
point I'll tell me if just too slow his
position is almost fine it looks Rock
Solid he does have the bishop pair I
slightly prefer white here just because
you have more space in the center
White's pieces are more centralized than
their counterparts but uh yeah the clock
factor is the biggest difference right
now uh can Fabi turn that into Victory
though another question would you pick
here James I'm definitely picking Fabi
especially on with you I mean when you
get our Timmy up to make Emmy he usually
sits very calm like he is right now but
I feel if you know if we roll the tape
back he was looking he actually did a
little head shaking away a little head
Bob like you see that when you can get
that reaction out of somebody to just be
magnets with a straight face right here
it's a it's already a win here the prep
is working and he's up so much time now
of course our Timmy have already has
time in trouble uh time trouble anyway
here but I mean white has the better
pieces right now yeah we have the bishop
here but better pieces more time this is
a looking bat for our tomato right now
well Fabi will try to grind out the
clock on this one but Hikaru is grinding
down the position against Wesley so
we're gonna jump straight back into that
game because that is heating up and
should what that Fawn on E3 oh my God
but is there a way to just finish this
off immediately you might resign uh
Wesley in the next couple of moves okay
he brings his Queen back he needed to do
this there was a huge threat of black
screen actually coming all the way into
the corner to A1 and pin that white
knight now the White Queen is back uh
able to defend just about but uh I think
Robert's idea from earlier bring the
black queen to B2 that's a beautiful
Square you're completely paralyze
White's pieces and then the Black Knight
will be able to rejoin the action
White's dream here is to give up his
Knight for that black pawn but I don't
think Hikaru is going to cash in anytime
soon he can wait that black pawn is way
more valuable than the poor White Knight
here and if white gets that if white is
able to give the knife for a pawn white
will have three pawns for a night that's
actually even material and well the eval
bar is you know going back and forth a
little bit Quincy to the most natural
move Wesley and time travel he has to
play quickly and if the move A2 is
played then the White Queen could take
it black will take the Knight so we get
that trade so just what David has been
highlighting that it's likely in some
positions that white will be able to
sacrifice the knife for the pawn and
then give him some chances yeah but is
that the best option or does he get his
Knight into the game jumping back to E6
and D4 and asking more questions to
Wesley when he's down to just 50 seconds
on the clock
it's good to me Tanya what could be more
natural just to put the other one on the
board if the pawn does step forward as
Robert mentions white would love to
eliminate it you could maybe wait one
more move but uh this position maybe the
three pawns can at least hold for a
while instead uh here Nakamura he didn't
get his Knight into the game yet he
offered a queen trade White had to avoid
that as we showed earlier and now this
Black Knight is coming into the center
it's gonna sit pretty nice and pretty on
D4 and totally dominate the white Army
white is paralyzed could barely move uh
look at this poor White Knight it's
stuck defending the A2 Square the White
Queen is stuck defending that night and
uh I think it's good night here for
Wesley so he's such a nasty threat
Knight D4 for black and then Knight E2
like even if there's no Forks or any of
that like you can put your king
somewhere else so I'm not giving you a
fork 92 I think still works you take my
knight I push my Pawn I get a new Queen
deflection that's best wow this is how
strong Corner pawns are against Knights
simply nothing to do and that night is
coming in and uh Wesley holding off uh
just delaying the inevitable here the
night's coming and uh as Robert also
alluded to uh if for example the Knight
jumps in if you're not careful if you
move your queen there's also Queen takes
Knight as a tactic and a nasty Fork to
win the day yeah this one's over the
night is coming in to get the win as
they say James you've been saying Hikaru
is your boy half half man half beast
half everything else what is that
everything else and how is he this
strong okay well I mean he's half man
and other half we just don't know what
it is yet but at the same time he's very
strong especially when you get low on
time it's a wrap like a lot of times I
mean you would just count it I mean
unless you're like winning you up some
material you've got the clear plan
there's very few people on the planet
Magnus even included that when you get
long time against against icaro I mean
it's really bad it's really hard he's
very accurate he creates problems for
you I mean even in the game with uh for
the sale like I had three extra I had
three pawns how
how did I make it through right it's
just it's insane almost a magician like
of course Robert
rubber with the tactinos hey guys I hear
you okay he better not be hearing me
that would be a big problem but no I
mean 92 it was a long way coming the
night jumped from f8 E60 for E2 and that
white knight is distraction and now the
black pawn will promote and Wesley does
have a knight and will be three pawns
for a queen now that should be
completely losing but stranger things
have happened especially if you can win
a fourth Pawn maybe there's some outside
chance to survive super unlikely but I'm
just saying Wesley he's not being too
crazy to play on what a poker face from
Wesley I mean I would be crying my eyes
out here but he looks uh
that's mean yeah that's mean
and finally promotes are expecting
wrestling to resign or get flagged but
resting wow Knight H5 the game continues
three queens on the board but the queen
can always fall back no Perpetual there
and with that we see Hikaru he knows
he's done it what a big win by him and
honestly a fantastic game there yeah you
want to hear something else that we
didn't make mention of Wesley actually
offered a car a draw at some point in
the game and the card declined it so he
was playing for a win he understood he
had the better chances he maximized them
now he's a one-game lead
ER with the black pieces he starts the
next game where the white piece is
Wesley he has to win to level the match
there is action still on in Fabi versus
James he's down to 10 seconds oh yeah
you know what's funny I mean yes he gets
in time trouble it's almost like grishek
in a way like he gets stronger as the
time gets lower because I mean he beat
Magnus with four seconds on the clock I
mean that was like oh he's gonna fly and
he was like ah you thought so right then
he actually did the same thing in that
other game to eliminate Magnus when he
had like he was about to flag oh he's
flying and he made it him so when he
gets you know you got to be careful Here
and Now Fabi is the one actually getting
in time trouble he had a five minute
lead right now of course he is doing
well here but Bobby actually is the one
that usually uh kind of like has the
less experience in the lower time
controls here like this low you see as
the email bars going down here more
mistakes usually you'll see from Fabi
than our team you have in this time uh
in this time like the time that we're
set right now the lower the time gets
that's actually a great point that
against a player like our time you have
you can't stop playing on the clock he's
just so strong even when he plays on the
second but the positions getting crazier
David Black's King is it in any danger I
see that Knight on 86 I'd be scared yeah
I'd be scared for the black king first
of all but I'd also be slightly scared
foreign that white knight entrenched on
H6 could actually be trapped long term
so you've got to be careful yes you're
attacking but if the attack Fizzles out
then you might be in trouble and uh it
definitely feels like Fabi had more
control a few moves ago he's lost some
of that control now but he's going all
out for that black king threatening some
nasty stuff we see a pawn trade here
black Bishop pair as well if the Queens
disappear
so it's moving very very quickly here
we're looking for tactics we're looking
for checks captures and threats James if
I had a five is it does it work or no
905 takes Queen H6
no checks I feel like in this position
yeah he's gonna trade but you really
want to keep more peace on the board if
you're Fabiano but he just brings his
Knight back to Satan David he's taking
your advice and well what attack does
white have anymore in fact black might
have the upper hand white pawns might be
in some trouble yeah if that black
knight wasn't so stupid over there on B7
then black would definitely have the
advantage but here Fabi he does have
coordination between his scissors the
queen of knights oh okay dropping back
here what a move just hanging D6 but you
could take on G4 I'm telling you it's
scary when he's in time trouble like
this he just gets stronger when the time
gets lower yeah you're completely right
James and nice Bobby how is he going to
go for it I was going to say how do you
go for the attack you're retreating this
is the wrong direction from Fabiana
caruana Black's pieces are coming
forward it looks like a great uh great
winning chances now for vladis love I'll
tell me a nice class to move the black
king super safe the white king is the
one that needs to watch out trading
Queens as you mentioned if the Queens
are off the board White's the one who's
going to be super happy but does he
allow the H Pawn he says yes my knights
in the center are going to be really
strong does this end game favor white no
favors black because look at White's
Queen side pawns all on light squares
sitting ducks in many variations when
the Black Bishop gets involved so look
at this Knight of five check now the
Knight is going to deform a check taking
off some of those pawns yeah you can
even keep the black a pawn if you want
you can push that black a pawn even
further down the board he gives a check
first crazy just looks beautiful for
black I've got to say he starts munching
on those pawns maybe it's more slip but
he's going after that white Central Pawn
and uh everything's falling apart for
Fabiano he's having he's actually low on
the clock right now everything's
dropping the pawns are falling I'm
telling you when he is when he gets when
the time gets lower our teammate gets to
they need to start him at a minute let's
start him at a minute okay that's how
artemiev gets his chances I mean the
time gets low and he just turns up
everything goes crazy he plays better
just like Grisham does it's very trains
very strong players here they can play
on this time controller in this time
pressure like this no time on the clock
and was able I mean it feels like he's
about to take down Fabian another
Central pawns are moving officer trade
has to to be captured but I see that
valmar says that the worst is over now
for Fabian that's a big blunder he
allowed this H Pawn to stay alive that
black Corner Pawn watch out they're so
strong against these Knights and while
he's coming in for those pawns that's
tough there's two white porns are doomed
on the queen side stop cemented on light
squares that's a life it doesn't matter
what he moves because those pawns are
falling and unfortunately for Fabiano it
looks like artemia I mean the guy is
just ice cold when he has no time in the
clock James you've been calling from the
beginning and he's really scored up I
mean it's crazy it's literally like he
gets lower and he gets stronger like
your power level gets over nine thousand
as soon as he starts getting low on time
somehow some way he just he just becomes
another player it's really he's done it
to Magnus twice right and now he's doing
it to Fabiano here he had no times of
five minutes probably had a five minute
time Edge right to tell you how big of
an edge this was completely winning five
minutes and wasn't able to convert and
now it's simply hopeless for white that
night is going to struggle to contain
those two black pawns a bit of a trick
here it's poisoned okay don't take that
night the white corn would run through
you're fighting yeah he's fighting Fabby
maybe some small chances the white king
coming back now but uh three seconds two
seconds oh time time he made a move
don't worry the moves are coming in yeah
no that's gonna happen when it was
coming with increments so chill guys
okay you can trust our Tammy if he does
not lose on time he doesn't get flagged
you're right wow but he's playing he's
playing the last 15 moves on seconds and
it looks like that was an inaccuracy
fabi's back because the bishop couldn't
go forward there would have been a fork
and now he gets the pawns he takes both
of them wow I'm sorry he's celebrating
he can't believe it he cannot believe
his luck that he survived this WOW don't
ride off these top players ever I think
that's the lesson from this game Fabby
saves a draw King versus King it's a
miracle vladislava let it slip though
one move or two moves away from winning
oh what a turnaround it's a roll
reversal from yesterday far beyond a car
one was winning against Liam lay and
just like what we just saw here that's
what happened Lemley was able to survive
so the players they're going to make
their mistakes in time travel but
Fabiano he should count his lucky stars
that was an absolutely crazy game there
we saw Fabi with a smile he knows that
he survived a scare it was completely
busted at some point but Fabi survives
to level the score and go into game
three what a round we've had full of
action David so many critical moments so
many critical moments both in the game
between Wesley and Hikaru and also this
one I just want to show where vladislav
could have actually finished it off just
a few moves before the end he was still
winning Bishops are better than knights
in these types of positions with pawns
on both flanks and he could have showed
this by simply pushing his pawns this
white knight is so far away there's no
way to come back and stop there's only
actually one route you have to come into
the center but black simply continues
pushing you park the bishop on this
Square the white king can come across
but now you defend everything and
Black's King could take this Pawn at
will if the white king ever Strays too
far away you'll make a new Queen White
is stuck and it's a matter of time
before black wins instead he moved his
Bishop to a poor poor Square allowing
the White Knight back and the white King
was just in time to come back and take
these pawns missed opportunity for Tamia
Fabiano breathing a sigh of relief yeah
on the camera in the end sabi is smiling
after picking up those Queen side bonds
what action we've had and this is where
we stand Hikaru Nakamura with a
fantastic win oh Wesley so playing on
the clock playing on the position now he
takes the lead vestily so Trails by a
point Fabiano Carana but vladislav about
time yeah that match is tied there is a
big a big game three coming up but
before that we're gonna take a shot
twitch break
thank you
[Music]
oh
right
now
[Music]
welcome everybody my name is
Champion our starting a new course here
for chessable a very special chessful
course master your chest with Judith
bulgar you know what I learned a lot
thank you
foreign
[Music]
knows this story so at some point we
were we were running what was called the
chest.com ambassador program I was
convincing to give this little chess
website that could a chance because I
know ICC is better to play but give us a
chance when we thought about trying to
get someone to play on our site who
could who could motivate other title
players to come we were having a lot of
internal debates about all the top
players at the time I mean I've noted
Carlos since I was 11 and he was nine
right it was we were everyone was good
there was no Pros I'm not gonna list any
of the cons But Eric was the one who was
like Hey like if we're gonna do this why
not just go right to the top like hey
cars the best online chess player in the
world we had all the other Grand Masters
you know but like hey we really care
about this why are we spending our time
um you know trying to trying to do this
in five years let's just go get Hikaru
to play on our site and and Eric reached
out to a car and had a great call and I
do a new car for a year so it wasn't
hard for me to connect with him and and
the moment we got hitkara playing on our
site it was like every top chess player
in the world followed
foreign
ERS in the world for not just that I
mean over the last year what performance
he's had winning the American Cup
re-entering the world's top five even in
2022 in his grappy performance
qualifying for the candidates and a
fantastic candidate is Hikaru Robert in
the best shape of his life you know he
was number two in the world in classical
Chess at some point but right now I
think he is just on fire every
tournament he plays in he doesn't just
have a chance he's right up there if not
winning the event so Hikaru Nakamura
seems Unstoppable most events he plays
in yeah and he is leading his match
against Wesley James what does flexley
need to do to come back and do this one
Lexi snow he flexi so needs to flex
right he needs to flex he also needs to
play his game maybe play more solid a
little bit here don't take I'll take
less rate but also he needs to like get
his time right right if you get the time
right he's blundered both times in time
pressure so if I can get my time right
just play maybe a little bit more
Instinct here a little more solid but
you also have to get over the fact that
I just lost this game right and I'm
losing on time he said this yesterday
too about his time management wasn't the
greatest so he needs to fix that today
and then right now in fact is he got two
matches left so two games so he needs to
fix that right now before it gets out of
here yeah Wesley saw has been struggling
on the clock and on the board and takes
a big decision to go for the Sicilian
wow yeah less risk evenly Psych
yeah James he jinxed it though with the
opening uh I was actually going to make
a bow prediction that it would be a
quick Berlin draw Hikaru would be happy
to get one closer one game closer to
that Finishing Line Wesley meanwhile
throw away that black game focus on what
uh a white win in the next one but no
Wesley wants to risk now here and now
it's a bishop B5 check Sicilian this is
a more solid option for white no open
Sicilians where it's kind of throwing
pieces towards each other's King this
one is more strategic kind of in line
with uh nakamura's strategy for this
match seemingly but uh yeah what do we
think of this opening Choice the bishop
B5 check for any Sicilian player like me
being included as well I've ventured off
into E5 and Carol Khan too as well but
being a long time Sicilian player the
one that you hate the most is when they
go Bishop B5 Tech believe it or not hey
man you can see the face that Wesley's
making right now he actually made that
fair as soon as Bishop B5 check landed
on a board his face he was just mad the
little smirk of like bro come on man
like that's exactly what happened here
and I understand because this is
annoying nobody likes to face the bishop
B5 check Cecilia now you play this is
someone have an open position attacking
chances in here you're like this
everything's closed now a single piece
has been traded and when Magnus was
playing against Hikaru we saw some close
the Suns as well just trying to keep the
action closed until black has to force
it open and look at Wesley's last move
C4 maybe opening the C5 Square for his
Knight trying to get some forward
squares but white can always strike at
that pawn B3 or D3 just try to trade
some pieces and we do see a quick on
passant yep a quick on percent and this
will be recaptured at least now for
Wesley if he wants to win this game
there is a small imbalance in the pawn
structure black has a rock solid
structure black once he gets castled
will be very happy I think Hikaru
meanwhile will want to strike on that
Queen side so still early days in that
game as these two starts their battle
Yeah I had a big game coming up where
vladislavartamia was so close to winning
round two against Fabiano caruana but a
miraculous save that and now Vlad starts
with the King spawn opening Robert you
are surprised yeah has been playing a
lot of Knight F3 systems but he's
challenging Fabiano head on in the Best
Buy test one E4 lines and then he's
thinking so I I'm just not sure what our
temmiev is aiming for it seems like it's
part of his game plan to spend a ton of
time in the opening and then speed up
later but he chose this first move he
could have expected Fabiano to play this
he was renowned as a Petrov player but
he also of course plays the Spanish and
now he's playing the Four Knights which
is not the most testing variation I'm a
little bit surprised at what's going on
yeah really surprising stuff it feels
like the Mind Games uh maybe he's on
tilt maybe he's been affected by failing
to convert that advantage in the last
game and okay he's actually using the
Spanish four nights just like fantasaya
did earlier in the day maybe this is uh
something the two Russians have been
working on that okay bringing his Bishop
out for black now Fabiano and this is
still mirroring that game earlier in the
day fedes against Levon aronian and in
that game I believe there was uh just a
pawn push here in the center and that
game was very balanced for a while but
uh Khan Fabiano spice things up at all
early days here but very symmetrical
solid start for both
yeah David I have to ask you the spawn
push with the Deep on defending E4 why
could white not just pick up the E5 pawn
it looked like it was hanging Center
Barn I'm attacking F7 yeah yeah Natalia
this would have led into a maze of
complications let's just jump in if
White had taken this Pawn I've taken it
myself in this exact position black for
example can bring his Queen out and here
things do get spicy white for example
concussion on this square but uh watch
out for the white king as well a bit of
a Target so this leads to uh just uh
reams of opening theory that I don't
want to get bogged down in here but it
would have got very complicated and
clearly uh Artemis just in the mood for
a more solid position this is the
current position on the board and you do
have to watch out slightly for this type
of move you don't get your queen trapped
but uh of course there is still one
Escape Square maybe the White Queen will
slide across to attack this black king
and you said opening Theory and we have
five on a Corona on screen when you
think opening Theory he's one of the
first names that comes to mind along
with the likes of Anish giri so artemian
wants no part of those crazy positions
he likely hasn't looked at him much
himself he's not really an E4 player he
does not play The King's Pawn often so
he's trying to play something solid he
wants a slight Edge so they can try to
press because as David you said
yesterday before he faced off against
Magnus he loves himself a good end game
and Magnus Carlson he is the highest
standard of end game player and artemium
is right up there with him yep for sure
so if the Queens do come off then watch
out for our team trying to work his
magic there against Fabiano but Fabiano
as he's shown uh in the first game
especially if he's direct he can catch
ultimate off guard in the opening and I
think that just that experience of game
one today has scared Artemis away from
his usual openings that's why we see
this position in front of us I think
that's a win for Fabi in fact I mean he
scared you away from your regular Knight
F3 I mean he played it every game
against Magnus through you know the
World Champ Fabiano here he went he's
like let's mix it up wow that says a lot
you know about Fabio's Fabiano's prep
and also maybe the psych part there
um psychology part on our Timmy of there
of like oh man oh let's play something
different but then you know I'm not
familiar with these positions and if he
gets along time I mean this can be bad
let's see how prep how much prep Fabi
has here too as well he feels like he's
good right now only 30 seconds off the
clock here up time already I'm still at
the beginning of the game here so I'm
pretty good for probably here but very
level position and nothing that you know
both players cannot play well yeah it's
only moved eight or nine but it's clear
that our time is freestyling completely
and again another long think what could
be more natural just Castle the white
king but maybe he wants to attack maybe
he wants to throw some pawns towards the
black king maybe he's going to bring
White's Dart score Bishop out just pin
that black knight lots of choices but
I'm worried if he keeps this uh pattern
of dropping low on the clock then at
some point in the day it will come back
to bite him yeah and we've often seen
that to come back when there are those
critical moments where you whereas that
difference of half a point and
converting it into a win after playing a
great game and then not having enough
time to do that so our time we have
needs to take care of the clock he's
down by two minutes also just notice
it's the same it's not the same t-shirt
that he wore yesterday when he hit
Magnus yeah I was trying not to call him
chess players are often Very
Superstitious right we've seen Daniel
dubov where that Balenciaga sweater many
days in a row when he's having a good
event Jana Palm she's done the same so
some people are very Superstition in
fact they use the same pen every single
time as soon as they lose a game that
pen is thrown off off the balcony what
Sam jersey Sam seven with the Jersey
right so at least that's you know next
week so I hope there was some laundry
being done I don't want to call it out
of this but yeah I think the uh you know
stinging like the Bumblebee that's still
part of our tenderness game plan
see if it works or not today it worked
Perfection against Magnus but right now
it looks like Fabiano caruana has
everything under control in this
position out of the opening let's hug
back to the other matchup Hikaru
Nakamura taking on Wesley so Hikaru
leads with his win in round two does he
have everything under control in this
one it looks very balanced to me on the
face of things but I do slightly prefer
Black's position just the flexibility of
having two Central pawns if you look on
the two Central files the E and D file
black has two why does one so black is
the one who can push for pawns forward
at the right moment I'm not sure whether
now or later will be the right moment
but uh you're the one who can make that
decision it definitely feels like Hikaru
is playing Safety First chess just
maneuvering keeping everything on solid
squares and he's saying to Wesley you
start the action and I will react but
that's a risky strategy in a situation
like this if you're too passive if
you're too negative with your Maneuvers
your decisions then it could haunt you
for sure Wesley meanwhile just setting
up he's going to bring all of his pieces
into the game maybe centralize his Rook
next to his King maybe step the black
king up one square cover some holes over
there and only then decide what to do in
the center there's something ironic
about it though sometimes in players
they have a lead that's when they get
the most nervous and icaro has been
ahead on the clock throughout most of
the competition right now we see him
spending time on this move he's playing
kind of timidly in on hikaru-like
fashion especially actually in a
sicilian it was his opening Choice he
won a solid game but he's not getting
that so this is a credit to Wesley so
playing a strong Sicilian getting the
type of position he needs to fight for a
win and icaro now is looking at the
center as David was pointing out will
black strike with that extra Pawn there
is there a problem down the C file what
is white going to attack it doesn't seem
like there's a Target in Black's
position I like the look of this for
Wesley so
potential breaks in these positions for
black right you can either go D5 strike
in the center or B4 strike on the queen
side James which one do you think will
appear in this game yeah D5 is the one
I'm a big fan of and now of course B4
yeah you have to be careful of the C
file it's not actually we don't have
that much pressure down and we do but
the nice defending here we also could
play Rook C1 at any time so D5 is
definitely the more thematic break you
also want to get the Knight on maybe
Knight takes D5 and then Knight can even
swing into F4 and you want to open up
that light Square Bishop as much as
humanly possible because of course I
mean even get the bishop to D6 I mean
everything is going to be aiming at this
white king over here and you can get in
a lot of trouble um especially if you
don't get the pieces off the back rank I
mean the Queen's still not this Queen's
on D1 The Works are not connected blacks
are like black has all the pieces
developed this is what you want
especially in any opening but definitely
in a sicilian like this there should be
five checks Sicilians can be very
annoying but it looks like I mean the
worst may be over for Wesley I think he
played it very well yeah but Black's got
a Time aimed this break really well
because you also can't allow white to
push that E Pawn forward after D5 just
blocking your own Bishop but James I
love the ideas and I think D5 is what
will be the aim uh Robert
do you agree yeah but I like David's
arrows here because I was just thinking
black played G6 a moment ago and what
was the point of putting upon to take
away the F5 Square so the White Knight
cannot jump forward so you play E5 to
stop white from doing that and then you
play D5 and you really blast the center
of the board open advantageous for black
if that were to occur Yep looks
beautiful for black everything in
Black's favor here I was just going to
point out this move as well if the white
knight Retreats here maybe the black
Knight's actually going to come to this
Square really tie down these pawns this
is kind of thematic uh uh kind of an
idea here especially when you've got
pressure down the C file uh if the white
knight goes the other way however look
how blocked in this queen is this queen
is smothered this queen is suffocated
and now you break open the center boom
and everything is in Black's favor I
really actually fear for Hikaru in this
position if he simply moves his Rook
across I think he's going to be
struggling he needs something more
active but where is that move what can
he try here already shaking his head
notice this uh uh David actually like
you know it's um he covers down time
yeah when is Hikaru ever downtown
against anybody on the planet right okay
he's down three minutes in the county
that's a lot Wesley this is a win for
Wesley right now in an opening battle
right now Wesley won the opening battle
and Hikaru is going to have to figure
this out as he's trying to right now he
spent right now the timer says three
minutes and Counting he's thinking and
using his time trying to figure this out
Wesley's up time that's huge for Wesley
right now yeah it is really about
getting these small wins so that you can
get the big win in the end getting that
little time Advantage putting a little
bit more pressure on the opponent having
ideas like E5 D5 in the air hey in a bit
of trouble and you can tell he's just
not shaking and bobbing as much as he
usually does when he's better he's no
longer acting right that that Grimace
that you just saw on his face that was
real that's a chest position Grimace
like this is not going the way I want
and it really is that straightforward
for black you have a clear plan and
white doesn't so black has the pawn
breaks I say this so often so many time
in the show the side that controls the
Palm bricks is usually signed with the
advantage and he brought his Knight back
to the first rank which opens up ideas
on the queen side flank or still in the
center I love the way this looks for
Wesley and I think we even all been
asking for this we love Wesley so when
he's playing ambitious chess he's super
dangerous but he often sticks towards
more solid openings and decisions when
he's playing the top he has to his back
is against the wall and he's doing just
that so Props to Wesley right now yeah I
first met Wesley so at the 2007 world
junior Championship and he was a really
attacking aggressive player he crushed
me straight out of the opening once a
few years later crushed me again by
playing attacking chess and I just
couldn't handle him and nowadays he
tends to prefer that more solid approach
and it serves him well of course he's
got that level of consistency that's
kind of kept him in the elite of World
Chess for so long but to beat the likes
of Hikaru to beat the likes of Magnus
you need a bit extra so it's nice to see
him in this game embracing his roots
embracing his uh Natural Instincts when
he was a bit younger and I feel like
just like the first game now is the
moment strike in the center before
Hikaru gets organized David I was
thinking about that you know that F5
break that he had in the earlier game he
missed that opportunity is this the
moment for him to strike in the center
push that epon drive the night away and
then move ahead with the Deep Pawn
opening up the bishop all the ideas that
James mentioned and we've got E5 on the
board we might be seeing D5 next yeah
that's on the boards on the board and uh
does he want to move this Knight that's
the question first maybe he brings it to
the side of the board maybe he brings it
back but uh as you say Tanya this is the
move next D5 break it open and black has
the advantage it's Unstoppable almost
this pawnbrick your idea is still there
Knight A4 first let's keep the peace on
the board when a side is cramped they
want to trade pieces the only side that
doesn't have space is white so let's
keep the knights on the board then play
D5 open up the center black has an extra
Pawn in the middle of the board this
looks so promising for black and hikar
recognize that it's not that he thinks
he's lost in West he did by the way hop
the night to the A4 square but hikar is
just uncomfortable and Wesley's in the
driver's seat yeah yeah just to fast
forward a couple of Moves In This
variation to show how strong this is for
black for example what do you do in this
position if you move your queen then at
some point you will get hit by a knight
F4 jump I don't see what else the black
Rook is going to come start creating
some monster threats also watch out for
sacrifices on this Square just looks
fantastic for black right now position
is gross that is just so bad after he
takes D5 it's really bad D5 here I mean
do you have a choice you have to take
this you've got to be careful if you
make a random move maybe we'll even see
the black porn step forward there's a
pin on this file as well and that could
NAB black a pawn at the very least you
just bring your Rook into the center uh
nice position so if you do have to open
things up that will suit black and uh
Wesley done everything right in this
game Hikaru rotates his Knight Retreats
that Knight backwards and uh okay he's
still solid-ish but look at the white
pieces they're all camped on their first
two ranks blacks are pouring forward
with all the momentum that almost feels
like the Mad situation has forced Wesley
to take a drastic ambitious decisions
and good for him because now after D5 he
does control the board white moving back
Hikaru moving back with his Knights but
there is a threat on the board he is
threatening to pick up that black knight
and win a pawn how does black counter it
that's a pawn I'd be willing to give up
if I'm wasted I get the bishop pair the
board will open up that's good for
Bishop so I would even think about
sliding The Rook that's next to the king
into the center in line with the queen
Rooks usually win those showdowns on an
open file and that file is going to open
up Wesley Knight C5 that is not a timid
move he just brings his Knight back
towards the center I think it makes
sense he knows he has the advantage why
give hikar even the slightest bit of
Hope with material so 95 is good Rook d8
is next still Wesley and look at the
lead on the clock as well I mean it's
not just the board it's the clock it's
everything and you can see it on
hikara's face
yeah he's worried he's one uh
uncomfortable man right now Hikaru
Nakamura and it's like you said earlier
Robert just when you're in the lead
somehow people freeze I've been there so
many times myself suddenly getting a
draw feels like Mount Everest climbing
that Mount Everest and uh it's the
hardest thing in the world just to stay
solid against these top players uh okay
Hikaru brings his Queen out but that
Queen is not gonna feel too safe anytime
soon James do you spot any attempting
moves for black attempting attempting
ideas here yeah I'm actually looking at
uh I was just going to say captures okay
capture I also looked at d42 but you
know it just locks down everything and I
have to like move the Knight and then
play F5 it's too much so taking at least
keeps the bishop open it's a very strong
Bishop I have there but after takes I
mean I'm not sure what to do yet okay he
took out the night so now we have to
calculate a little bit takes takes takes
takes takes takes takes takes and then
grab the juicer exactly I'm not sure
which way you capture with the Knights
let's say this way for example and I'm
really worried for a car after a move
such as B4 look at this look at the
pressure on the C file it's as if you're
getting hit from all angles this Pawn in
the center is isolated internal weakness
now you're getting hit from this flank
also black is the one actually with the
advantage on the other side it's
actually on the board right wow it's on
the board before we were talking about
should black go for the D5 break or
before wrestling says I'm gonna get both
of them and he does it in the strongest
way possible with that PIN on C2 Hikaru
Nakamura in big trouble low on the clock
as well 92 does that just well the good
news is that the B7 Bishop is attacked
David so you perhaps can't really pick
up the C3 Pawn immediately yeah I'm not
gonna be greedy that I'm not I'm not
keen to rush things here if I'm Wesley
so he's got the long-term Advantage so
he's actually done the hard work
long-term white Central Pawn is isolated
after a Trader pawns on the C3 square
that we pointed out he'll have a bunch
more isolated pawns uh Hikaru Nakamura
so Wesley can actually make sure
everything's defended everything's ready
first there we go bring the Rook into
the action only later cash in on that
Advantage it's all about transforming
advantages in chess you have the
Strategic Advantage transform it into a
material advantage later but only when
you're ready only on your own terms and
I like this myth and the one piece for
black that really isn't optimized that
Knight on F6 it is staring at White
Center but at some point it may hop
around the board to find Greener pasture
so if that Knight hops the rim we
typically criticize those decisions call
it dim but here that night May Venture
into F4 that's a great Square to work
with white would like to use the dark
sweat Bishop to cover but then black
will try to trade off the dark Square if
you use your Pawn to cover by pushing a
G3 you open up even more squares around
your king that does not look like a good
way to stop you see the evaluation go
higher and higher for Block in such a
position I think that Wesley his play is
so easy here he has a lead on the clock
his car was not feeling the game right
now and I think Wesley has to punish him
yeah he has to punish him at some point
you will take on this on this Square you
don't need to rush this because of the
pin against the C2 Bishop maybe a move
such as bringing the bishop to C5 I'm
also looking at ideas like Knight G4
trying to go for this white king trying
to cash in on those dark squares and
just looks beautiful for Wesley but he's
spoiled for choice will he be able to
find The Knockout blow it feels like
this is the game he needs to strike here
uh if he doesn't win this one Wesley
he's not going to recover from this uh
from this disappointment he's up time
too as well he's just trying to Bishop
C5 weight we have a move here okay very
logical he's trying to trade off and
take on no you still can't take us well
you can now the problem was B7 and E7
was hanging now there's only one piece
hanging and then you can actually win
the pawn there but you allow The Rook on
the seventh with some counter play it is
interesting yeah it's interesting I I
just don't see a movie maybe you have to
push the white king into the corner and
just cross your fingers and hope pray
for the best but uh yeah black is
breaking through on the dark squares
that might be the uh the bigger worry
right now for Hikaru yeah yeah are we
leading the match took this decision to
play a more positional strategic opening
with the Rosa limo not playing the open
Sicilian which is more his style do you
think that is where it went wrong for
him that he didn't believe in his own
position but instead wanted to play The
Mad situation yeah you've got to play
the board in front of you and if Wesley
doesn't play the Sicilian on a regular
basis it's because of the open Sicilian
it's because he doesn't want to be
attacked and uh here Hikaru hasn't tried
to attack him hasn't given any difficult
questions hasn't tried to make Wesley
uncomfortable he's just playing for a
draw yes you've got white you haven't
done that much wrong but it's these
small kind of signals that would have
given Wesley confidence in the match wow
and H3 stopping the black knight from
jumping forward but a bit of a sad move
to play yeah yeah
currently struggling in this game on the
clock and on the board we will come back
to this let's get an update wow lots has
happened here
Queens have been traded off what is
going on how are we evaluating this end
game well when you said struggling on
the clock and on the board that
describes position he is down seven
minutes and change he's also a worse
position because his Pawn structure is
worse and Fabiano caruana has full
control of this open E file the Knight
is better in the bishop we like a bishop
pair but when it's a lone Bishop the
Knight can hop from color complex to
color complex the bishop is inherently
limited to its own color the dark
squares and look at this black controls
the E file black has a rook in the file
that Knight on D7 can jump into the
position via B6 and go forward from
there this looks really really nice for
Fabiano and did we mention that he's up
seven minutes
what does he even hope for here I'll
tell me if all the Rooks come off you're
probably losing it's good night versus
bad Bishop uh if the Rooks stay on the
board the blackrocks are likely to come
into the position which pieces do you
want to trade there's no chance you'll
ever get Black's night off the board for
your Bishop I don't see it what are your
hopes long term Maybe you just have to
survive move by move but with three
minutes it's uh not an easy task
and so it's hard that when you have to
play moves and suffer from a worse
position like that's just the worst like
you know you're worse but you're just
trying to hold or make some create some
type of chances here it is Bishop versus
knight but I mean like the night's fine
you have double pawns here I can always
defend the B file with B6 if you go Rook
B1 I'm about to double and then trade
and uh definitely an in-game would be
nice for black here we have the
Maneuvers we can even put the Knight to
E4 we get a knight to E4 it's gonna be
extremely annoying right so black has
all the play here and the time to do it
now Fabi needs to be better with his
time management I think here too because
he got in time trouble and almost lost
that game you know so he needs to be
careful too not to get too low on time
here and I use the time Edge wisely yeah
James we saw that happen and a lot of
messes happen when you're low on the
clock is it a good idea for Fabi to keep
the Rooks on the board or should he try
to get rid of them I would love to make
them all disappear wait if that magic
wand and Hoover them off the board just
yeah I think the Black Knight is just uh
gonna be a beast if it lands like James
says on e4 or C4 the route that fabby's
going right now
uh beautiful outposts and uh when you
have squares that can't be challenged
for that night
the white Bishops simply can't compete
and black can trade a pair of Rooks at
any moment right you can push your Jeep
on Force the bishop out of the way then
trade Rook so I really like the dynamic
here for Fabiano it seems like he has a
pretty easy gameplay and for artemia who
doesn't have much time he's looking am I
going to lose a pawn in the next few
moves and if he loses one Pawn is that
too much to deal with unlike game one
where five ever got in time trouble and
almost lost there is zero losing chance
there he would have to blunder a full
piece or a Miss click and give him his
opponent pass Pawn I don't even know how
you lose this position Fabiano has a
dream situation right now
situation just keep things solid and
just uh defense and pawns get those
Rooks off the board at the right moments
yeah looks perfect just for that
strategy and I'll tell him if he's an
in-game expert but not when he's
suffering like this I don't think anyone
could be an expert in this position uh
for white it's just this is a nightmare
we're just two and a half minutes on the
clock playing with the white pieces it's
just not a scenario you want to be in
Fabiano caruana dominating this end game
Let's head back to our other match
Hikaru versus Wesley Hikaru with the
white pieces has landed up in big
trouble straight from the opening also
for the first time in this match it's
Wesley who is ahead on the clock we see
that the Bishops there's still tension
there trades haven't happened on the
queen side King H1 how does black
continue now oh spoil for Choice uh you
could trade a set of Pawns on the queen
side but again do you rush it I don't
think so
I was going to say Robert's idea from a
few moves back bring that black knight
into the game that's maybe the piece
that can be improved right now I would
love to take a time out as well to just
kind of Shuffle the black king forward
one square just to protect some pawns
but uh you've kind of got this luxury of
time of all these different moves how do
you choose and actually the more I look
at it the more I don't like Wesley's
decision to open up the white Rook on
the B file some trick suddenly in the
air
um we should see five is a threat you're
actually threatening to just win a
baseball big fella swinging I was just
gonna go Knight H5 but he hit him with a
tactino David said improve the nicest
give me that pawn in the center and this
works tactically what a shot from Wesley
so he grabs a pawn and it may look like
white is about to win a piece because
that 94 is under attack multiple times
but the issue is that Queen 92 is needed
to guard the dark side Bishop so the
forcing lines actually play out in
Black's favor yeah just as an example of
the forcing lines firstly you can't take
this bishop if you take this bishop
there's a nasty night Fork a nasty check
winning the White Queen so the only
other forcing move is to take this one
take the Knight but suddenly after
Bishop takes Bishop the White Queen is
overloaded as Robert mentions Queen
takes Bishop you drop this piece the
white Bishop here is lost and black will
emerge a clear Pawn up if you take the
other Bishop then black is actually
spoiled for choice you can take this
Knight if you want or you can be even
more ambitious even more greedy and take
this Rook at the very end after the dust
clears black has won the exchange and
the pawn game over so uh Hikaru now he
needs to be resourceful to even stay
alive head shake this game headshake
from Hikaru there headshake classic head
shake saying oh this is terrible you
know what do they do chat oh I'm a
oh am I dumb or am I is that the
title for the YouTube video
that's what he says on stream all the
time right so he definitely just missed
the shot here he's definitely a very
angry at himself very emotional players
you can tell right guys you know he does
this all the time on stream as he's
probably streaming right now in fact but
it is uh it's annoying that's a nice
shot from Wesley and I missed that
Knight H5 I thought he was going forward
but 94 is even better I'm just thinking
yesterday everyone was winning with
black I don't think we had a single win
with the white pieces Hikaru just beat
Wesley with black Wesley gets is this
gonna be like 10 nothing it's a decisive
games with the players the black pieces
we rule out the Armageddon yeah and I'm
ruling out the arm against that's
different format wow nine wins with the
black pieces zero to wide in the rapid
portion on day one and as you're
pointing out it was Hikaru taking the
10th black win and it looks like Wesley
has the upper hand with the black pieces
you could be right I don't think we've
ever seen those stats before black
scoring so heavy yeah it just shows how
well prepared everyone is these days if
you can't make a dent on your opponent
with white then actually things do turn
around and look at Hickory down to one
minute how often do we see this down on
time so significantly and totally lost
position great play by Wesley uh yeah I
don't think this would have been on my
radar either but uh he spotted it and he
deserves to win this game so far I'm
grabbed right in the center and I just
do want to point out that I just thought
about it and LeBron one with the white
pieces against Federal Sav earlier so
Lavon I apologize you know please
forgive me you did win with white and
look at uh Hikaru he puts his Bishop
there what is going on hold on man
tactics everywhere everything's hanging
relax yeah you just pick it up you can't
pick up the rug because the queen was
hanging yeah let's do a count so white
has sacrificed The Exchange a rook for
Bishop but in return has got the White
Queen active it shouldn't be enough but
there's an attack against the black
knight from the White Queen that's an
attack against black Rook from White
start squared Bishop so a couple of
tricks in the air he's just gambling at
this point Hikaru he knew he was losing
anyway so he's going to go down in
flames he's going to hope that Wesley
gets nervous and slips up but four
minutes for Wesley he should be able to
find a solution what is it though that's
the big question Daniel Rook how do you
defend your knight from these threats
it's critical that Wesley has so much
time because with an open King the dark
squares are rolling roll around the
black king if the bishop and queen could
line up there could be even a Checkmate
against it so Wesley has plenty of time
he's up a rook and one Pawn for just the
bishop that is more than enough so I
think he just needs to figure out how to
save his Rook save his Knight I think
maybe moving his Dark Sword Bishop back
to attack the queen that might be the
way to do so but I see chances for
Hikaru he is the king of making things
complicated when it looks like he has no
shot you have really nice move there
really nice suggestion Robert I'm not
sure if it's the only way but it's a
very sensible way you defend your knight
with Tempo James mentioned earlier
everything has to come with Tempo
everything has to have a purpose
and uh Here We Go attacking the White
Queen now the pawn is taken but the
black Rook has time to move I'm not sure
which Square you use you can move it up
you can across as long as the bishop
can't take you you will have a decisive
material advantage and Wesley converting
it really nicely so far he hasn't
slipped up but will there be twists
ahead yeah Hikaru doesn't look too
unhappy looked a bit uh well at least a
bit positive there with his life
decision yeah he understands it's
practical right you've got two Bishops a
weak King over here you know the The
Bishop's on G7 dark Square Bishop there
could be some things there like I mean I
mean by uh sorry uh black would be way I
mean way better I think he'll be fine
you're covering the weaknesses around
the king but white definitely has some
practical chances of like a bishop B3
and if you can reroute this bishop and
then get the queen on the diagonal
there's some problems in there right
there it is Bishop to B3 we're like
maybe you can even play Queen G4 Queen
G6 is there right Bishop F6 Queen H6 I
mean Bishop F6 might be next Queen H6
and you have a mating net this is
disgusting right so it's crazy you can
create chances out of this but Wesley
definitely has to be accurate here
Bishop F6 is a really strong move and
then Queen H6 and you might be getting
mated yeah
Hikaru is very resourceful very
difficult to beat him even when you have
a good position and what might have
looked like a blunder to many of us
giving up that exchange is just him
posing very important strong practical
problems for Wesley currently and we do
see as the clocks get more and more
level right now Wesley has an extra
minute on the clock he does attack the
White Queen and wow that is a dangerous
Quest placing it on the diagonal of the
bishop dangerous squirt but the only
square that Queen was borderline trapped
and look at this Knight E4 retrieving
the Knight but defending everything the
bishop is covered The Rook is covered so
a car once again moves his Queen
attacking the knight in the center and
for Wesley I mean if he gets in time
trouble this is when mistakes happen he
still has over a minute advantage of the
clock gotta be really careful suddenly
James your ideas if the white Queen's
swinging across towards the black king
telling you there's tricks here I mean
even like Knight C3 Queen E8 my guy and
then Rook takes Rook takes Bishop F6 but
of course obviously I think G5 there is
there Bishop C2 ooh exciting stuff
you're thinking about some Queen
sacrifices bringing the queen to the top
of the board I'm not sure they work but
for example you could just swing your
queen across and just to point out a
huge threat but Queen takes Pawn boom as
you say uh due to this pin the black
king is in actually huge trouble here so
you've got to be really wary really
careful uh for Wesley how does he
maintain this Knight in the center of
the board maybe he can't if he can't
then uh at least it's not one way
traffic maybe driving back trading off
pieces is a good idea but not an easy
move to make Wesley big decisions ahead
practical this is practical decisions
here I mean these Bishops are sharp and
again the dark Square weaknesses are
evident around the king there you have
to move the Knight and queen G4 is a
very strong move maybe he just moves the
king up to G7 or something yeah it feels
scary though suddenly for Wesleyan down
to one minute the clocks are basically
level Anything could happen in this
position Wesley needs to move he needs
to get pieces off the board the Dream
the ultimate goal is to get the Queens
off but uh hikara is going to say no to
that one he's going to keep the Queens
on and go for the attack Black's King
lacking Defenders okay Wesley's down on
the clock for the first time in the game
really could we see a turnaround what do
we think now yeah that's a problem you
know you cannot be giving all the time
Bishop G3 and oh speaking of turnaround
bro is that 94 just hanging it is just
take it the heck was that oh my God I
thought there was a background Checkmate
but there is not one there for black
that was a huge blunder and I'm I'm
looking it was it this might just losing
the match he lost his absolute on
National Television this is the move he
missed he missed the night Retreat then
the most difficult type of move to see
in chess backward night moves but wow
suddenly he's just lost a piece for free
Wesley so London didn't look at Hikaru
the Bob was going there the head Bob hi
practical chances practical right engine
says oh I'm winning and we all see it at
home and the eval borrowed the evil bar
right we see it and it's but the
Practical chances figuring it out
yourself on the board playing somebody
as strong as this is and the time
trouble again A Time issue for Wesley
when you get low on time you make
mistakes and he blundered a piece can't
express how important this is because
now hit car borrow I mean he's winning
he's up a full uh two minor pieces for a
rook that's too much to deal with for
Wesley so but when I think about the
overall tournament now Westie will drop
to the losers bracket where he faces
Magnus Carlson so so Magnus or Wesley
will do no better than fifth place which
means we'll see them in the play-in for
the next time and if akaro can get this
Victory this looks for him quite easy at
this point if he wins this he makes sure
he makes it to the third event division
one yeah I mean not just was it a
blunder that blew the advantage it's
literally 360. he was totally winning up
material now he's just uh yeah as Robert
says lost in Practical terms and you
don't want to be facing Hikaru in this
type of end game where he's going to
grind to grind grind forever 10 seconds
as well for Wesley at some point very
very shortly the White Knight white
bishop and white Rook are gonna gang up
against Black's F7 Pawn the pawn next to
Black's King on a light Square easy
Target and that one will full watch out
for that white a pawn deciding the game
later on any end game any transitions
Transformations exchanges will favor
because of that past Pawn on the a file
Hikaru taking his time he's gonna win
and so resourceful hats off to him but
Wesley
something was up today a few blunders
we'll see if worst thing can be
resourceful though because right now
Hikaru he's trying to make progress but
if a rook sacrificed himself for one of
the minor pieces and gets a pawn in the
process perhaps white will not have
enough material remaining to win the
game and that's what Wesley is relying
on and a car is avoiding at all costs
he's keeping this game going he
centralizes Knight make sure that no
trades are about to happen and for
Wesley I mean it's back against the wall
time what about a rook trade will The
Rook trade help Wesley here he can force
some of the Rooks off the board there we
go he goes for it now
he is removing one of White's potential
attackers but still he has fewer
Defenders now against the white a pawn
oh fruity stuff yeah for white spawns
and if you wow if you're taking all this
pond at some point you may not have
enough remaining yeah missed by Hikaru
maybe he went to the wrong square with
his King he should have stepped back he
went forward and now his pawns will fall
wow I wrote him off too soon I wrote off
I can't read first then I wrote up
Wesley and uh these two fighters just
throwing everything at each other maybe
he was gonna hold this one now yeah not
that many pawns remaining and that's all
black needs to do is you're gonna trade
off the king side pawns and then bring
your King on over to the queen side and
then try to give up your Rook for Bishop
and Paul or Knight and pawn as long as
white has no pawns remaining and one of
the minor pieces off the board it's
immediately a draw yeah that trade of
Rooks I don't think Hikaru should have
allowed it now his bishop and Knight
don't combine as well without the
protection without the help of their
rook and blackstruck is causing all
sorts of nuisance here there's a nasty
threat of pushing that black pawn
forward with a check and then the
blackrock's gonna go for that lone white
Pawn on the king side and uh okay hey
Karu treating everything off this should
not be winning anymore no definitely not
you can't even take the pawn now oh my
goodness so let's say so I mean we were
talking about him being knocked down to
the elimination bracket no he is still
right in this match if he can take this
draw he gets the white pieces in game
four he could force Armageddon with the
win there this is shocking
I thought Hikaru was home and dry he
probably thought he was home and dry but
look at his face now he's devastated
just uh Missing the opportunity to cash
in on Wesley's blunder earlier well this
one should be a draw simply not enough
material the best you can hope for here
is uh to give up uh one of your pieces
for those black pawns and the black Rook
but just no material it's going to be a
draw 10 seconds shouldn't be a decisive
Factor here
yeah I had the head Bob too he was
filling it he's like yeah let's go I got
you I got it and then I mean at least he
didn't lose the game though no that was
definitely this was sort of been
Wesley's game for sure of course but
practical chances both being in time
trouble I mean there's still there's
still play left he's going to try me
anything can happen especially after
that our Timmy of uh Magnus game where
there was just that crazy game where he
he should have it should have been a
draw but he did not yeah seconds on the
clock Anything Can Happen the air pawns
advancing black king comes forward the
G6 Pawn is now hanging is it time for
Wesley to pick up that A5 Pawn go for it
now there he goes and I think Hikaru
forgot about the clock for a second uh
he nearly made a move
yeah a little sneaky to the last dish
Everett he's ready to get out of here
Hikaru you can see on his body language
the pawns disappear and Rook F5 this one
ends in the draw but if anyone's pleased
with that it's Gotta Be Hikaru he was
completely busted Wesley had such a big
chance but Hikari the recovery things
and tricked him yeah that being said
chess players they only remember the
last blunder and Hikaru was the one who
let the wind slip at the end there
meanwhile this game has turned what's
happened black has lost control and G5
oh my gosh you could spring free this
past Pawn immediately I think Batman was
just lost at the moment he was much
better all game time travel James you
called it once again it is his biggest
Achilles heel absolutely and of course
it was funny is he gets stronger as
artemiev is a beast when he get low time
when he is loaded when he gets lower on
time artemia becomes another person it's
just insane how he can do this to the
greatest players in the world with no
time on his claw but during the game
when they have time he's like losing
he's down a little better position
better this better that and now he's
about to go look at that yeah that's a
that's a sign of uh of game over there a
sign of desperation he had to give up
his Rook that pawn was about to become a
new Queen and now it's only two pawns
for The Rook White's pieces are going to
coordinate though and pick off those two
black pawns the black porn simply
Advanced enough and Fabi just went for
it at the wrong moment allowed counter
play and things have turned
I'll tell me if nerves of Steel you've
got to say as long as he avoids a
nightfork he will win this game yeah the
Knight will try to help protect the
pawns but then the white king will join
the party and that's the thing about the
end game the white king can be used as a
weapon but look at this this is like a
pretty good setup for Fabiano it's not
easy to crack this yeah not easy you
need patience as I try to sing it it is
a shot it is working for him this is
unbelievable stuff there playing on
seconds how does he beat the very best
players in the world and we see Fabiano
kairana bringing his King in but that is
a whole drug that was strong it's it's a
good move just stop D4 everything under
control yeah
yeah important move and uh now the white
king can step into the center uh at will
and those black pawns will eventually
fall black lacking the coordination now
lacking the centralization you can see
from Fabi he's just devastated he's
throwing this game missed opportunities
left right and Center for both players
but uh here we go last a few moves and
this will be over just don't take the
knight uh well you can but uh if you do
don't grab the pawn afterwards gotta be
slightly careful
sites dropping down to one two seconds
on each move
this one is a matter of time now yeah
the part's not Advanced enough white
will be able to Corral it and the one
thing you need to watch out for is the
black king slides over and the pawn
pushes forward then you have to
sacrifice your Bishop to stop it Rook
against Knight that would be a
theoretical draw so Fabi Clinging On to
his last bit of Hope here our 10 minute
bringing his King back give us a check
um that's that's nice yeah the Pawn's
too slow oh yikes that's it wins the
night and we'll bring the bishop to stop
that seat Pawn it's going nowhere and
with that Fabi shakes his head a lot of
slav our time yeah takes the win takes
the lead which means going into round
four Fabiano caruana has to win on
demand to force the playoff wow what a
comeback that was by Fabi big moments in
both these games amazing turnarounds
Hikaru fighting it back to stay alive
and Fabi taking the lead David what was
the standout point for you uh there were
multiple standout points of course that
dramatic game between Wesley so and
Hikaru Nakamura essential uh for the
whole tournament but Fabiano caruana
where he let it slip was here black is
actually a pawn up he had the winning
chances he was better earlier in the
game as well but rather than allow a
draw rather than agree to a repetition
for example stepping his King back and
allowing a Perpetual check he played for
the win he dropped his Knight back but
suddenly white was better this walked
into a pin of course and suddenly it was
the black pawns that started falling
Bishops are better than knights in these
open positions horns on both flanks and
as we saw Artemis went on to guide this
to victory yeah yeah and with that win
let's take a look at our score line
going into the final rapid game in these
two matches that is love our tummy I've
lead his match against Fabiano caruana
after that great idea that David just
showed what a big Miss by Fabi
everything was over
still leads the match against Wesley so
surviving a very difficult game where
Wesley could have leveled the score
while Wesley and Fabi need to win on
demand to take it too
playoffs to take it to the Armageddon
we're hoping we at least get one of the
army guidance but for now for our
non-subscribers we are going to take a
twitch break but for those of you who
have subscribed here is a video here's a
sneak peek into what makes Hikaru
Nakamura such a beast
[Music]
thank you
Hikaru Nakamura starts the chatable
Masters as one of the favorites
when he was young Nakamura had a really
aggressive style a really direct style
he wanted to win every game by Checkmate
and and many people feared him for that
however as he's got a bit older Hikaru
has slowed things down he plays a very
solid brand of Chess nowadays preferring
to take things to a more strategic level
and to grind down his opponents in Long
games as an example of hikaru's
attacking instincts this is perhaps his
most famous move of all time
as black here against Boris gelfand he
played a queen sacrifice this game
stemmed from his favorite King's Indian
defense something he's also published a
course about unchessable Queen to D3
what a move trying to deflect away this
white Bishop there are multiple threats
including Queen takes Pawn leading to
Checkmate and of course if the queen is
captured this
this Checkmate this is how Hikaru played
as a young player however as a streamer
these days he has an utterly different
repertoire in recent times Hikaru has
shown his natural talent for the game by
winning the Fisher random World
Championship that shows his flexibility
of course and this is reflected in his
streaming career on chess.com his most
successful opening is 1b3 however he's
also very well known for inventing the
bomb cloud
and bringing the king out not to be
advised but Hikaru makes it work
wow
look but we are going to reveal the most
played openings on day one of the
chessable Masters and it's not born
Cloud rabbit it's not 1v3 it is a very
classic Queen's Gambit declined Queen's
Gambit decline Ultra solid opening you
know the top players love it Levon
aronian plays it all these top guys do
but it's super solid for them yeah are
you surprised to see any of the openings
on on this list uh Sassoon only at one
it used to be such a popular fighting
Choice especially in quicker time
patrols but these days it can be a bit
of two aggressive chests they prefer
their solidity at the top yeah it's such
a solid opening it is the opening of
choice of the top players the Queen's
Gambit declined Robert you've got to
show it to us okay let's go with it the
Queen's Gambit declined it is extra
solid it starts like this white plays D4
black plays D5 you're countering in the
center white plays the Queen's Gambit
you do not accept but decline no thank
you for the offer I'm gonna play E6 and
here afternoon Knight C3 by white the
most popular continuation black has a
vast array of choices and I want to take
us back in time to like of Pillsbury and
he played the Queen's game but declined
of course we had the 1927 World Chess
Championship match between Alexander
alikine and Jose roll capablanca all but
a couple games featured the Queen's
Gambit decline so if you're a qgd fan go
back a century and go look at those
games but Magnus Carlson in this day and
age he choose a variety of opening
things of variations against the qgd he
plays A6 you can look at Neil's Grand
deals this course on chessball where he
a former second of world champion
maggots Carlson goes through the ins and
outs of these offbeat variations where
you say I'm not going to give you the
typical plans you have to figure out am
I going to take on C4 am I going to
continue nacho with Knight to F6 and we
often see a carlsbod structure if white
does take on D5 here and black takes
back with the pawn eventually the move
C6 as possible or in a spirit of tarash
you could play even for C5
Queen's combat declined has stood the
test of time Robert you mentioned some
really big names there and we see this
opening even in modern times being
played at all levels what makes it so
popular I think part of it is schooling
Mikhail badvinic the former world
champion he had a big chess School in
the Soviet Union and he played against
the Queen's gamber declined a lot so
when you're taught that when you're
younger it's a very solid opening for
black so trying to break through it is
very difficult and when you're the top
of Chess it's not just about tactics
anymore you have to work those small
advantages so it's been taught
throughout the generations yeah
so if you want to check out the Queen's
Gambit Decline and want to learn the ins
and outs of the opening check out
chassebel
[Music]
hello this is Christoph zileki and
welcome to
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
wow action is still on a big game four
coming up in division one but the action
has ended for the day in division three
let's get updated from division three
wow big games there and we see some
surprising results Robert chakra or
mamajara one of the world's Elite a
Mainstay of Champions chess tours passed
he is out in division three Wei Yi the
super gray Mass from China he says
you're not going to get by me and he
moves on so did Matthias bluebaum who
was in the official random world
champion he takes down Nguyen from
Vietnam
action is on everywhere but of course we
will be focusing on the final round of
division one it is now Wesley so needs
to strike what is it that he's going to
do in this one Wesley he gets the white
pieces that's the good news but he can't
keep playing the solid stuff he needs to
take risk the time is now he did it with
black a game ago it almost worked out
for him now he has to play something in
a similar fashion and James Bobby needs
to do the same he is trailing vladislav
or tammyev how is it possible that our
time we have comes down to seconds and
yet he's the one who wins I mean really
in fact both in both matches it's the
time you have to be you have to stop
getting low on time right if it's easier
said than done obviously but of course
probably got low on time in both games
right that he was up time then he got
low on time and then lost right and one
game he actually Drew but he should have
lost that one too as well same story
with Wesley these guys got to get better
a little bit better in that time manager
yeah hey what is going on with Fabi
right now with latislav dropping low on
time but still winning the game yeah
it's hard to pinpoint exactly what's
going wrong fabi's playing well in
general his openings have been great of
course as usual but as James mentions it
is the time I mean I'm hypocritical if
I'm going to criticize anyone's time
management but for Fabi that has been
the decisive Factor end games not quite
matching our time if especially in the
last one and the clock
big round four coming up will we have
armageddon's it is time for our panel
board in chat tell us what do you think
which one of these two will go into an
Armageddon guys James I'm gonna start
with you on this one there's no
armageddon's right now I feel like these
are all decisive matches right now I
mean it's either draw or win right
that's it I mean of course it depends on
who has white obviously in these
situations here I mean maybe you can
push maybe you cannot but there's a lot
of pressure on you you know you're
facing elimination here I mean half a
point half a point away in the next game
over yeah
now you're gonna see an Armageddon I'll
say fabby's gonna strike back oh I don't
see Wesley though Hikari just too strong
at the moment too resourceful yeah
one of his players to beat in the world
in the situation if he didn't lose the
third game it's hard for me to see him
losing the fourth especially because
Wesley's conference might be a little
bit rough but I agree with David about
Fabiano his preparation is great his
leaving the clock has been huge he just
needs to put artemia away the clock is
ticking Wesley saw does start with the
white pieces but what a win he missed it
in the previous round but Hikaru
Nakamura known for his resourcefulness
he did not make it possible and that he
as well he kind of looked a little
surprised with Wesley's choice of
opening David yes because Wesley nearly
always goes one E4 against him but he
switched it up uh Wesley so here he's
going for the English shout out to the
English opening and uh yeah I like it
he's keeping pieces on the board keeping
tension and he's asking Naka new
questions uh not something that they
play time and time again against each
other which is a good sign for Wesley so
reacting with C6 getting ready to build
upon Santa what do we think of this this
is sort of a reverse dragon in a way of
reverse Sicilian and that is usually a
lot of times I like yeah this is
actually a line from of chessable course
obviously Simon Williams actually has
this uh where he covers a lot of this
you actually go Knight B3 and you do a
pawn sack line Knight B3 you actually
play D3 and then after e takes D3 you go
Bishop G2 you don't even care about the
pawn you actually end up casting so he
went E3 though Knight B3 is usually the
more sharper stuff but he went with a
more solid line
yeah and uh Hikaru when he looks up like
that he's normally trying to record that
opening theory of course playing very
quick very confidently early in this
game he's almost at 15 minutes still and
uh even if he was surprised in the
opening he's not showing it Wesley the
first to think and that's the good thing
about akara I would say right even when
he's caught off guard he still plays
quickly and he still has confident play
levana Ronin actually plays in a similar
style uh the top players sometimes they
just go in a deep think you know they're
really thinking uh Lavon when he plays
quickly he's not always necessarily in
his preparation he is just showing his
might over the board Hikaru he knows
this opening but I think he does that as
well
yep interesting it's basically a C3
Sicilian one of your favorite openings
James uh with colors reversed right just
uh White text remove of playing Pawn to
G3 maybe he wants to take it back
there's some really weak light squares
in wet's Camp yeah that's gonna count
right these weaknesses that you're
pointing out in a white scam and Hikaru
playing aggressively in the center I'm
always worried when a player starts
thinking out of the opening James is
Wesley feeling a little uncomfortable no
yeah so something he doesn't play a lot
of course here I mean E3 is already
something it's just a different line ip3
is usually more of the mainline ways of
playing or the more Modern Way of
playing is with the Knight B3 line E3 is
just solid very cool but I think the
problem here is choosing the diagonal in
fact in the reverse here actually Roman
DZ slapped the keyboard right with him
in fact colors reverse when you're
playing accelerated Dragon here the
problem is like you can't have the
diagonal you got to choose where's the
bishop gonna go G2 where is artemia
playing from the Invisible Man yeah I
love it be on the toilet we got the
phone right now on the wireless mouse
you know this day and age it's really
helpful where is he
crazy
he really might be on the toilet right
silly playing from the from there in
fact I think Magnus said he was doing
something like that before that's uh
insane here and the moves are happening
you still know her on the screen what is
happening then this should be set Heaven
from where telepathically chat we need
your help where is vladislava where in
the world is he how is he making the
moves happen who knows it's
oh there he is what just happened he's a
magician
I'm here I'm here I appeared it's not
just when he's got one minute on the
clock that he's full of Tricks he's full
of magic tricks even now and that must
be scary for Fabiano if he's got the
camera up on the zoom call that's crazy
whoa whoa all right but not such a crazy
opening this looks pretty familiar David
yep it is a branch of the ante Berlin
white not allowing the Berlin end game
with all of its drawish Tendencies so
Fabiano keeping all the pieces on the
board the game will take a slower Pace
but that's what Fabiano needs at least
for now he needs to keep the tension and
hope that vladislava I'll tell him
cracks a bit later on uh if Abby can
keep the pace that he's shown in the
first three games for the first kind of
90 then he's got a good chance but uh
it's that last 10 where his uh play has
been lacking as Robert mentioned lack of
Killer Instinct for Fabi and uh that
time trouble panic but uh early days
it's looking promising for a full uh
full-blooded fight
is that a strategy Robert just get a
Vlad low on the clock and then find the
chances I think Vlad just gets himself
low on the clock there's nothing you can
do about it you can't be like hey play
faster Planet he said no no no I'm
trouble's my friend but I think for uh
Fabiano he has great wealth of
experience and knowledge in these
Spanish structures so he is where he
wants to be artemiev he dabbles with a
variety of openings he plays the
Sicilian every now and then he plays the
Carroll Khan today he's been playing E5
but I think Fabi he's not unhappy about
the opening but I think he was quite
dejected when he threw away that end
game he could have made a draw I'd
actually looked through it he could
afford hit a repetition he chose not to
do it he ended up losing the game so it
was kind of his fault I'm sure he's
kicking himself for it yeah that's
always the most heartbreaking defeat
right when it's self-inflicted when you
had a winning position you threw it away
you were too stubborn uh to go through
the draw and suddenly Things Fall Apart
and Fabi needs to pick himself up it
does help kind of resetting when your
opponent is tanking early in the opening
like this flat Is Love on time what's he
thinking about this is a very standard
type of position surely he's analyzed
something similar to this before you go
to play by Instinct but now Fabi will be
gaining in confidence every moment that
I'll tell you hesitates and waits I've
never seen her to me I've grabbed his
head like that I know right it's just
that Fabiano actually is making him more
emotional he's giving him some emotions
that but of me it's not working like
nothing's working against our team here
like what is this it gets low on time it
gets itself low on time and then he
becomes some just super engine like play
it's insane precise and everything and
with no time on the clock it's a very
very strange force to be recognized
maybe Fabi is his favorite player so he
feels bad that's why he's getting
emotions I don't want to do this to you
buddy I really like your play I'm sorry
bro there's a reason why a lot of
slavors that we have is the only player
who beat Magnus Carlsen in the world
rapid Championship the one game that
Magnus lost he did go on to win the
World rapid Championship but he lost to
vladislavartame and here Vlad is on fire
but he's taking his time again big
questions one more time why is he
thinking right out of the opening he's
still recovering from that magic trick
earlier he's just catching his breath
there but uh okay he finally does move
he kicks back that white ship which
Retreats the whole way and uh which
setup is Ultimate of going to go for
here there's a bunch of ways black can
arrange his pieces white will step
forward in the center over the next
couple of turns and you've got to be
ready for that but it's still very
standard if you study the Spanish
opening pretty much you will have had a
position similar to this on your board
so to spend this much time this early
it's the type of thing I do and regrets
immediately but it's not the type of
thing we should expect from the world's
top players strange hard to explain yeah
not at all I do the same thing so I'm
also like David guilty of this I spend
way too much time in a position I played
dozens and dozens of times so for our
temmiev he's really just trying to
figure out where to take this game and
he's playing this very solidly he goes
rookie eight oftentimes black could have
decided to strike in the center with
Pawn to D5 he may still do that but that
loosens his guard of the E5 Pawn so any
pawn push you make there are weak
squares left behind you could create
some Targets in your own camp and our
attemptive he's just trying to be as
solid as possible right now yeah and I
like fabi's approach just easy plans for
white this white knight is going to
relocate it's going to rotate over
towards the G3 Square in front of the
white king it's going to park itself on
that square actually the Maneuvers are
very simple very straightforward very
thematic for white you will have seen
them all before but he's asking I'll
tell him if how are you going to move
where are you going to put your pawns
it's going to be a question every time
for our time we have I'll tell me if
we'll have four or five logical moves on
every turn that means clock will be
burned and here we go again he's just
playing a quiet move there Fabby not
threatening anything and I'll tell him
spend quite a bit of time he doesn't
care about burning the clock once he's
got no time he burns the position and
our tummy after taking a bit of a tank
falls back with the Knight now David you
were talking about plans for black often
in these positions we see black Advance
those Central pawns is that what we're
expecting next from our Damian I think
it's quite likely uh Artemis last move
might look mysterious to those
uninitiated in this type of opening but
the idea is to Simply Park this Black
Knight on the G6 Square in front of the
black king nice and safe white is likely
to do the same for example we could see
a maneuver such as this and actually
something similar happened in a game
between Wesley so and Hikaru Nakamura
earlier in the day these nights kind of
mirror each other protect their kings
threaten to maybe jump forward later
it's all about who can strike in the
center first and quite likely white will
be the one occupying the center black
will be reacting and actually this has
happened in the game different move
order but same ideas and at the right
time Artemis might try to release the
tension either by pushing his Pawn in
the center maybe he'll park his Bishop
on this square and put pressure on the
central pawns from afar either way still
very typical stuff I'll tell me if the
needs to speed up absolutely yeah the
Royal Lopez is actually a card also the
Spanish torture in fact they call it
that because of just how long and
maneuvering and like so it's just boring
right but of course I mean it's such a
rich opening there's so many ways and
strategies and and plans that you can do
I mean obviously Knight G3 I've even
seen G4 Knight G3 I've seen A4 I've seen
Bishop G5 Bishop E3 I mean it depends on
how you want to go here based off of a
black black setup is here black is
flexible too I actually like this 97
Knight G6 line it's very rare I would
say I'm used to seeing Knight ba brayer
style or Knight A5 with sugar and C5
going back with Knight C6 and Roy Lopez
so this is a definitely different I like
how we move this Knight around to G6
looks more of like a um Italian game but
the bishop 108 is very bad usually
you'll see in fact Magnus from the black
side likes to play G6 Bishop G7 there
and it's just a common idea to reroute
the bishop to a better Square because
it's gross on f8 right now yeah could be
the problem piece eventually long term
for vladislava Tami of again in the tank
very surprising but I think rich is the
right word there James you mentioned it
uh Rich because it's got so many ideas
for both sides so many different move
orders nobody can memorize an exact
antidote against the Spanish because
your opponent would play a move in a
slightly different order and it changes
everything and of course Fabiano caruana
Magnus Carlsen these kind of specialists
in the Spanish opening they use it when
they're trying to grind down their
opponents so I like it from a must win
perspective by Fabi and Fabi is kind of
a perfectionist we know that he is a
calculator he wants to play objective
best moves every single time but here he
needs to be pragmatic he needs to punish
vladison return of on the clock a lot of
someone's gonna think no matter what he
does that's clear at this point we are
in standard opening Fair artemium has
played like this before so if you're
Fabi just keep playing those quick moves
that is what Hikaru Nakamura does so
well he says this time and time again
you play good moves quickly rather than
the perfect move slowly when you're in
this kind of time control and Artemis he
lashed out with C5 Fabi closes the
center with D5 and this is classical
stuff at this point yeah classical stuff
and I love that approach because if
you've got to play on the clock you want
all your pieces on the board it's not
just all your pieces it's all the pawns
on the board as well no trades happen it
is about playing on our time yes clock
that is fabi's strategy well it's clear
he needs to find a way to win this one
to force an Armageddon otherwise he does
go down to the elimination bracket on
the other hand Wesley so also needs to
win his game against Hikaru Nakamura and
the Queens have been traded but there is
a lot of tension in the center look at
that evaluation bar right whoa massive
on white side wow white has the better
the bishop pair better long-term chances
but black has some threats Black's
Knight is attacking White's D4 Pawn that
pawn in the center
what is happening here it must be some
something immediate something in this
position because if black gets one or
two moves you can imagine everything
disappearing from the center and the
play being level maybe Hikaru doesn't
realize how bad it is I'm trying to
figure out as well myself is there a
strong move here I'm gonna take a lesson
from James and I was about to say this
this is wonderful because it gives up a
Central Pawn but James said earlier
sometimes white gives up a Central Pawn
and ignores it just develops castles so
he's giving up a pawn that Knight can
capture that pawn in the center but once
that happens I think the white king can
castle queenside and blacks kings in the
center Bishop takes F6 is happening in
the near future I'm shattering your Pawn
structure and winning that pawn back on
D5 or E4 so James I mean you called this
out earlier it's the same exact theme
and a car could be in big trouble here
wow again getting those Queens off early
maybe playing too much for the draw and
he's in trouble Hikaru Nakamura uh what
a move this is just great vision as well
to see the after Knight takes born you
can Castle Queen side it wouldn't be on
the radar of most players including
myself here I've got it it but once you
see it you see how strong it is you not
only get your king to safety but you
bring your Rook into the action with
Tempo Tempo is so important in the
opening uh you're kind of indirectly
hitting this Knight as Robert says
indirectly as well attacking pawns after
capturing this one massive trouble for
black and maybe it's too late you've
kind of burned your Bridges you've
traded off the Queens this Pawn is weak
no matter what this Pawn is weak no
matter what everything is falling
imagine a structure like this I've got
to put it on the board porn takes pawn
bishop takes nine here look at this
structure
what is that what is that Shale like a
deer head or something what the heck is
that wow all of them weaken all of them
probably gonna fall this could be the
wreckage of nakamura's structure if he
captures the pawn in the center big
trouble yeah for him and suddenly Hikaru
goes into a sink it looks like he's he
relies after Bishop G5 that it's not as
easy as it might have seemed to him this
position with black the fact that Wesley
is just sacrificing two Pawns in the
center it's an angry Wesley he is
looking for that win he came so close to
it in round three as well that was a
moment where you're onikara's face it
registered in oh bleep he's like he said
Oh I thought I was just developing I'm
attacking the center and now with one
simple bishop move his position is about
to completely collapse the Pawns in the
center are all hanging this bishop is
threatened to ruin the pawn structure on
the king side as well and I feel like
for Hikaru Nakamura for a second game in
a row he's feeling the full force of
Wesley so's might I love it this is the
Wesley we love to see we need to see
this more often this ambitious play by
him James absolutely of course I mean in
fact I was reading up just on like the
history of Wesley and I remember this
this reading but like as David mentioned
before he was very aggressive growing up
he was just a very aggressive player I
mean I guess you see this a lot from
very strong players now that we're
younger when they were younger they were
very like aggressive Hikaru same way and
as he got better and stronger they
played a little bit more solid because I
always thought Wesley was just solid
like this and just like boring because
he likes my favorite opening is Queen's
gamma decline I'm like bro bro you were
ridiculous right but at the same time
you know he's very aggressive and he
still has that went back to his roots as
David said going back to the roots
playing some aggressive chess here right
and it looks like it's working yeah when
he turns off his brain when he turns off
those emotions that Fear Factor
disappears and uh when he doesn't care
he's a dangerous opponent and yeah he's
shown it the last game almost getting
there now this one big big favorite but
Castle in Queen side Robert
it's got to be the way to go I think
he's just considering do I first catch
the Knight with the bishop and then
Castle Queen said I'm feeling very
positive that he will Castle queenside
but move order is very important in
chess maybe there's some other move that
hikara can consider if white initially
castles Queen side that may help him
over there on the king side so I think
that Wesley he's doing the right thing
calculating right now because he knows
he will have the upper hand whatever the
move order is yeah it's always the
question how much time is too much time
when you're playing against Hikaru you
know he is going to be asking you the
questions on every single move so you
have to not burn the clock as much and
he finally takes the decision this is
what you were talking about long Castle
he is looking for the win in this one
how much trouble is Hikaru in with that
King in the center I would say a lot he
would be panicking here I would be
sweating it just looks like there are
too many threats Bishop takes Knight one
takes porn everything opening up on the
central lines that we highlighted a
minute ago James do you see any wave for
Hikaru to even survive the next few
moves sure I don't have seen anything
this is a very scary process I mean and
then looking at casting again and then
it takes F6 and you literally have like
it looks like the almost the Bucks logo
you know with the uh with the the pawn
structure looking like some type of
mystical animal it's very crazy look at
this Pawn structure it looks like a a
composed puzzle or something that you
may like find a maiden 11 right whatever
that's it because this this never
happens right this is a terrible
structure and this is really really bad
I'm I'm definitely don't find a move
here maybe you have to just castle like
because you have the king off the center
I mean that's for sure if you Castle
however then I'm not sure whether you
take the night but Pawn takes porn look
how many targets there are on this D
file I'm glad I don't have to play this
position that's all I'm saying okay wow
oh bad times work's not connected I mean
this is terrible yeah has an extra Pawn
but it counts for nothing in this
position his King is weak the pawn
structure as you're pointing out
everything in the center hanging and he
is getting down on the clock Hikaru not
liking his position shaking his head and
I don't think this time he is being
deceitful about his Expressions not even
a Hoover could clean up this mess
is ruined his King is in the center his
pieces are all in line with an enemy
Rook he has very few options here but we
know Hikaru Nakamura can survive
positions that look like he is just
about to resign so Hikaru he needs to
find a couple moves here but I feel like
for Wesley he should be confident he was
out playing hikara for the majority of
the first game he blundered a piece in
one move very uncharacteristic of Wesley
so so two games in a row he has just
gotten the brute force method and he's
taking it to Nakamura and hikara has
looked like the slightly worse player in
the two games wow yeah I completely
agree and especially in this opening
phase okay he brings this Rook across
I'm surprised by that one maybe lining
up a nasty sneaky night check but come
Wesley just Shuffle his King out the
corner that'll be my first instinct
before I even start calculating I'm sure
Wesley will calculate maybe he'll find
something even stronger but when in
doubt Play Safe and uh that white King's
Super safe and Hikaru Blitz is a a
capture on D3 He doesn't care about
opening up the e-file and the pawn
structure that you're talking about is
this Brave or desperation
you set up a trap at least
you set up some trap he set up some good
stuff he got the extra posters all right
I grabbed another Pawn from you and also
uh I mean Bishop F5 is an annoying move
Bishop F5 D2 check and like Knight C2
and geez or even almost Knight B3 Rook
A8 it almost is there it's not there yet
but it's almost there like I mean
there's there's some threats here
there's some tricks and if anyone can do
tricks I mean we've seen that in the
last game with Wesley it's done it's
going to be car yeah and uh he looks
optimistic actually on his camera Hikaru
Nakamura first I would wreck the black
porn structure just aesthetically it's
too tempting giving black that pawn
structure that we mentioned of course
you can't take this Pawn because you do
walk into the pin uh along this diagonal
or or maybe you can I'm not sure but uh
evaluation bar not too fussed by this
which is incredible I was Bishop E4
there whoa James what a shout what a
call Bishop E4 and uh or Knight E4 maybe
even the idea is to give up a piece just
to block the diagonal and you can
actually snack on that Black Knight and
the game goes on crazy never gonna
happen though shortly it's too crazy
yeah but uh I was gonna say maybe you
flicking this one and you take this Pawn
uh at least that would be my first
instinct you take this Pawn next or this
Pawn with check but the question is
whether black conflict in uh this bishop
move and create some counter play you
mentioned this Checkmate I want to show
it on the board James talk us through
this one for example if I let's say six
might be so I'll take I'll go back this
way just to okay just to let you know
right you're right and then a D2 check
and then King A1 and hopefully you're
doing your puzzle Rush tactics here a
lot of people love nice C2 but it
doesn't work you're on ab3 Boom in fact
boom maybe three Pawn takes and Rook a
mate and get him off the board
getting off the board this is a family
channel let's get this off the screen
off the screen but actually we could be
heading in this direction if Hikaru puts
his Bishop on this Square I'm not sure
he's going to but it looks very tempting
to me yeah white has a great response to
Bishop 5 there are all sorts of tactics
in the position you can interpose with
your own Bishop Bishop E4 looks like
you're just throwing away a piece but if
the bishop is captured Knight takes Pawn
that is checked to the king and back to
the bishop you take the bishop the D3
Pawn will fall next white will be up at
least one Pawn maybe more because
Black's King is still in the center and
a rook is sliding in for white as well
this looks terrible Robert be doing
puzzle Rush chat make sure you're doing
your puzzle Rush at home okay puzzle
rush we want to see it in the chat where
she plays a rough score wow that's a
nice trick robin fish should be for just
challenging that Bishop on F5 which is
why Hikaru isn't rushing in with this
idea he spotted that the main thread
doesn't work Robert finding that
repetition but if not Bishop F5 look at
that pawn structure it's just collapsing
for black yeah it's uh the most flimsy
edifice I've ever seen those pawns and
aesthetically of course ugly for black
he's trying to keep it together here
with tactics with tricks and uh that's
why we're talking about puzzle rush
because if the tricks don't work in
Black's favor game over and uh yeah I
love that geometry of the white Bishop
interposing he's got his King out the
way so now some of those tricks won't
work things won't come with check again
ugly move especially that black in the
corner on h8 not a happy pizza right now
but at least the tactics might work for
Hikaru if his King won't get checked
yeah what's really annoying is how
resourceful he is because King f8 is a
very strong move now you actually are
looking at Bishop F5 and that's a very
annoying one you still can't take the
point I thought Knight B6 was probably
best here like just get to stuff and
he's done it anyway you big fella oh my
goodness and then D2 Knight C2 check
then what do we go after that let's put
that on the board that would just be a
repetition then yeah setting this up
yeah if you take this Rook suddenly a
discovered check and Hikaru will
progress to the next round because the
King has to move you throw in a night
check the King has to move and double
check this time hitting the king with
the Knight and the bishop and there's
nowhere to go you simply have to repeat
the position with the draw instead the
bishop was kicked back but still the
same tactic on top here along this
diagonal how do we evade this how do we
get out the way yeah
whoa he's getting ready to block yeah
eight that's a big move F5 kill the
bishop whoa and the black Rook has dived
in jumped in both sides creating threats
here on every turn I think just sidestep
with a bishop just get into safety on D5
and then start threatening F5 or take
that pawn on B7 get the bishop safe that
is uh Paramount here and then you're
throwing Pawn F4 to F5 trapping the
bishop on G6 and then white goes into
mop up Duty so this looks really
promising for Wesley hikar though doing
a good job he's trying to wheel himself
back in as the head Bob here is not
because he loves his position but he's
like I do actually have chances at the
moment yeah he's still alive at least
for another few more moves and Wesley
down to three minutes we've talked so
much about the clock today it was always
come back to haunt the side that drops
down and uh kind of struggles to
navigate those complications when they
come against a car you need a few
minutes in the bank in your back pocket
for later I do fear for Wesley could he
blow it again due to the clock just get
your Bishop out the way I think that's
the first instinct Robert's right why
not take a pawn if you can you know if
he takes apart I think I was looking at
King G7 and the F5 Rook G Rook B8 he
takes and The Rook takes B7 hitting B6
and uh hitting B2 we might find out
James we'd like to see right now
you can't I mean you have to do
something about this he's going to move
he's going to take this Pawn on D3 after
F5 so King G7 does make sense you
activate the Rook Rook B8 is coming in
and I'm gonna hit the bishop connected
to the Knight and you can hit B2 as well
but maybe he can go back to A4 let's
just show this on the board uh King G7
looks like the most natural totally
agree uh the pawn move stepping forward
the black Rook shifting across this is a
skewer the two pieces two minor pieces
attacked but the engine is not impressed
of course maybe you just leave this
bishop you leave it on G6 it's trapped
anyway you start mopping up on the other
side of the board Rook takes Pawn Rick
takes bishop and now Rook takes Knight
takes takes takes and at the end this
Rook says everything just in time to win
my goodness there's so many captures
there there's so many tactics here so
what is he gonna come up with that
magician here he needs some magic indeed
hey look at agaro it looks like he does
realize that he is in a big trouble
still thinking he's up two minutes on
the clock but not an easy position to
navigate West is so good make a comeback
and this one wow he stops it with his
own F5 but this just means that Bishop
on G6 at least a great question great
question a big Bond same thing as a
point
that black Bishop is the most sad
unhappy depressed piece I've seen in a
long time but uh Hikaru he's keeping his
hopes Alive by going for some of white
pawns if those white pawns on the king
side disappear the black Bishop might
breathe life again in future so uh he's
kind of abandoned everything on the on
one Flank In car route but he's going
for the other side of the board he kind
of looked over at the camera like a bit
guiltily there he's like yep I'm still
fighting forgive me please uh yeah how
critical is it for Wesley to defend that
at football and he says I don't care I'm
Coming For That Big Pawn on G6 H4 H5 is
a thread on the board wow that's a great
move because I mean everyone would just
take this Pawn on D3 it's a free Pawn
but what hikar was trying to do is take
on F4 and that Bishop that's been
trapped by its own Pawn see him which
moved he was trying to spring it free
and wow card is going less ridiculous
every move is tricky it's so tricky he
is just such a difficult player to face
he just sets up these traps and he's so
fast at it and he's so precise with it
it's scary to play against
I want to play him nobody ever wants
somebody man give me my ball I'm going
home you know what I mean like that kind
of thing like nobody wants to play Caro
that's just kind of annoying like when
you're winning you're not winning yet
you know what I mean you have to be the
fact they say you have to beat them once
in the right opening Middle Line in game
like and in tactics and on clock and uh
you know the air they breathing like
what the heck is this man this is crazy
he's making so he's making practical
problems like he did in the last game
yeah Wesley's played I don't know how
many genius moves in a row like 10
fantastic excellent moves double
exclamation mark moves but he's still
not won the game the car is still
fighting still ducking still punching
and uh will there be some tricks and
traps ahead okay the black king moving
the evaluation ball says white should be
doing well but look at it it's dropping
every move because from a human point of
view it's difficult it's not easy maybe
that black Bishop moves jumps in to E2
to attack the white Rook what is Hikaru
got up his sleeve now for sure there's
going to be some type of trick some type
of tactic it's not easy anymore maybe
the black Rooker so on some point is
going to come over to B8 as well some
pins over there for first you have to
defend this black Bishop whoa what type
of move is that the best move probably
because you saw the eval bar it approves
it says that Hikaru is still in the game
I don't know how he does it but Bishop
G4 on the board look at the clock for
Wesley once again he's getting low on
time he's getting low on time every time
this happens what happens it's not good
every time he's been low on time the
history repeats itself and that's
because the car was so tricky he is
going to set
every move you need those seconds to
navigate through the complications
carrying a winning position against this
guy is just not enough Wesley with a big
Advantage Robert will he be able to
convert this one but now it's anything
but clear because the F4 Pawn black has
multiple piece attacking that Rook on F2
for black is attacking not just that
pawn but also the B2 Square in front of
the white king and the black Rook that
has been sitting on h8 this entire game
it's ready to jump on over to B8 and
start threading not just the bishop but
the pawn behind it so all of a sudden
black has a legitimate attack and white
a pawn is one move too slow if you could
go A5 in one turn if you just put it
there you're winning the game on the
spot it's going forward to A6 A7 and A8
but it's a little bit too slow he puts
his Bishop on A6 but the eval bar goes
back to level oh my goodness that I mean
he's firstly he's walking into some
night folks some night jumps secondly
how are you actually going to answer
this threat against your pawn it looks
like you're stepping forward but now the
world's gonna jump oh man you're right
Knight F4 first everything's hanging
okay over K3 or D6 yeah this is really
scary suddenly right there's no time oh
20 seconds yeah that's it this is it
yeah he car was going he car was going
to the ship Right double attack that's
it and uh let's go back to the players
at least at least the draw yeah he
started again yeah there's some time
he's done it again it's 12. down two
pawns down two pawns almost getting
mated with his own King on G7 and then
finds this amazing way to create tactics
and now is Wesley the one who's in
trouble you can jump in with a check
capture that B2 Pawn
you know what I actually thought it was
white smoke because I couldn't believe
the fact that he played Bishop C4 I was
like no he can't I mean you can't allow
me to take on B2 can you repeat two I
guess he's saying A2 defended yeah A2 is
defending there could be some tricks
that Wesley has up his sleeve because
upon F7 the bishop is in line with it
there could be threats towards the black
king so I'd be very very nervous here
for both players because that Bishop
Muncie for it defends the white king and
also attacks the black king like your
point I think the point that you're
trying to make well but just to finish
that off that eighth that eighth round
crook moves anywhere then White's the
one who steps up with his own rook and
don't forget that G8 Square it could be
a check made on that that would be a big
trouble for black skin just to show
actually taking this is a huge blunder I
have to be more natural if you move your
Rook for example you get mated simple as
that it's the black king not the white
king that gets trapped 17 seconds 13
seconds for Wesley now to fight against
this what a genius move though Bishop C4
dropping it back saying please take this
Pawn it's poisoned if you take this Pawn
Hikaru you will lose this game uh why
what else could it be maybe it's the
other room maybe it's the other Rook
what's the evaluation I'm going to say
it says yes and the King moves but now
what do you play maybe the idea is to
get rid of this thorn in the side by
dropping your knight into the center but
this is not easy you eliminate the piece
that might trap the black king who's
checkmating who that's the question up a
pawn there and so it's not clear who has
the edge we have the evaluation bar
saying yeah it's Dynamic equality it's
clearly an equal position no of course
not right they're looking at this like
this is crazy it's Mayhem and you see
Hikaru he's down to two minutes he's
been spending nearly two minutes on this
turn he knows it's a critical moment and
he's not sure what to do by the way
Fabiano caruana it looks like has a
massive advantage against artemiev whoa
wow Armageddon everyone I mean we don't
know actually we gotta be you know never
know
going up in this game too so both
players with the white pieces carwana
and here Wesley so they're doing well in
H5 going for the king oh that black king
is in big big trouble and six seconds on
the clock Wesley if he can land
checkmate with two seconds left he's
gonna be happy but it's gonna be so hard
to navigate this one and while Wesley
has six seconds left our Tamiya is down
to five seconds and it looks like
Fabiano caruana will be making a
comeback in his game if we can just
quickly get an update on that one
what is happening Rook F7 is a maiden
one let's stay right here I think you
can just take the bishop
and then you repeat you have to go King
E7 Rook D7 wait but I have key six I'm
running away how am I not winning yeah
black is running away there's no
Checkmate if there's no Checkmate it's a
free piece and Hikaru might be closer to
that draw you have to worry about a few
captures here and there white H6 Pawn
might become a new Queen in some lines
everything's happening it's so
complicated I think we need to stop
fishing the computer to suggest moves oh
987 I think is a draw I think that's
probably the way it's not enough oh
you're right yeah yeah it's not enough I
was just trying to figure out why is
this draw yeah yeah
look at a girl who knows it he's
calculating what he knows he's done it
yeah that's it just go towards the night
what's wrong with that one and then
check and you can't go to the corner I
think because
he needs to win yeah it's desperation
trading pieces was not going to get it
done he wants to bring the Knight back
but where does Trump it's trapped
exactly this is going to be a win for a
car yeah oh that's that's that's tricky
don't take that knife eight seven and
you're not going to be able to save that
bond from promoting you're not going to
stop that bond in your face that's a
that's such a sweet move night of Faith
wow if you had to take pieces in Chess
this would be a winning move but black
can reject the offer just defend the
pawn that the White Knight wants to come
back and take and I think you should be
fine drop back to black Bishop for
example drop back to black Rook I'm not
sure which one but it should be fine
hikaru's got less than a minute he's a
piece up what what what what are we
doing because the black Rook can drop
down with a check and go behind save the
day yeah so well these players are so
good I've got to say drop that Rook down
Hikaru and you will not lose this game
he does it how does he find there's just
amazing stuff by Hikaru and Rook H1 he's
gonna take the queen and this end game
only black can try yeah and he doesn't
need to win the game so he just a draw
sends him through to the winners final
he is trying to make a draw right now he
does not want to win he just wants to go
through yeah you have to be slightly
careful where you put your pieces but
now he's bringing the black king across
the black Bishop is able to guard the
promotion square of the white Pawn the
white Pawn promotes on light squares
Black's Bishop will guard that will even
give itself up if it has to and this
should just be a draw if anyone's better
it's got to be back especially with this
extra Pawn we have here too as well we
can sack and we'll have an extra piece
and the pawn making you have to maybe
even sacrifice your Rook for uh for the
pawn and we end up having a draw here
wow this looks like Hikaru will be
advancing to the Winner's bracket final
let's go back to the other game because
Fabiano Carona is making a comeback on
the board and on the clock look at that
black king it is under Fire and how many
pawns is that three extra Pawns of Fabi
he's not gonna mess this one up
you can only not need it though he ain't
made it yet
it's not me yeah yeah James is always
like that he's our Champion's down under
five seconds no our Tammy is doing well
okay fine he's okay he's okay guys he's
fine I like what fabi's done he's just
protected everything look at those
Knights they're each other's best friend
here defending protecting and the White
Queen will eventually break through you
can throw a Central Pawn forward here if
the white Rook gets into the attack that
black king is on an open line but first
he's protecting everything three pawns
up you don't need to check mate when
you've got three extra pawns and it is
official Nakamura has drawn his game
against Wesley which means Wesley moves
on to the losers bracket while Hikaru
continues in the Winner's bracket while
action's still on here David you called
it that Fabi will level this one and we
will get an Armageddon it looks likely
but I'm not going to I'm not going to
write him off just yet vladislava tell
me if he's so resourceful remember he
beat Magnus in an Armageddon as well so
even if it does get there then uh Fabi
will have his work cut out but meanwhile
the attack's gone White's King Super
safe three extra pawns what more can you
say I think I could bring one more piece
into the attack the Knight on E1 maybe
it's time to hop that one forward we
just got out of a pin let's bring that
Knight to deliver the Checkmate it looks
like the last piece you would think to
help out but the Knight can jump forward
to D3 hitting the Rook back there then
continue there it goes the knight's
coming into F4 and over to G6 yeah oh
nice do it now bring that Knight in and
that will be the Hammer Blue the final
touch to this game really nice game from
Fabi you've got to say yeah
pointed out Robert you call it check
pick up the bishop with a check and now
pick up the Rook you don't even need to
look for a mate it probably does exist
then move like Queen F5 Tottenham made
on G6 but what a does it what a guy what
a guy he says I don't want your Rook I
want and look at Savvy he knows he's
done what needed to be done to get that
win and vladislav our time you have
resigns what a nice comeback what a
brilliant finish there by Fabi yeah
because he finished what he started
every single game that we saw off of and
it was well ahead on the clock he just
couldn't put artemia away in artemia's
time trouble but this time he had a huge
I was keeping track he was up six
minutes on the clock and he made our 10
me a pay wow he finally got it done of
course yeah he had that lead every time
right and he was doing good and then we
like oh yeah and then and then he gets
long time or timia and he does some
spectacular things in time trouble even
putting away Magnus twice with the same
amount of time right so but not this
time Bobby's like not this time I'm
tired of this and he finally was able to
clinch that and going we're going to
Armageddon boys yeah Bobby strikes back
we will go into an Armageddon while
Hikaru does advance further let's do a
deep dive of this dramatic round with
David
yeah so much drama it's hard to even
pick a highlight Fabiano well played for
him he takes its Armageddon but I want
to highlight the game between Wesley so
and hikar and Nakamura Wesley so close
again to taking that win but not close
enough in this position he played a very
natural move he brought his Rook forward
but after rotates Bishop there was no
Checkmate Hikaru had grabbed a piece and
was safe if however Wesley had found the
genius move G6 we would have been
heading to Armageddon this is so
difficult for a human James right but uh
it's the clock if Wesley had five
minutes maybe the whole idea here is
that uh for example if Pawn takes now
you capture this Pawn the king moves a
check the king moves again and there's
this beautiful killer blow at the very
end it's so difficult to see
Bishops what the whole point is you
eliminate all the pieces and at the very
end White's night simply moves you make
a new Queen What A variation is this
never gonna be found by a human but
Wesley this was his chance
chess is a beautiful game and with that
let's take a look at our score line of
the Winner's bracket semi-finals we do
have action left as Fabiano caruana
managed to level the score and take it
to the Armageddon we will have the bids
of the players very soon exciting
exciting Armageddon coming up in the
other one Hikaru Nakamura what a match
that was he won in a game two kept it
solid throughout managed to save some
very difficult moments and with that won
his match against Wesley so let's bring
on the winner of that match Hikaru he's
joining us congratulations Hikaru
thank you guys appreciate it it worked
out it did work out although even after
winning that second game you were in
trouble in game three and four
yeah well I mean in game three game
three I mean I simply confused my lines
early on
um and then I was just too passive and
probably at some point I was lost but
Wesley then made a huge blunder I should
have won the game as well so I mean the
third game could have gone either way
this fourth game probably I was in
trouble for most of it but once it was
kind of getting low on time and the
position was just uh very chaotic um I
mean I think I I think I played really
really well to survive to the point when
I got this Rook B2 but I think I made a
couple of bad moves there I haven't
looked at obviously but it felt like um
felt like I had something and then
apparently there's a win with this G6
move but you know it is what it is it
was a pretty much a bullet game at the
end
yeah hikara you you played really
fantastic resourceful defense but I
actually want to ask you about the
opening choices because you played
Wesley so many times now so many
Berlin's how did you choose what
openings to play today
I mean you just pick an opening you play
chess that's that's all I did I mean
it's not like my first game was very
inspiring
um you know the second game I think I've
played this line before in this Italian
with this whole d5d4 something very
similar to it um I mean I just think the
second game was was the only game which
was smooth everything else was was
choppy but you just pick openings you
play chess and we played each other
probably hundreds of times now if you
include rapid and Blitz and um yeah I
just picked something and roll the dice
hey Carl gray play as usual bro what we
want to know is how are you so
resourceful what can we do to get a
little bit of fraction of
resourcefulness like that
I mean I I don't think there's any
Secret in terms of how to do it I think
at the end of the day um it's in the
mind though if you believe in yourself
if it's in your mind that you can do
certain things good things happen there
you go
and Hikaru congratulations it must be a
relief to see the back of Wesley but
tomorrow you face uh vladislav or
Fabiana who'd you rather play
I mean I I it doesn't matter at all
because I think by winning this match
I'm guaranteed to uh be in the top three
if my math works out
um so I think I top three guarantees a
spot in the next event that's really the
only thing that matters I mean as long
as you finish in the top three I don't
care I could finish third second first
it's it's all pretty relevant it's just
the fact that I um that I'm guaranteed
to play the next event I don't have to
go through the whole slog of playing the
qualifiers so that's that's what I'm
happiest about it doesn't matter who I
play just finishing top three is the
only thing that matters
the action and the drama in the
trustable Masters feels like a lot more
than we had in the first event are you
feeling this momentum as well with this
exciting mix of flares that we have
yeah I mean I I think um it's definitely
a little bit different I I guess what I
would say is I didn't have a chance to
look at all the games today but I think
yesterday there's a simple reason it was
exciting which is everyone was playing
like they were completely drunk
um so there were so many blunders in
every single match that I saw today I
don't know as much about
um but I think certainly when you don't
have the same set of top players in
every single event they're going to be
wild things happening yeah and
um yeah it's just uh it's great to be on
the the winning end but I think at the
end of the day it's just trying to keep
finding resources trying to keep the
game going get your opponents on time
and uh I seem to be doing a pretty good
job of that for someone who doesn't play
chess professionally
heck are you keep saying that and then
you keep coming up with these big
results we stopped believing you now
with the whole
no interest professionally I mean I am
not playing over the board shots other
than a handful of terms a year so
um I I don't know what you want me to
say it's like you're trying to get me to
say something that gets clipped where
where I'm gonna sound like like really
arrogant or something but I mean the
simple fact is like I'm just doing what
I'm doing and it's I mean I'm not
studying as much chess now as I was four
years ago let's just be clear on that um
nowhere near as much so I mean it's what
it is and yet here you are re-entering
the world top five Hikaru we love it and
fantastic performance today all the best
for tomorrow
thank you so much you guys appreciate it
hey guys
we're not there anymore I
I buy him we've got big action coming up
with the Armageddon but before that we
are going to go into a twitch break and
a very special look at our tamiyev
coming up he has been on fire in this
tournament
[Music]
so it's not a center of Russia not the
chess Center
and the in this city I I make my first
steps on a chess board and I also would
like to say that my father was just a
Mater and
he to support me when I wanted to start
chess learning chess I would like to say
many friends to my father for this great
way I started learning chess probably
between
six and seven years I think that
immediately I have positive emotions and
my first good results
was quickly vladislav altamiyak became a
great chess player at an early age he
also became a father when he was quite
young his daughter Anna was born two
years ago we have a little child
and it's a very big day for me because
uh
many people
I have dreams are to be parents and not
not every can
can have it finally so I very love my
daughter and I hope that
our waiting for many happiest days
I will show just the pieces
Bishops Rooks and I hope that it will be
interesting for her vladislav has dreams
for his daughter but he also has Big
Dreams for himself maybe
in future I would like to be a candidate
on world title maybe it's not easy but I
will try to improve my chest and
training and maybe I will have some
chances I like sport atmosphere and it's
it's my life and
all right tell me I was just such a nice
guy but it is time to go into an
Armageddon which just means that you've
got to put that being nice guy behind
you because that's the only way to win
the Armageddon of course we are waiting
for the players bids and the this these
are the regulations for the Armageddon
the player who bids the lower time wins
decides the color usually it's black
because black cats result odds which
means if it's a draw black wins the
match whoever gets white has to win on
demand but that means that white would
start with 15 minutes that is the base
time
Robert how important is it for the
players to get the black pieces you know
I this is an interesting match for me
because artemiev he had white against
Magnus a magnet is actually in a good
position and caught up on the clock but
then blundered his Queen at some point
and for Fabiano he's had a huge lead on
the clock every single game and against
Liam yesterday he won with the white
piece so I don't know what to choose
and it is mind game games going on right
now as we are waiting for the bids to
come in to reveal the bids it is about
how low can you go with your bid to get
those black pieces it's going to be
critical black gets result odds while
white has to win on demand but white
gets those extra minutes on the clock
David what are you expecting here well
normally with most players I think they
want black here I think both players
actually are very happy with the white
pieces Fabiano just one with white with
15 minutes a clock advantage against the
slightly slower tell me if why not
Artemis needs the time he took down
magnets with white with 15 minutes but
it was close but yeah I can't see him
catching him up on the clock if he
starts with black James do you think
then we're gonna have very close bids
and perhaps not compromising on the
clock too much I think they're going to
be a little bit close but I actually
think I'm gonna take a curveball here
and say I think our team here is going
to bid low or he's scared he does he he
thinks a lot but it's going to be like
you know I'll take black and I'll take
the less time but I'm gonna move fast
because he's actually really fast and
when he has low time he plays better as
strange as that is so I think that's my
pick there
we saw the players there making that bit
by our time you have expression yes how
do they stay so in control
very calm we're gonna have bids really
soon
the player is talking to the staff
behind the scenes and I mean I think for
our temi over he won with the white
pieces against Bobby but Bobby was
better with black so I just don't know
what he's gonna do what his bid will be
is super unclear to me yeah I'm trying
to recall what they bid yesterday uh
vladislav I think was over 10 minutes
yeah and uh Fabi was against Liam also
over time over 10 minutes as well so it
might be very very close uh if I were
Vlad I would just bid 14.59
get those white pieces yeah it almost
feels like it doesn't matter what he
bits 20 moves into the game he's going
to be playing with a minute on the clock
and playing god-level chess might as
well take the black pieces right just
take the black pieces I got two options
draw or win right and I got low time and
I played better when I have low time
that's the sergeant yet sounds logical
when you put it like that James but
these players yeah the emotions are
going to be racing of course yeah sorry
go ahead Robert completely thought no
this is so difficult right because
artemiev he is faster in time scrambles
but he's slower out of the gate so I
just don't know who prefers what yeah
wow I can't wait to see those bids I
think it's going to be dramatic either
way and I think we're going to see a
decisive result on the board I can't see
either side playing solid they just
don't know how to play for drugs these
days even though we did have two draws
between a Fabi and artemia but both
games they were fire on the board our
camera was winning he managed to survive
and it is time to reveal the player bit
wow our Tammy had made a 12 and a half
minute bid that makes a lot of sense not
losing too much time on the clock but
Fabiano caruana wins the bidding war he
starts with 9 minutes and 59 seconds
that gets the black pieces yeah that's
what he wanted and as David was saying
yesterday both paid above 10 minutes so
far we thought maybe 10 minutes was the
minimum that our temmiev would go and
his limbo was just a little bit more
Nimble for Fabiano he gets the black
pieces I think he's very happy about
this yeah so our time we have starts
with 15 minutes on the talk that's
almost that's a five minute and a one
second Advantage but we've seen our time
we have go down on the clock that's
gonna go level so James basically Fabi
gets result odds our time you have has
to go for blood he has to go for blood
he can't try his regular Knight F3 so I
mean let's try to go to an end game and
try to in-game him because he even
in-game Carlson right so it's actually
very important to get something going
here maybe play something short we'll
see
well David what are you expecting in the
opening well from Fabi it's just his
best repertoire his most solid
repertoire he shut down our teammate in
the first game of the day very
impressively with black in the third
game also very very impressive getting
an opening Advantage so it's about as
James says the opening for artemia from
Fabi it's clear his strategy the draw
but Automotive needs to handle those
extra five minutes really well he can't
tank he can't think early doors if he
does that Bobby's just gonna flag him
yeah Bobby's actually playing the better
chest between the two today Bobby's had
the advantage for a larger majority of
their games if I'm gonna blundered in
time trouble and lost that one but he
was better throughout and then in game
four he came back and smashed through so
I feel like Bobby should be confident
about his chest yeah in just a few
moments we will have the Armageddon the
players are getting ready to go David
Sabi did make a comeback winning that
game four do you think momentum is on
his side yes that's why I predicted he
would choose the white pieces I thought
he'd go for a win again he's just one
with white why not try again but uh he
needs to switch things up and momentum
might be on Fabi side but momentum is
out the window Armageddon is a lottery
it's just about who is more focused at
the time and uh we see the floating
chair will we see the move start coming
out well last time we have uh the
magician that he is is away from the
board we're just waiting for his
opponent to return to play the first
moves action is about to kick off did
you see that as well Fabio was literally
stretching his wrist he was literally
getting ready getting limber
this work only flexible all right let's
get it all right you're probably ready
Bobby's ready right is that the warm-up
to flag your opponent by making really
fast moves yeah you gotta have that
Mouse speed so he's loosen up the wrist
he's making sure that he's gonna be set
and for our team up he's just getting
back maybe he was giving his daughter a
good night kiss you know he was that
video he just said how important his
daughter is to him we see the cats in
the back so uh you know for our team I
think he needs to put all that aside No
More Mr Nice Guy he's got to go for the
kill
yeah dressed to impress her blood is
match that on the board uh his lucky
outfit bringing him luck yesterday
against Magnus in the Armageddon if you
could take down Magnus he's got to
believe he can take down Fabi too that's
uh yeah it will be a race I'm expecting
Knight F3 something solid and like you
said James it didn't work out earlier
but he needs uh to find a way somehow
passed about these defenses he's also
ready 903 C4 so let's see if we get her
ready are we ready
okay could it be I was gonna say could
it be the Queen's Gambit declined no no
theory in this one
wow and Fabi forced to think early in
this game okay he brings his Knight to
the edge this is not the typical London
uh both sides have flicked in this
little pawn move on the C file which
maybe isn't great news for Fabi normally
you want to break early in the center
with black against uh the London system
but he's forced this bishop to retreat
you don't want to allow a trade Knight
for Bishop early in the game Bishop
surprised very highly by these top
players and artemio's choice to play C3
that early that's not typical either the
problem with playing Fabiano he studies
all the lines so you may think oh I'm
gonna catch him here he quickly brought
his Knight to the rim to attack that
Bishop so he is unafraid of this
unorthodox London and for artemiev he
had a big time advantage to start that
time Advantage might lessen if he keeps
spending uh so many minutes in the early
stages yeah I'm really surprised what
he's doing with his Bishop because the
white Bishop is just going to get caught
on the edge of the board he's going to
get attacked and uh later on black will
be able to NAB the bishop pair first
Fabi brings this own Bishop out very
logical stuff and let you say Robert
he's just so well prepared how do you
catch Fabi in the opening I want to know
it's uh difficult and yeah so far
looking good for black and is that the
reason that he's chosen this slightly
off-beat opening that he doesn't usually
play are Tammy have just to avoid any
theoretical battles against Fabi
that is the logic but unfortunately uh
if you don't play theoretical lines
you're unlikely to get an advantage with
white and you need to win that's the
problem I'm just wondering here and I
think James I'm curious what your
thoughts are because I feel like for
artemia we know how good he is a bullet
over 3 100 right but do you think he can
get into that mental gear where he's
like I'm ready to take it down and just
flag you right you know what absolutely
in fact especially as strong as he is in
the bullet if I need to flag you I'm
just going to do that right especially
it's a gear that you just go into that
gear when you're playing bullet chess
you just oh it's just you you have that
intuition
um that's that uh the mouse beat you
know and that experience from playing so
much online chess here so when he needs
to he'll kick it in the next gear here
especially I mean this time Edge he has
right now is starting to diminish a
little bit
something that our time you have can
start considering already it's certainly
something he was considering that he
should consider but okay the Black
Knight is retreated anyway and it cost
him around a minute that is too much in
Armageddon chess with no increment the
five minute Advantage he started with is
around three minutes now so he's lost
two of his uh extra minutes that's a bad
sign it's so early in the game the game
will not be decided now it'll be decided
far far in the future you need those
minutes in the banking Armageddon
especially he's definitely not switched
out of that increment mode that we saw
from him earlier and C4 he's lost a move
that pawns moved twice it's a very
standard position now yeah this is what
you call off the head chest he's just
like moving pieces around like let's
play London well no let's play like an
accelerated London now and unless I
guess put the bishop on E2 and just he
plays off the head and unorthodox in a
way which can definitely help especially
if you can get fobby thinking here but I
mean Fabi has no problems he got all
these almost all the pieces developed
here I'm gonna Castle get the queen
maybe the C7 or E7 I'm fine it says Fabi
he's probably also confident he's hasn't
even spent a minute thus far and artemiv
once again spending early minutes early
uh minutes in the game and I feel like
for Fabi he must be coming he won game
four he only lost game three due to a
blunder of time scramble so I think that
he should be happy with his chest I'm
just worried about his mouth speed I
know he was flexing that wrist
stretching out but when it comes down to
those final seconds he isn't the fastest
player amongst the elite yeah worried
about our time yes clock you're worried
about fabi's wrist I mean our tummy have
throughout the rapid potion has been
playing on minutes and seconds with no
increment on the clock if he lets that
happen it is match over he cannot afford
to go down on the clock in this one he's
got to keep the pressure up
yeah and I'm just looking at the peace
formations white started with the London
system but black pretty much has a
London system here itself with this nice
Bishops out nice central control that
triangle of Pawns in the center for
black wow I'm really surprised you went
back in this direction I thought he was
going to go the other way with the black
bishop and uh now I'm expecting Vlad uh
to throw pawns forward on the queen side
as fast as possible white has committed
he's locked close the center and
normally you want to play in the
direction that your pawns are facing
White's pawns are facing and towards the
left in that direction so you play on
The Queen side and likewise on the flip
side black tries to play in the center
on the other side of the board still
early days but at least now it will be a
long battle and that tends to favor the
side with more time if Vlad can maintain
that time advantage
it's a big if though if he maintain that
time Advantage because Fabiano has spent
only a minute and change thus far so I
feel like our Tammy has a nice looking
position and he can keep it closed for a
while but he needs to speed up I just
feel like it's not really in his nature
to just Blitz out the opening but he
needs to actually switch that mentality
yeah he's too nice to flag people that
is part of the game in Armageddon chess
uh No More Mr Nice Guy he needs to move
two minute Advantage incoming he's lost
three of those extra minutes what's he
doing what's he thinking about throw
pawns forward Castle the white king or
something yeah
James oh no I had nothing I was just
saying right like yeah you're correct I
completely agree with David here yeah it
just looks like that's the obvious plan
right you start advancing on the side
where you've got your space Advantage
the queen side pawns can start rolling
up the board get your king to safety
it's really fascinating how our temmiev
chooses these moments which look like so
obvious and then he makes the move
Knight to D2 Retreats with the Knight I
wasn't expecting that I wasn't either I
think he's expecting some peace
exchangers just to jump in and explain
this really mysterious move if he played
maybe the most natural move uh I was
assuming this Pawn would jump forward
you want to create what we call a porn
storm here throw pawns forward open up
lines on the side you're stronger then
maybe black would have jumped in with
his own Knight these Bishops might
disappear uh along this diagonal maybe
the knights would disappear too things
would start to get traded heading
towards a draw he needs to win so he
can't allow this instead he drops back
his Knight we see black castle and could
he be considering playing on the
opposite flank what do we think oh yeah
absolutely that's the first move I was
gonna say I was going to say G4
absolutely but of course it looks like
he moved the bishop back to G3 but G4 is
definitely there he Castle G4 G5 I got
to play for a win but okay Bishop G3 is
possible yeah and then I could go Bishop
G3 now I'm fine with Bishop G3 and maybe
Rook G1 now I mean it feels good but
Bishop G3 was played he doesn't take
these risks he doesn't play aggressive
like that no he's just playing the long
game and uh next we'll see him push
these pawns forward but how does Fabi
strike out normally black wants to play
for this break in the center but how do
you arrange it at this precise moment
that square is sufficiently covered so
not easy actually to create counterplay
as Fabi and for the first time in the
game he's really having a long thing and
now we better understand artemio's
previous move he brought his Knight that
was developed in F3 and brought back to
D2 that bishop and queen they're lined
up across the diagonal there they're
covering the key Square so I feel like
he has decided to strike forward with B4
to protect that pawn C5 and black can
continue trying to create Pawn tension
but the pawn tension will remain white
has a little bit more space and I just
feel like black needs a strike in the
center at some point yep strike in the
center first he strikes on the queen
side playing on the side where he's a
bit weaker but maybe just trying to
trade things off and I'll tell me if now
will he just push his own a pawn forward
just to keep the structure intact there
we go normally you don't want to break
your Pawn structure unless you're
completely ready I do worry that the
white king is in the center still
meaning there might be some tricks that
Fabi can utilize will we see the Rooks
leave the board as well the Hoover's out
the vacuum's up yeah it depends on what
they obviously keep the tension here so
if Rook takes Queen takes but I guess
you have Queen A8 but then I Castle so
you have to be careful and not allow
something like Queen A6 to happen or
even Queen A7 is just kind of annoying
right the pieces get over there you can
even have a knight B3 to A5 in some
cases if you allow the white to get very
active there whoa did he just play evil
whoa I did
breaking in the center why not and if
Pawn takes Pawn the Black Knight will
happily move I'm not sure where but uh
it could use this Square it might even
Retreat the whole way and actually this
Pawn is indefensible now this Pawn will
fall Black's night or Bishop will snack
on it next move and change of structure
who's a favor I'm not sure but at least
Fabi is getting active but at least not
balance right we don't have a
symmetrical Pawn structure anymore for
our temmie if you need winning chances
if you lose it's the same as the draw
you need something to happen but look at
Fabi we often hear the best way to play
for a draws to play for a win he's not
just sitting relaxing trading pieces
because he would be worse in almost
every single end game because he has the
weakest Pawn in the position that pawn
on C6 would be a Target as James was
indicating before so I do like this move
E5 he lashes out he is playing
aggressive standard thematic chess and
not just sitting and saying let's just
make a draw he's like no this is the
best way let's be concrete yeah nice
move there and if he opens things up
then maybe the black pieces will start
to enjoy life more and also the time
Advantage is being eaten up one and a
half minutes in it now vladislav needs
to move just get that white king castled
or take the pawn you need to decide
either you go for chaos take that pawn
it gets really unbalanced maybe good for
a must win situation or you Castle the
king to safety it's a stylistic decision
here he can't look too far into the
future uh he's trying to calculate a bit
too much it feels like if Emma or Timmy
have here I'm literally I'm really
trying to pray aggressive honestly with
uh with my pawns but also with the
pieces here I mean I have to not allow
black to get so much counter play right
this is my goal here right I mean I have
to do something now because he will take
and isolate my Pawn on D4 in fact he can
take on D4 then I get an isolated Pawn
now who has a weakness we both do right
nose can be you know very uh Dynamic
both sides have things to do I got a D4
Pawn we yeah of course Knight F3 makes
sense I can take back maybe but I mean I
now have an isolated Pawn on D4 if he
takes so we both have ISO pawns C6 is
weak but D4 is weak but I do like it he
just has to play you know for uh for
peace activity I see yeah decent move
trying to play provocative chess he's
asking black to actually step forward
and block it up in the center again I
think the white knight will happily
Retreat back where it came from losing
two whole mousse for weight but at least
clarifying the central attention and I'm
not sure whether that was worth the time
I would have just casted the white king
away but at least he's paused uh Fabiano
caruana here Fabi difficult decision
stylistically what to go for Block it or
capture he answered it because he
thought it does fall back and I think
for many of us to understand is very
important that if all the major pieces
do get traded actually it does favor
white in these positions simply because
of the queen Side Pawn structure yeah
and the dark Square Bishop for white is
way better than its counterpart the
bishop on G3 stares through the line all
the way to the enemy territory the
bishop on E7 is blockaded it's blunted
by that pawn on C5 so that decision to
play E4 that was a game-changing
decision not that the evaluation bar is
completely out of hand but he could have
taken on D4 but he was worried about
tactics so that was a big moment it's
worth analysis but right now I think the
current state of affairs definitely
favors artemia and just to follow up on
what Robert said he he is taking
advantage of the B open B file because
black doesn't have the option to bring
the Rook slide it down to that B8 Square
because of that Bishop on G3 that is the
key piece in White's position it's like
a sniper it's like an Archer from afar
just peering all over this diagonal
cutting the board in half and white has
the advantage look at that evaluation
bar it's all about Artemis right now uh
still with one extra minute on the clock
he's brought his Knight forward as well
I was just thinking that it's 984 and
ib6 idea and literally just killing the
queen side every piece I own is going to
go to the queen side over here Fabi
definitely needs to do something fast
with this dark Square Bishop I mean that
Bishop is menacing I mean even Rook a
seven is coming we're over to C7 Queen
A4 Knight B3 Knight A5 the Pawn's mine
right it's very very difficult now of
course if you get to Rook to C7 it may
be a bishop d8 so you have to be careful
but uh the C6 is very weak white has a
very clear plan yeah meanwhile Fabi
needs the Checkmate while the white
pieces are distracted over there on the
queen side he's got to go for the white
king hence his last move pushing that
black H Pawn forward Harry making an
appearance again hurry
but uh he's doing what he needs to do he
needs to Checkmate white I think that's
the only way it seemed it could seem
desperate you could read that as oh he's
getting in trouble on the queen side so
he's just throwing his possible it
actually is thematic right you attack in
the direction of your Pawn chain White's
Pawn chain all the way towards the queen
side blacks Pawn chain from C6 D5 E4
into the center over towards the king
side so Bobby's throwing his pieces
forward and he's creating some chaos and
if you look at the clock it's about even
so white has an advantage according to
the evaluation bar but when you sit and
play at this high level you're not
thinking oh I'm you know 1.2 better
you're looking at this and you're saying
this looks complicated I may crash
through on the queen side over here or I
may get checkmate on the king side yeah
and in those terms Robert the stakes are
higher for white White's King is much
more valuable than those black pawns on
the queen side so White's play is
designed in a materialistic fashion you
want to pick off pawns you want to
slowly Advance you want to trade off
pieces but for black it's one-way
traffic you just checked mate there's
one goal and that's actually easier to
play when you're short of time like this
in Blitz just it's easier to attack than
defend right and uh that's why I'll tell
me if it's tanking 100 because I mean
after Ace three I mean I don't know if
I'm a psyched out or not but I
definitely okay so you play H4 because
he was like I mean he might sack it so
it is possible we play H4 here I'm also
looking at believe it or not white
playing Knight A8 just whoa it's such a
stupid move because but it's so funny I
mean I actually played a game OCB where
I put a knight on H1 and when I put it I
twisted it because you never make a move
like that right so Knight A8 just going
back for a knight to C7 looks pretty fun
it's a fun move now Knight G4 blocks
everything I don't know what we got oh
he's hitting H4 that's what he wants
yeah so maybe Knight A8 now but I mean
the idea here is I want to clear that I
want to clear the way of the Knight to
get the queen involved Queen B7 and and
also um Rook a you know Rook takes C6
whoa you want to move this one five okay
same idea James but maybe an even better
route into that Square thank you fella
what are you doing taking this point
somebody says 64. yeah there's a pen and
if you take it Bishop C4 it's a skewer
it's on the board okay and mix up F7 as
well wow look at this double attack
who's up on material here it doesn't
even matter it's just pure Chaos on the
board and uh pieces everywhere white has
a rook and two pawns black has two minor
pieces White's one point ahead but and
can happen here and I like the minor
pieces because as you were saying
Checkmate ends the game white king not
the safest but Black's King also is in a
bit iffy territory there are not many
pawns shielding it but H4 is loose the
bishop the Dark Sword bishop and the
Knight for black team up on that pawn I
think that this is a crazy position and
I'm looking at the clock artemium is the
one down on time and there is no
increment in this game he's lived on the
increment he can't live on increment
because it doesn't exist that's a race
to the finishing line now and okay Fabi
has snatched upon White's lone defender
of his King is that Bishop White's
Bishop if it's traded off suddenly you
start to be worried that for a time yeah
as I saw in the chat there Fabio about
to enter god mode he's at least trying
to uh big attack incoming
stem the flow can he maybe launch an
attack of his own bring the white Rook
up to the seventh rank threaten the
Checkmate of his own against the black
king that's nice I think you have to
take it first you just just to have your
your uh the Knight you have to make a
few moves before you actually are mating
me you do have to get on this dark
Square diagonal and be Queen H2 that's
going to be difficult it's not actually
that easy yet and I do have some threats
of my own in fact your queen is a little
short on spaces there but if I let you
know you have to do something because
Bishop takes G3 is very it's ugly I mean
your structured ugly E3 is going to fall
at some point right so it's very
annoying so you may have to take and
then maybe Queen C6 or Rook A7 now you
may have to take but you definitely have
to move look at this one and a half
minutes down now I'll tell me if he's
Frozen this too much in an Armageddon
you can't burn the clock so much make a
move what's going on there Robert and
let's not forget that Fabiano caruana is
the only player who has not lost a match
either in the air things Masters or The
Trestle Masters he came through division
two but he won every single match he
played he won yesterday right now he's
in Armageddon so he has not lost and we
see a trade of Bishops and G3 what a
calm move from our team of kicking the
night out of there but he didn't take
the potency six just yet and I guess a
big question is is that Knight actually
under attack sometimes you can't take a
piece if it opens up your king
but three and a half minutes for our
time we have this is a panic time he
needs to start building an attack
against the black king should n't idea
ideas of capturing the C6 spawner
doubling up on the seventh rank yeah
he's definitely angling towards that if
the Black Knight Retreats if black steps
back white will happily have the time to
start grabbing pawns but I think the
question is as uh you're both alluding
to that do you have to move that black
knight can you somehow bring that black
queen into the game if you could pick
her up just drop her anywhere near the
white king it's a Checkmate but how do
you get there what's the route into
White's position that's what Fabian is
trying to work out right now he's
thinking about Queen G6 and just
sacrificing the night just uh pinning
that King on G1 but then you probably
pick up the C6 Pawn Robert but I see
what you're saying you're looking for a
draw because black wins with the draw
result he he does sacrifice oh my gosh
that Bishop hits the queen and the rook
in a row but also it goes to the F2 Pawn
so it's kind of a double threat what a
move from Fabiano fabul with them
calculations over everything look at him
that's a big boy move from a big fella
no matter what you do in fact work A8
Bishop C8 any move you make bishop C8
right so you have to be very careful
that is a sick move from Fabi Queen f8
world-class move from fabianos that
would not be on most players radar just
x-ray vision through the through the
bishop through its own piece and
vladislavartame brings this queen to the
side he's ready to drop back Bishop
after this is just over yeah but we're
treating moves are the easiest to miss
but this is a game-ending move double
attack if he finds it he wins on the
spot look at that the engine says plus
seven for black
and leans back he knows this is a big
moment has missed it and our Tamia
realizes this is busted for white takes
his head it's over Fabi Oh My Fabulous
Fabi watch move queen of Fate that is
genius just that double attack was too
sneaky vladislav didn't have enough time
to deal with it just the shock of that
move Queen takes porn now would end in
Checkmate or the white Rook will drop
one or the other no exaggeration but
with the speed with how little time he
has with the tension of the moment
that's early candidate from move of the
year that was a nasty move yeah I think
Queen more than the bishop
saying stuff right oh my gosh now it's
up a piece yeah yep he's just a draw
this is just over F5 Fighters got no
compensation the F5 Pawn Falls as well
the only hope that our Tamia has got is
to pick up the C pawn and start marching
down with the central pawns how
dangerous is that
um those phones are protected and uh
yeah clear piece up wow you don't even
have one Pawn to compensate for that
extra Bishop now and look at that black
knight beautiful blockader in the center
of the board this one as long as Fabi
doesn't Mouse slip or lose on time it is
over
Fabiano the human calculator Coe
beautiful yeah it's why they call them
that that was insane like that truly
deserves as many instant replays as you
can give it and five minutes maybe down
on the clock that's the thing normally
white has this big time Advantage but
right now Fabiano head in the clock he
found that Queen f8 moves so quickly
that was nasty that was yeah most
beautiful moves their sacrifices you
sack your queen you sack your Rook you
break through you Checkmate that was
just subtle it was just kind of the
Hidden Beauty behind it that's another
level another time you have collapsed
right the plundering into Bishop C8 and
that's what happens when you make moves
like Queen f8 with no obvious idea and
they're so difficult to find because
it's not a forward move it's just a
slight shift of the queen leaving the
Knight hanging and this end game though
artemiev is playing there are no chances
at all yeah he's doing the right thing
why resign and go home go home might as
well play a few more moves at least
Force Fabi to show the uh the final
touches
yeah Fabi has got nervous in the past so
some track record there but yeah I agree
Tanya I think 99.99 of the time Fabi uh
will win this one and uh okay the king's
coming in but the Black Knight can come
in with a check now stop picking off
pawns or the black king can just slide
back play it safe why not thank you just
not allowing any checks any Fork picking
up the C6 Pawn there is a check from D6
but it doesn't matter black can just
slide over with the King to E7 now yeah
because you make a draw I I honestly
keep forgetting about that that black
I'm like oh it's easily winning but he
can just repeat the moves and of course
vladislav does it at best a draw is good
for him in a normal game but this is a
normal time again wow he just said yeah
that's professional yeah that's
professional yeah wow and Fabi there he
knows he was trailing the match he won
the fourth game making a comeback forces
it into the Armageddon and amazing play
with the black pieces there yeah you
know he kept steady on the clock he of
course played a great game but credits
of vlades of artemium that Knight takes
D5 move happened at a thin air he took
it to Fabiano he gave him all he could
handle but Fabiana was just on his
rarest best form yeah he did our time we
have did create his chances with the
white pieces in a win on demand but we
all know what was the moment and let's
do a deep dive at this stunning position
David take it away yeah some what a move
what a moment it was it clinched the
match for Fabiano caruana and none of us
saw her coming here in the studio and
I'll tell me if most importantly didn't
see it coming either here Black's Knight
is attacked White's just pushed upon
forward most of us would Retreat this
night what could be more natural but
Fabiano had a counter-attack up his
sleeve he shifted the queen across using
an x-ray to actually threaten some
checkmating ideas more importantly the
bishop is about to move out the way with
Tempo and uh Fabiano missed this of
course the only defense was so difficult
to spot you needed to bring your Rook up
to the top of the board with the idea
that if the bishop Dives back with a
double attack hitting the queen hitting
this Pawn as well you can actually
ignore the threat to your queen you can
play Knight takes Pawn so difficult to
spot because this bishop is actually
pinned it is uh pinned to the queen if
you take the White Queen now white
emerges with a material advantage of
course this was missed the White Queen
moved out the way the black Bishop
dropped back and Fabiano caruana moved
to the next round Queen takes F2
threatened and Bishop takes A6
threatened this way is too much for a
tamif to handle
stunning stuff that by Fabiano caruana
and with that he stays in the Winner's
bracket let's take a look at our results
from the semi-finals what a day of
action we've had first take our Nakamura
wrapping up his match against Wesley so
in the rapid portion with two and a half
points and then Fabi making a comeback
in his match winning the fourth rapid
game taking it to the Armageddon and
then this moment that David showed us
just a complete collapse there by our
tamiyap Fabiano caruana stays in the
Winner's bracket vladislav our time we
have and Wesley so move to the
elimination bracket we've got Tabby with
us let's bring him on Fabi
congratulations
wow that was a really dramatic match a
roller coaster one sum it up for us Fabi
yeah I guess the first game already
showed how uh how messy this match was
likely to be I was much much better
probably winning than I was dead like
completely dead
um I was almost ready to like mentally
resigning uh but somehow I drew that
first game
um
and oh I mean the well sorry the the
first the first game was just like a
boring draw so I almost forgot about it
but like the the second game where I had
the white pieces is what I mean
um so that was a crazy one and then
I lost like a complete uh idiot I mean I
I don't know what I was thinking like I
was better the whole game and then
suddenly I okay I should take a draw but
somehow I decided
um to play on and immediately give him a
much much better and probably winning
position
so that was a terrible game uh to
recovering from a mentally was already
um was already difficult but luckily I
got a very nice position from the
opening and the fourth game
and I don't know if it was smooth like
at some point
I was considering for a long time do I
play 91 because I was sure that he would
sacrifice uh the palm of Knight F4 and
so basically I I wasn't sure about it I
saw this line up to like my takes of
seven it looked like a mess
um but then I decided I'll go for it and
and count on his time trouble and
hopefully he won't be able to find the
best way
and yeah that was super important and
the Armageddon also was a mess I mean I
might have been much worse at some point
it was I was very happy when I saw this
queen f8 because at first I Knight F3
was like the first instinct but it
didn't seem entirely uh convincing and
then I suddenly noticed that like I saw
Bishop C8 and then
um and then there's like some Queen
update ideas so first I was looking at
Bishop C8 and and then suddenly I
noticed that I can start with queen f8
and it's probably a more promising
version
so yeah it was a very tough day very
top-notch
I mean it was a
portion we saw
we saw so many times that our time have
played amazing chess with just seconds
on the clock was that frustrating at any
point that you were not able to make the
most of the clock situation
yeah it felt a little bit like the the
match against uh the Quan Liam in that
when when we're both in time trouble
then he's uh he's playing better than me
much much better
so um that was a bit frustrating there
were some positive sides to it that I I
was always keeping an advantage on the
clock but I sort of thought that would
happen because I noticed from his match
against Magnus that he's very often uh
playing very deliberately at the start
of the game
I actually like I I don't know if it's
just his style or if it's uh
maybe because they've worked together
but he he does remind me as a player in
some ways of uh reshook who also is very
deliberate at the start of the game very
careful methodical again gets into time
trouble but then doesn't seem to
negatively affect him as much as it
might another player so I kind of
expected that I I knew that I would
struggle if we were both down to seconds
and that's what happened
but uh luckily in the fourth game I
managed to keep a very healthy buffer on
the clock
and Fabiano of the players who have
played in both the air things Masters
and the chesso Masters you're the only
player who has not lost a match what is
it about this four matter what's gotten
into you how are you getting this done
well I think that's a little bit too
generous I did I did lose a match to
Alexei Serrano
um which is the reason why I was
relegated to division two
in the in the previous tournament but
besides that I haven't lost a match yet
I mean uh I hope it stays that way it's
it's definitely very difficult I mean
the match yesterday was difficult the
match today was even more difficult
um and I imagine the next match will
will not be any easier at the very least
so it's really tough but
luckily I'm fighting well like if I'm in
different difficult situation then I am
fighting back well my play isn't perfect
but at least my fighting spirit is there
it's amazing player there uh Fabi
especially in the Armageddon we really
loved that moment with queen f8 and now
just looking ahead to tomorrow's match
you will be playing against Hikaru
give us your thoughts on what that's
going to be like
yeah well we've had a lot of experience
against each other we've played so many
games not so many matches but definitely
definitely many many games
um we played over the board matches
stretching back from 2015.
and I also remember a crazy match we
played in the first uh it was like the
first chess 24 Tour event I forgot about
the name of it but it was like the first
event organized in 2020 after uh covet
hit and and chess moved online for uh
for a while it was like the first event
I played after the candidates and I
played hikar in a match and I lost why
don't know I had to win with black on
demand and I won that but then I lost
this tie break
uh so yeah he I mean he's so good
um that's obviously not a revelation to
anyone especially in faster time
controls I mean of course also in
classical but in in these matches he's
um he's self-efficient
and I think it already shows that he got
to the final last time and here he
already won two matches including
against Wesley that in this format he's
really really tough
it's going to be a big fight Bobby and
we are so excited to watch the action
tomorrow congratulations one more time
and good luck for tomorrow
thank you
stays in the Winner's bracket and let's
take a look at the bracket going forward
this is where we are we're gonna see a
big match there with Fabiano taking on
Hikaru James your thoughts on that one
yeah of course uh that's gonna be a
heavyweight matchup as everybody know
All-American heavyweight matchup but uh
Bobby's in and run for his money here I
mean Nakamura is definitely on a tear
here he does this in all the short time
controls he wins everything he streams
eight hours on a Tuesday cleaning up
title Tuesdays is like a bully in a way
now of course this is rapid now and it's
a little bit more time here and Carolina
is definitely capable of doing it but I
don't think he should get in any type of
time trouble against Nakamura here yeah
yeah both players have nerves of Steel
just the way they managed it today
neither really at their best but they
came when it mattered with those
incredible moves Queen f8 I think move
of the tournament move of the years
Robert says I still think nakamura's
slight favorite in this format but uh
yeah Bobby capable of anything I would
agree yeah hikara is playing excellent
chess but my focus is down below look at
Wesley so and Magnus Carlsen one of them
is going to get eliminated in fifth
place these were top three finishers
from the air things Masters but one of
them is going home after tomorrow yeah
one of them will be relegated to play
the play-ins for the next event imagine
Wesley so against Magnus Carlsen that
could be a final in its own right so
tomorrow is for elimination yeah that's
a really big one as well Wesley against
Carson and both of them facing
elimination what are we expecting from
that David
it's gonna go to Armageddon I'll predict
who wins who knows who knows I love it
we always enjoy an Armageddon and that's
what we were treated to today with
Fabiano caruana eventually winning his
match against vladislav or tamiab let's
take a look at also what happened in
division two bracket today some huge
matchups and huge results there not
about the former World rapid Champion
took down Arjun aragassi that was a fun
fight yeah no derbeck is playing
excellent chess he took down a niche
gear yesterday in Arjun era guys today
Dennis lazwick he is a standout he's a
teenager people underestimate him they
don't know about him but he is taking
down duboff and Vincent kheimer back to
back Maxine versus Sherlock three nil
that's a clean sweep he did benefit from
a mouse slip from prognanda in the third
game it was already you know going to be
a win for him in the match but probably
the blunters queen yeah and Maxim and
Vladimir kramnik winning their matches
so experience did win against youth in
that one division three was also on with
some big names the biggest shocker that
Robert Shakira Mahmoud in division three
to start with but he did win the losers
bracket yeah he got a win in the losers
bracket but the day continued it's long
it's you know really long days in
division three uh he took down Alvar
Alonso the Spanish Grandmaster and then
he went on and lost to Wei Yi so
Matthias bluebaum where he they make it
through the lose weight round five of
the losers bracket they played so many
games at this point
so much action division one two three
packed with big names big drama David
what was your biggest takeaway awesome
Italian but the biggest one is that
these players they're Geniuses but
they're also human some mistakes but
also those beautiful moves so I'm going
to go back and study some of those Queen
I think what a blue and uh yeah I'm
hoping for more of the same tomorrow
this is so much fun and that move Queen
f8 I think that's going to be in our
minds for a long time James what did you
enjoy the most well two things here time
management make sure you guys are
managing your time correctly and they
try to work on it as much as you can and
the second thing is do your tactics
queen f8 that was gross that was a nasty
move from Fabi that means that boy does
Tactics every single day hopefully
you're doing yours at home
oh wow some good advice there by James a
so much fun and the drama of course
continues we've got a big winner final
coming up an All-American clash as
Fabiano caruana takes on Hikaru Nakamura
and big matches in the losers bracket as
well once again a big shout out to our
chat thank you so much for joining us
it's been a fun ride calling the action
today for day two of the chessable
Masters we will be back with more
tomorrow same time same place see you
then
thank you
[Music]
foreign
awesome
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]